но на чем-то нормаль все таки тут в моно даймонд привет каши ай-ай-ай-ай-ай-ай-ай-ай так
так видос на звуку а вас супер чудо нормально там может поделать с презентацией я хотела их
побачит а потом же делаю то есть добрый да да да крикну дай тут чекаю но давай-то давай-то
Резинку взяла, все взяла, чтоб волосы все брать.
Я на подготовке. Супер. Я готова.
Я подъеду тех, кто уже ожидает, и будем начинать.
Хорошо. Было много людей вообще? Все приходят или нет?
Вчера было 33, ну, то есть, в общем, их 36 студентов,
2 грантовые места и 34, ну, студентов.
Вчера было 33, сегодня посмотрим, сколько будет.
Добро, это же ранок.
Да.
Так.
доброе утро всем доброго ранечку доброе ранку доброе утро доброе утро и добрый ранок добрый
Ранок. Витаю. Подключайтесь. Хочу на вас поделиться, познакомиться с вами.
Всех витаю. Вы такая красивая. Я не могу сказать вам комплимент. Вы очень красивая.
Спасибо, спасибо. Нарядились, все наилучше для вас одевались, девчата.
И не только девчата. Всех рада видеть.
Очень рада видеть, очень рада. Приединяйтесь все.
Вот, молодцы. Так приятно посмотреть, кто приходит так, как нужно, да, вчасно.
Сразу предупреждаю, я начинаю всегда вот за таймингом.
Насколько могу, сразу все заканчиваю за таймингом.
Это моя особенность.
То есть в 10 часов я буду всегда начинать.
Всех приветствую.
Всех приветствую, приветствую, приветствую.
Сейчас покажу, чем мы будем с вами заниматься и вообще познакомимся.
У нас сегодня должен быть интересный семинар.
Классный.
Смотрите, это тема.
Контракты в транзакционном анализе.
интересно вам такое посмотреть узнать или нет да конечно конечно я очень рада все интересно все
интересно это классно я люблю когда все интересно когда есть люди мотивированные формат общения сразу
мы будем с вами выбирать вот и вы мне все равно как вы к мне обратитесь буду обратиться к вам
так само. Всех витаю. Доброе ранку.
Если есть возможность, включайте камеры.
Я хочу подивиться на вас,
потому что мне просто очень интересно.
Очень интересно подивиться,
с кем я буду общаться.
А кто будет со мной? Меня зовут Влада.
И сейчас мы будем
с вами знакомиться.
Хорошо?
Но
перед тем, как мы начнем,
возможно, вы все один одного
Мы уже немного привыкли к один-одному, или нет еще? Да? Да. Ну, это же первые дни.
Добре. Смотрите, у меня есть всегда одна единая работа. Она позволяет всем собраться, но даже если вы один одного не знаете, давайте начнем с этой маленькой работы.
вы скажете единое, что вам сегодня, что вас может отвлекать от обучения?
Это первое вопрос. Знаете, я говорю, перед тем, как мы начинаем обучаться, всегда нужно выгрозить
все то, что нам мешает. Вот первое вопрос, что мне, возможно, мешало, что у меня накопилось за
за этот тиждень. И что мне поможет? Хорошо, так сможете
делать. Сразу предупреждаю, мы будем всегда миксировать
залы. Но перед началом какого-то своего семинара
лично, я буду вам давать эту работу. Для того, чтобы
вы ко мне пришли с чистой, свежей головой. Все согласны
с этим? Поднимите руку, кто согласен. Нормально, да?
Хорошо. Юля, мне нужна помощь, пожалуйста. Я прошу сейчас
объединять в тройки и одна одни и сказать, что меня сегодня
мешает учиться и что мне поможет, хорошо?
И это все на 10 минут, то есть по три минуты на каждую.
Хорошо, нам нужно 2 минуты, я вас распределяю и 10 минут
будет комната.
На 10 минут комната, потому что знаете, иногда, когда
ты сидишь, вот это думаешь, что меня сегодня мешает,
или мне мешают какие-то отношения, или мой бизнес сегодня мне какую-то проблему принес.
Нужно всегда это выгружать.
Поэтому, пожалуйста, в комнату скажите, один одного просто поддерживайте и возвращайтесь назад.
Юль, я не буду, захотите заходите в сессийную зону, хорошо?
Да, вы можете посетить.
Да, да, если нужно, я всегда к вам приеду.
Двое людей,
которые не заезжали, я вижу.
Это нормально. Просто я думаю, нам нужно всегда некоторое время, чтобы все собрались, чтобы не было так, что кто-то не узнал что-то, что-то не знает, и потом нужно снова, да, про это говорить.
Поэтому я всегда делаю такую интересную работу. Она улучшает обучение. И собираются все, кто не пришел сразу.
Но нужно просто присоединиться в те сессийные залы, которые уже есть.
Давайте посмотрим. Я вас присоединяю тоже в зал.
Они там делают коротенькую практику.
Заходите в пятый зал, я вас додала.
у нас идеально вышли все по трое в залах я ж знаю что по трое
сразу всех объединяем а кто-то потом объединяется это очень
хорошо как раз 10 минут нам достаточно чтобы они все собрались
это хорошо
Юрий, я вас додала до сессийной залы, можете приединиться, они там делают вправо.
Давай к нам, не считай, там у нас до семнадцатого.
Смени свои имена, имя и прозвище, будь ласка.
Мы не знаем, кто до нас приеднался.
Девчата, у нас пока сессийные залы,
залишилась буквально хвилинка,
поэтому я вас уже не доедню и будем продолжать.
Заразь все доходят.
Все дошли.
Доброе. Я вас приветствую. Выгрузили немного информации, что вам мешает? Лучше стало? Доброе.
Найшли, что вас поддерживает? Да? Концентрация есть? Все готовы? Доброе.
Тогда давайте познакомимся. Сегодня у нас тема про контракты.
И начнем с вами познакомиться.
Кстати, кто я такая, посмотрите. Меня зовут Влада Березянська.
У меня очень большой опыт выкладывания и работы.
У меня своя психотерапевтическая практика. Я работаю с ее компанией.
Сертифицирована в Европейской ассоциации транзакционного анализа
и в американские ассоциации.
У меня есть троевысший
учебник, и я кандидат
наук.
Также сертификована в Европе
как транзакционный
психотерапевт.
И проводжу
очень много разных
выкладаний.
У вас должно быть посылание
на мой инстаграм. Подписывайтесь.
Буду очень рада вас
видеть, с вами общаться.
Чи е в вас якісь зараз питання до мене?
Нема.
Добре.
Якщо будуть питання, вы их, будь ласка, задавайте.
Але у нас е деякі правила.
Хочете дізнатися, які?
Цікаво, да?
Будь ласка, піднімайте руку, якщо є питання.
Щоб не було хаосу, да?
Коли всі одразу говорять, я не зможу навіть дати вам відповідь на запитання.
Добре?
Если есть какие-то свои думки, вы их занутовываете себе,
потом можете со мной поделиться или отрефлексировать с группой.
Но сейчас мы начнем знакомиться.
Смотрите, про что вообще этот семинар?
Этот семинар, он не про психотерапию,
А этот семинар я готовила для вас, как для личностей,
которые могут на дальнейшем использовать очень много интересных инструментов,
как в своем жизни, так и с другими.
Было ли у вас когда-то такое чувство, что вы начинаете с кем-то общаться,
и вы не понимаете, куда вам дальше идти?
Было? Было.
Было ли у вас когда-то, не было, это очень круто, что если это не было, а было, сейчас дам вам другое вопрос, когда вы уже поспілковались с кем-то, то есть проговорили что-то, сделали что-то, а потом вам говорят, нет, это не то, что я ожидал или ожидала.
Было и такое, да? Вот сегодня я вас научу, как начинать общаться так, чтобы на конец вашей встречи вам сказали, что это просто супер, мы все сделали очень круто.
И чтобы это не вы показывали другим, о, смотрите, пожалуйста, все хорошо, все хорошо, потому что есть такое чувство неуверенности, когда ты не отвечаешь каким-то ожиданиям, потому что мы их не доверили.
А чтобы вы шли с гордостью, поднятою головой, думали, это я. Я бы очень круто все сделала. Я очень круто. Я удовлетворена самостоятельно. Мне это очень нравится.
Хотите так? Я думаю, это очень легко сделать. Сейчас покажу, как это мы будем делать. Очень рада.
Пожалуйста, отвечайте, я люблю очень общаться с всеми, я открыта к этому общению.
Что мы будем делать? Какой у нас план на сегодня?
Контракт как наша стратегия, как лидера.
Контракт как инструмент.
Какие вообще есть контракты?
Даже такое слово, оно как-то такое, немного юридическое, контракты.
но какие есть типы этих контрактов, какая есть культура,
как можно быть и сильным, и гнучким, и как можно вплывать через контракты.
То, что мы будем исследовать.
Мне очень нравится фраза Марка Виндоуса.
Он сказал, что контракт – это не только про достижение результата.
Это больше большое расширение возможностей быть в контакте с собой, с другими, с целями бизнеса.
Потому что, когда мы говорим только о контракте, как будто в этом есть что-то механическое.
Но когда мы начинаем создавать бизнес или общаться с кем-то, нам нужно установить и контакт.
Для того, чтобы наш бизнес, он имел под собой энергию,
общение, контактность и дошел до той цели, которую мы себе запланировали.
Это очень хорошо.
Идем дальше.
Все-таки мы должны познакомиться с вами, да?
Как мы до этого дойдем? Я вам расскажу, что такое контракт в транзакционном анализе. Мы поговорим о том, что это больше, чем только термин или договоренность.
Вы сможете посмотреть авторские модели, вы можете посмотреть какие-то команды, вы будете очень-очень много саморефлексировать.
Если у вас есть какие-то думки, пожалуйста, записывайте, занотовывайте для себя это все, это очень классно.
И вы начнете сейчас понимать, что контракт – это что-то живое.
Это то, что мы можем изменивать один с одним.
И это то, что, когда происходит эта изменка, это то, что приведет вас к результату.
И контракт – это не только то, как вы договорились,
А это то, что вы привнесете с собой, как эту договоренность.
Но вам нужно понять, какая у нас будет структура семинара.
Есть ли такие люди, которые волнуются, когда не понимают, что мы будем делать,
когда мы пойдем на отдых, или мы пьем чай, или мы не пьем чай.
Да, есть такие.
Поэтому смотрите, есть слайд, где есть структура нашего семинара «Организационная».
То есть мы работаем три блоки.
Пожалуйста, сделайте себе скриншот или где-то занотуйте с 10 до 12.30.
Это первый блок, потом у нас есть перерыв, потом у нас второй блок, 15 минут перерыва.
И мы заканчиваем в 16.45.
Я буду заканчивать вчасно.
Но буду оставить вам время на вопросы.
У нас есть некоторые правила.
Сразу их покажу.
И потом на минутку выключу и запитаю, что вы согласны с этим.
Хорошо?
Головное правило на конфиденциальность.
Все, что говорится, проговаривается тут,
залишается только в группе.
На минуту остановлю.
Давайте.
Все согласны с этим?
Кто согласен, пожалуйста, можно руку поднять.
Кто не согласен, пожалуйста, сразу прошу.
Это про небезопасность своего пространства.
Можно позвонить?
Минуту.
Сейчас закончу, да, и сразу вопрос.
Конфиденциальность – это безопасность.
Хорошо? Хорошо.
София, слушаю вас.
Прошу прощения, прибыла к вам.
Вопрос, можно ли вас выставлять в сторис,
потому что это также про конфиденциальность,
и вообще снимать с боку, что происходит?
Я думаю, что тут нужно снимать себя.
Да, меня можно снимать, для меня это окей.
Но рассказать о кейсах, о чувстве, о эмоциях, о том, что происходит здесь, я думаю, это просто будет опасно для всех.
Потому что я буду давать вам очень много вправ, очень много, да, вы будете один с одним, ну, рассказать какие-то интересные вещи,
которые есть о вашей личной, возможно, жизни, о вашем бизнесе, о том, что для вас главное, насколько это безопасно.
Поэтому, пожалуйста, больше следуйте, София, о том, сколько вас там есть, да, и нужно брать разрешение, кто там не против. Я лично не против, но если вы с кем-то общаетесь, спросите, пожалуйста, как они к этому относятся.
Чи це окей для усіх? Це нормально? Я дуже-дуже пиклуюся про безпеку, бо коли немає цієї безпеки в групе, мы боимся раскрыватися.
А я з вами буду 10 месяцев, чи 11 месяцев, и мне потребна нормальная, здоровая атмосфера, чтобы вы меня не боялись, чтобы не боялись и не думали, что сейчас все будут знать.
Доброе. Договорились? Класс. То есть конфиденциальность. Сейчас верну сразу, чтобы никто не сказал, Влада, я этого не видела. Это для меня какой-то ноу-хау. Доброе? Доброе. Смотрите. Сейчас вернусь назад до своего слайда. Все проговорю.
Камеры, пожалуйста, я вас очень прошу, для меня так важно видеть вас.
Я люблю смотреть на тех, кто к мне пришел.
Вы мои гении, вы мои инноваторы.
Поэтому я люблю смотреть на людей, потому что, знаете,
когда ты сам собой рефлексуешь и сам себе что-то рассказываешь,
и никого нет, ой, это меня так как-то сумоет.
Нет этих очей, ваших очей.
Поэтому, пожалуйста, включайте камеры.
Турбота про себя и про других.
Т.е. телефоны выключайте, звук выключите, все выключите то, что может Вас отвлекать или отвлекать кого-то другого.
Я вижу, что все пришли в хорошем настроении и все находятся как нужно, как должно быть на обучении.
Пожалуйста, когда Ваши камеры выключены, следуйте за тем, чтобы не было чего-то такого Вашего личного в камере.
Это очень важно, потому что мы все будем смотреть за вашим личным жизнью.
Что я имею в виду?
Да?
Пожалуйста, не ходите в голени, такое бывает в жизни.
Чего вы смеетесь? Знаете, сколько у меня лет выкладывания, а что я только не видела?
Пожалуйста, очень вас прошу, это действительно офигенно, это круто.
Не нужно заходить в ванную комнату и принимать ванну во время обучения. И такое было.
Я знаю, что вы очень понятны, но я просто рассказываю, чего делать не нужно.
Можно сидеть, можно пить чай, можно пить кофе, можно, когда нет интернета, можно быть с выключенной камерой.
Да, я адекватная женщина, я все нормально понимаю.
Но, пожалуйста, можно, если у кого-то есть дети, но кто-то там зашел,
муж зашел поцеловать, обнять, это окей, это нормально.
Но будьте в контакте просто с нами, хорошо?
И следуйте за тем, чтобы мы были все в безопасном пространстве.
То есть это ваша ответственность.
Чай пейте, водичку пейте, печенье можно перекусить.
Но сделать ланч перед всеми нами, пожалуйста, не делайте,
потому что я захочу приезжать к вам в гости и буду есть вместе с вами.
Я когда голодная, я иногда не могу в море.
Договорились? Это окей для всех?
Нормально? Дам как-то руку.
О, супер, супер, мы уже договорились про это.
Так, что еще у нас должно быть за контрактом?
Давайте посмотрим.
Понимаете одно, я приезжаю вчасно.
Когда вас нет, это не проблема.
Я с вами уже начинаю общаться, то есть, если вы волнуетесь, чтобы у вас был весь семинар, приходите вовремя.
Эмоции будут, это нормально, нотуйте свои эмоции.
Какие-то могут подняться ощущения, почувствия, что-то может на поверхню подняться, поэтому занотуйте это себе.
Иногда, иногда есть ожидания от обучения, что вы сразу получаете и психотерапию, и обучение, и супервизию.
Это наилучшее ожидание каждого студента. Я это знаю. Вы обучали группы.
Я могу ответить на какие-то вопросы относительно вашей работы, но у вас есть супервизия.
Я смотрела, за раскладом у вас есть супервизия.
Добре? Туда выносите это все.
Если что-то такое, вот хочу узнать, запытайте, запытайте.
К сожалению, мне можно задавать любые вопросы.
Любые вопросы. Почему?
И никогда не боитесь задавать вопросы.
Есть иногда такой состояние, когда я помолчу немного,
может, дурное вопрос.
У меня тут есть со-тренер.
Сразу, да, понимаете.
Он здесь со мной, может иногда нам мешать, гавкать, но, извиняюсь, не может его выгнать из комнаты.
Поэтому, когда вы задаете вопросы, не боитесь быть дурными.
Все вопросы классные. Если я не знаю ответа на ваши вопросы, я скажу, я пойду подумаю и дам вам ответ в следующий раз.
Будьте открыты к обучению. Я люблю коммуникацию, здоровую коммуникацию, с уважением один к одному.
Поэтому, если что-то интересует, запитайте.
Окей? Добре?
Почему я так люблю?
Потому что, если вы что-то не понимаете, вы не будете учиться дальше.
Если для вас какое-то слово не понятное, вы не будете понимать дальше материал.
Поэтому, если что-то не поняли, спрашивайте. Договорились?
Если нужна будет какая-то помощь в момент, когда вы работаете в залах,
мы будем миксировать завжди залы, чтобы вы больше познакомились.
«Зведь мене».
«Відносно формату спілкування».
«До мене можна звертатися на ты, на вы, як вам зручно».
«Як ви до мене звертаетеся, так я буду до вас і відповідати».
«Для мене окей на ты, але якщо багато людей не звыкло, на ты можна і на вы».
«Для мене все це ок».
«Добре?»
«Добре».
В группе также попросите, как вам лучше общаться один с одним.
Для меня это только все о безопасности.
У вас есть какие-то вопросы ко мне?
Нет? Никаких?
Все понял?
А, вопросов нет. Это классно. Очень классно.
Сейчас я посмотрю.
Так, что-то у нас было интересного. Буду смотреться и в чат.
Так, без камеры можно... А, еще!
Слушайте, очень важная информация о тех, кто находится в Украине.
Это про безопасность, пожалуйста.
Если есть поветренная тревога, и вы чувствуете, что вы где-то, там, где может что-то быть,
Для меня самое лучшее, чтобы вы про себя попеклевались.
Можете и, пожалуйста, сразу выходите из нашей зоны и идите сохранить себя.
Для меня самое важное, если вы сами, если у вас есть дети,
если вам нужно с родиной пойти куда-то, и вы чувствуете, что вы в небезопасности,
безопасность первое за все.
Чи ви окей до цього?
Бо іноді бува так, хто хтось залишається, потім шипки летят і всі схвилювані.
Добре, давайте так не будемо робити, бо багато чого бачила за цей час навчання.
Я вас дуже прошу.
Найперше, це безпека ваша особиста і вашої родины.
Добре?
Домовилась, про все рассказала.
Еще, относительно общения и языка.
Я буду отвечать на вас тем языком, которым вы задаете мне вопросы.
Хорошо. Российский, украинский, я открытая к любому языку, общаюсь и так, и так.
Иногда, иногда, я сразу предупреждаю,
много лет я выкладывала российский язык транзакционный анализ,
иногда мне нужно будет время на адаптацию относительно термина.
Но я уже, как будто, привыкла говорить на украинском языке.
Для всех это все ок?
Да?
Супер.
Вопросов уже нет.
Все согласны?
Начинаем.
Да.
Что у нас дальше? Давайте посмотрим.
Конфиденциальность мы с вами проговорили. Сейчас.
Первое упражнение.
Сядьте удобно, выдыхайте и сформулируйте, пожалуйста, ответ.
«Навище я тут?»
И побудьте в этом процессе, в тиши.
Занотовали?
Так, Оля, вижу, да, плохой интернет.
Я поняла, да, можете отваливаться.
Все, я поняла.
Я окей до всего интернета.
Так, Бова.
Сейчас не всегда классный интернет.
Вы занотовали себе,
почему я тут?
Смотрите, у меня есть одна особенность.
Но я вас научу ее.
Она очень классная, и вам будет до вподобия.
Смотрите на то, что вы написали,
и сформуйте это одним речением.
Дайте мне суть.
Сформировали?
Добре, теперь обогрейте. Одно слово.
Одно слово, но ваше, особенное.
Скажите мне, кто хочет это одно слово, почему я тут?
Так, Снежан, слухаю.
Чудово вправо.
Впевненность.
Далее.
Лера.
Инвестиция.
Круто, сгодно.
София.
Глубина.
Глубина, супер.
Анна.
Учиться.
Учиться, замечательно, это очень хорошо.
Юля.
Рист.
Рист, Растаня, супер, круто.
Ульяна.
Собили.
Стабильность. Это просто супер.
Так, далее у меня Анна.
Допомога.
Допомога, да. Супер. Юля?
Знания.
Знания. Таня?
Ценность.
Ценность. Супер. Наталья?
Структура.
Структура. Круто.
Видите, у каждого из вас есть свое особое слово.
И я вас научу говорить Янко и по сути.
Я всегда люблю, когда мне говорят,
або одно реченье, потому что нас забагато,
и мы не можем делать большие рефлексии,
або только одно слово.
И это не означает, что это про просто,
это про вашу особистую глубину.
Сделать все Янко и за одно слово
передать информацию другим.
Для чего вы тут?
Так, эрудиция, бренд, структура, призначение, легкость, суперпрофессионализм, суперпрофессионально.
Так, это очень круто, очень круто.
Развиток, возраст, расширение. Вау, все.
Буду смотреть в чате, еще нам говорить про то, что у нас есть и чем мы будем заниматься дальше.
А сейчас переходим к следующему.
Познакомьтесь.
познайомиться. Дайте, пожалуйста, ответ на такие вопросы. Кто я для себя и для других?
Кто я? Не почему я тут, а кто я? То есть давайте познакомиться.
Какое вопрос больше всего вас, знаете, как волнует или находится где-то внутри, в глубине?
И самое главное, что вы ожидаете от меня, как лучший результат нашей сотрудничества?
Занотовали?
Еще одна
хвилинка на закинчение.
Алена, я извиняюсь, а вы можете слайд вернуть? Да, да, сейчас смогу, смогу, пожалуйста, верну.
Кто я? Какие вопросы меня больше всего волнуют?
Какие ожидания у вас от меня, чтобы вы хотели получить самое от меня, как наилучший результат?
Если ничего не беспокоит, это замечательно, я люблю.
Если ничего не беспокоит, можно так и сказать, что мне ничего не беспокоит, это замечательно.
Всё окей, всё хорошо.
Единственное, что, Александра, у меня есть одна просьба.
Пожалуйста, подумайте, что бы вы хотели получить от меня
как наилучший результат нашего взаимодействия.
А я себе это всё запишу, а потом буду сверять ориентиры.
Знания, опыт, которые экономят года.
Хорошая идея, класс.
Беру себе.
Так, Лера, Валерия, кто-то мне тут сказал, что руку подняли.
Буду прям тезово. Кто я для себя и для других? Одним словом, ураган и, возможно, с временем донесу, почему именно. Это моя личная метафора.
Какое вопрос на сегодня наиболее мощный?
Вы, правда, и я, ожидания и своих, и тех людей, которые в меня поверили.
И какой вопрос к вам?
Понять и влюбиться в глубину транзактного анализа,
потому что это новое для меня и важно действительно так влюблено и жадно получать знания.
Круто, круто. Это очень интересно, кстати, относительно транзакционного анализа. Кто-то когда-то его видел раньше?
Знал его? Нет? Я вам потом расскажу этот опыт, это интересно. Нет, нет, я рада, я рада, что я буду вас проводить по этим дебрям,
потому что я не знаю, как это назвать, это очень интересно, очень классная наука. София, слушаю.
У меня как раз вопрос к этому, потому что, знаете, когда мы говорим о определенных ожиданиях, то нужно понимать, что тут вообще будет, а я даже не понимаю, что тут будет именно с вами, знаете, то есть какая ваша специфика и чего ожидать, ничего не ожидать, знаете, принимаю глубину и, наверное, знаете, чего я ожидаю, все-таки для себя новую информацию, которая сможет помочь мне в работе с клиентами, но что конкретно, я пока не знаю.
Доброе, доброе, тогда начнем сначала еще, да, у кого-то есть еще какие-то ожидания, потом можете сказать, я так поняла, вы не знаете, что это за слово транзакционный анализ или транзакционный анализ, не знаете, да?
А кто знает, кто не знает, доброе. Слушайте, читали ли вы когда-то книгу «Люди, которые играют в игры, игры, в которые играют люди», да?
Читали? Это супер. Это книжка Эрика Бёрна. Он основоположник. А, вкус, это и любимая книга, да? Это интересная книга о том, как мы взаимодействуем один с одним.
Чи хтось зрозумів теоретичний матеріял цієї книги, хто читав спочатку?
Я не знаю, хто там читав. Не зрозумів.
Вот дивіться, давайте я почну, мабуть, з історії своєї, да?
Спочатку ні, да, спочатку це був якийсь треш.
Дивіться, багато років тому я сиділа і думала, чому люди спілкуються так один з одним?
Шо це взагалі таке гра?
Я не розуміла, шо за гра, шо воно має бути?
Там все сказали, что я такая интересная, мотивационная, стильная на учении, я транзакционный анализ.
Я вам говорю отвертую, это слово транзакционный анализ, знаете, сколько я себе дала времени, чтобы его выучить, чтобы понять, что это означает.
И открыла первый раз книжку, потому что все сказали, что это такая классная наука, так все интересно.
И открываю, я ничего не понимаю.
Закрыла книжку, походила немножко.
Пришла, послушала аудиокнижку. Думаю, что за эго-станы? Что это такое вообще? Я не понимала, где эго-станы, что это за эго-стан, что это вообще такое, даже не смогла уявить.
А это основная концепция, потому что транзакционный анализ, он изучает мотивацию, почему люди делают то, что нам нужно. Он изучает личность, личность других людей, как они, с чем они взаимодействуют.
Он изучает поведение других людей. Это очень крутой метод психотерапии или поддержки, но он не выглядит так, как у Фрейда, мы все отдыхаем на диване и рефлексируем, а это про структуру, про понимание, про поведение, про использование в практике.
То есть это то, что вы можете использовать, как в организации есть, то, что вы можете использовать в особой терапии, потому что это действительно психотерапевтический метод изменения личности.
И это то, что вы можете использовать и понимать в личной жизни.
Для меня транзакционный анализ – это как компас, карта.
Вы видите людей, или было у вас так, чтобы с одними людьми вы себя чувствовали неуверенными?
Вот кто-то зашел, и вы сразу, ой, как будто я хорошая и разумная, да, и хорошая и разумная,
но что-то как-то мне дискомфортно. Было у вас так?
Это все изучает транзакционный анализ.
То есть вы сможете получить структуру, разобраться, куда вам дальше идти и чем вам дальше заниматься.
Но когда я увидела эту книгу, я поняла, что что-то здесь очень сложно написано.
И действительно, Эрик Берн писал очень сложно.
Потом я начала изучать транзакционный анализ, потому что это интересный комьюнити.
И есть свои организации, как в Европе.
Так и в Америке. И между этими организациями существует единственная стратегия, единственное правило принимания экзаменов у студентов.
То есть то, что валидно в Европе, так само валидно в Америке.
Если ты приходишь в эту сертификацию в Европе, ты можешь так же, будучи в Америке, написать, что ты сертификованный транзактный аналитик.
Есть четыре сферы, где используется этот транзакционный анализ.
Я сертификована психотерапией.
Если сказать честно, это наибольший путь, потому что 4 года учат в будущих психотерапевтах. Я выпустила в этом году 2 группы психотерапевтов, они 4 года учили транзакционный анализ, чтобы изменить личность других людей, помогать им в жизни.
Есть транзакционный анализ в организациях, и у нас будет также акцент на бизнес, на вашу
личность, мы будем отзывы много чего брать. Есть в консультации и есть в обучении.
И эта наука, транзакционный анализ, она объединяет теорию мотивации, теорию личности, циклы
развития людей, то есть, как мы
взрослеем, как это приходит к тому, что
мы именно такие, какие есть, и
он изучает сценарий.
Что такое сценарий?
Мы будем с вами эти темы проходить,
они интересны.
Это ваш особенный план жизни,
который вы придумали
до шести лет,
а потом забыли,
Когда вы были в подростковом возрасте, его немного отредактировали.
Хорошо. И так жили.
Когда я встречаю клиента, используя только вопросы, я могу понять, с чего началось его жизнь и чем оно закончится.
И это не означает, что я какая-то гадалка или делаю расклады. Я использую просто психотерапию.
То есть это такой очень классный инструмент, то есть это не то, что мы можем предбачить,
знаете, там посмотреть на метафорические карты или предсказать, или почувствовать, да, по своей интуиции.
Это вопрос-ответ, вопрос-ответ, вопрос-ответ, и у вас есть существенно хорошая интересная картина про вас и ваших клиентов.
И я более понятно вам объяснила, что такое транзакционный анализ.
Нормально заходит?
До речи, он очень сложный.
Но у меня есть однособистость.
Когда я изучала транзакционный анализ, я такая же, как и вы.
Я не понимала эти все термины сразу.
Я подумала, боже, что они говорят?
Что они вообще говорят?
Знаете, я не люблю, когда начинается настолько много такой сложной теории,
потому что люди любят выглядеть разумными,
но так, чтобы другие их не понимали.
Ну, вы знаете, да, такие у нас есть выкладочи,
кто учился где-то в универе, все такие разумные.
Все что-то так скажут, а ты потом сидишь и рефлексуешь,
и думаешь, что ты сказал, что ты мне хочешь донести.
то я сказала, я буду делать и выкладывать транзакционный анализ легко.
Так, чтобы все все понимали.
Чтобы не было чувства, как будто ты сидишь, и ты такой какой-то неразумный,
и ты какой-то такой дурный, если сказать, да, вот это такое чувство, да,
потому что ты какой-то не такой, ты не понимаешь, про что там вообще в этих концепциях говорят.
Поэтому я для себя поняла, что это мой личный стиль выкладывания
говорить про очень сложные вещи очень просто.
Я это обожаю.
И я считаю, что это, знаете, все должно быть в простоте.
И вы будете смотреть на то, что я делаю, сложные вещи, и вас научу очень простыми.
Потому что мне всегда говорят, слушай, Влада, а как это, а как это ты даешь такую работу, она такая легкая, как я не додумался до нее. Я говорю, потому что я много лет училась, поэтому я вам передам с удовольствием все эти знания, идите используйте, если будут какие-то вопросы, нотатки, что-то себе нотуйте, всегда заплатите.
И никогда не бояться быть дурными, да, потому что сначала, когда мы начинаем встанавливать контакты один с одним, мы так боимся как-то проявиться, ну, недосконально.
Я вообще не люблю доскональность, честно вам говорю. Я не люблю эти маски, которые мы надеваем, да, когда мы говорим, что я такая разумная, или я такая, или я такая разумная, или у меня все хорошо.
это неправда, в нашем жизни бывает и хорошо, и плохо, поэтому я вас приглашаю общаться здесь, в этом
пространстве со мной без масок, хорошо? И задавать нормальные все вопросы. Всех принимаю, всех
понимаю, все кордоны уважаю, но научу вас делать это легко. Хорошо? Хорошо. Сейчас вы себе там
занотовали, какие у вас есть
ожидания.
Поэтому, пожалуйста, перепишите, какие у вас
есть ожидания от меня.
Я хочу занотовать себе свои
контракты, знаете, то, что вы хотите
отрабатывать от меня.
И если можно, напишите
мне, пожалуйста, это все в чат.
А потом я вас
соединю, попрошу, Юль,
мне нужна ваша помощь
соединять в группы
по четыре человека
и на 8 минут, смотрите, у меня будет с вами очень много упражнений, они будут такие, знаете, экспрессовые,
вот вам нужно за 2 минуты сказать, кто вы, про что думаете и ожидания.
Снежан, если не знаете, да, я потом буду объяснять, я буду давать такие, ну, больше информации про это,
Буду просто говорить. Собе занотуйте, что, в целом, хотелось бы получить. Новый досмот, удовольствие от общения. О, я люблю удовольствие.
Так, далее.
8 минут и начинать. Можем продолжать?
Начинаем, начинаем.
Юлечка, Юль.
Да, да, я тут.
Меня всегда кидают в зале, а потом мне всегда пишут, кто меня ждет в зале.
Да, я вас просто... Ну, я, чтобы быстренько распределить, то я не замечаю, что у вас ваше имя, и закидываю. А вы не соединяетесь, если у вас...
А я не соединяюсь. У меня такая самая Янгелина, она меня всегда также закидывает, и я не соединяюсь.
Но мне всегда она сейчас пишет, кто меня там ждет.
Хорошо, буду стараться вас не соединять в следующий раз.
Просто соединяйте меня, хорошо?
Да.
Надо было сразу объяснить про транзакционный анализ. Я думаю, нужно добавить эту информацию, она будет больше важна.
Да, можешь подробно. Про курс.
Потому что нет, нет понимания, что они получают.
До речи, да, можем это добавить.
Это нужно добавить, да, то есть, я думаю, это с точки зрения методологии
нужно добавить по всем курсам.
Сразу нужно занотовать это, добавить, да, почему вам это нужно.
Я думала просто, когда мы начнем, ну, это была одна моя гипотеза,
изучать транзакционный анализ, больше объяснить, что это такое, да,
потому что они не понимают, что это такое, это нормально.
Не все видят это и не знали этот направление.
Но нужно это все сделать, это все объяснить
и показать людям, в чем есть ценность.
Метод, он действительно очень крутой,
и он используется в всех направлениях.
То есть ты изучаешь одну и ту же структуру,
а можешь идти работать и психотерапевтом, и консультантом,
и в организациях, и в школе.
Очень широкий такой аспект.
Поэтому нужно будет больше
сейчас сделать акцент на этом,
что это такое,
почему оно им нужно.
Сейчас я посмотрю, знаете,
что у меня есть презентация
относительно транзакционного анализа
101 курса.
Сейчас я смотрю одним очком.
Возможно, один слайд
из-за этого использовать важный.
Зараз, девчата.
Вот, нашла 101 курс.
Но у меня, к сожалению, презентация русской языкой.
Давайте, возможно, мы подумаем и на следующую лекцию это добавим.
Они не будут понимать, проблема в том, что они не понимают, почему это все.
Я думаю, ничего страшного.
Не страшно, да? Привет, привет.
Если объяснить, сначала это лучше сделать, это действительно очень важная тема,
раскрыть им ценность, потому что я каждому рассказала,
что такое транзакционный анализ, с чем мы будем работать,
Но так, как вы, я это не сделаю.
Вы не сделаете. Давайте так.
Смотрите, девчата, что у меня есть.
Я сразу вам показываю. У меня есть
начало 101 курса.
И он действительно
очень офигенный.
То, что мы будем изучать.
Смотрите. То есть, есть
ценности, которые приносит этот метод.
Есть история
развития. Это я проговорю.
Но вот это главное. То есть, структура
человека. Почему люди
что-то делают. Это то, что
мы должны дать им в первый год обучения, или если у нас есть эта наша программа, ту Настю,
которую мы подтвердили, нужно показать им. Если есть возможность, давайте ее сейчас выведем на слайд
основные, чтобы они понимали, что мы должны делать.
А как мы ее выведем на слайд сейчас?
А додать, а додать, а додать, а додать, например, если мы посмотрим.
Сейчас я, знаете, что сделаю? Я ее закину в наш чат.
Или вы закиньте ее в чат, а я ее объясню.
Давай.
Хорошо?
Чтобы они поняли, куда мы идем, потому что мне очень жаль, что они не будут понимать, чем мы вообще будем заниматься, они не будут понимать ценность.
Познакомились? Нормально? Комфортно, некомфортно? Звыкаете? Звыкаете.
Будет очень много миксовать, познакомитесь все, будет у вас интересная своя комьюнити, когда вы один за одним общаетесь.
Хорошо. Я подумала о том, что если вы не понимаете, в чем ценность транзакционного анализа,
сейчас мы договорились с организаторами, чтобы вы вообще увидели программу и поняли, что мы будем с вами делать.
И тогда, если у вас будут вопросы, вы поймете и сможете мне их задать.
Настя, вышло закинуть в чат информацию по нашей программе?
Да, смотрите в нашем чате.
Пожалуйста, открывайте чат. Я также его открываю.
Но я пока не вижу.
Да, Настя, пока нет.
Нет, Настя.
Я вам сейчас очень быстро объясню, что там должно быть.
Взагалі наш план работы на рік.
Ага, закинули в наш чат в Телеграме, Анастасия скинула.
Да, есть в Телеграме.
Так.
Значит, сейчас мы сделаем таким образом.
Я вам тоже надсилаю, Влада, сейчас вам надсилаю.
А в этот чат? Я это уже увидела.
Давайте я сюда также перешлю.
Давайте сюда также. Вот этот кусочек, да, то есть там техники вековой регрессии, на этом остановим.
начинается с у меня есть уведомления тут семинар контакты в транзакционном
анализе вот этот кусочек так да это первый первый абзац
из загальный чат сможете да сможет давайте мы и помещается дякую
тут есть вступ с у меня интеракция на все досягнение ося поведомления я не даст на
c значит будет тут я зараз вам все роботов все показывать и все что мы будем мы работы
Зачекайте одну минуточку, я вам где-то покажу и где-то расскажу наши планы.
Тут я не вижу.
Хорошо, хорошо, сейчас я все сделаю.
Ловите, студенты, я сделала.
Видите? Начинаем.
Смотрите, у нас будет много тем, интересных тем, выбрала лучшие.
О чем мы будем говорить сегодня?
Про контракты, то есть, как установить контакты, контракт с другой человеком и как достигнуть цели.
То есть, сначала, как мы встретились и сравнить с конец, как мы оставили один с одним и чтобы быть в этой стратегии вин-вин.
Далее, теория личности.
Помните, я вам говорила, говорили какие-то про эго, станы, да, что это такое, а это, ну, для меня это было когда-то неизвестно. Что это за теория личности?
Возможно, вы когда-то слышали, есть три станы. Российской языкой 100% слышали. Родитель, взрослый и ребенок.
Гении, я вижу, как они взбирали гению. Девчонки, это просто невероятно.
Украинской языком это «батько», «дорослый» и «маленький». Вот мы об этом будем говорить в следующий раз,
когда встретимся. Далее поговорим о теории коммуникации, то есть как мы один с одним
общаемся, какие есть транзакции. Транзакции — это как мы общаемся один с одним так, чтобы нам было
либо хорошо, либо плохо. И вы понимаете, когда кто-то на вас приехал или сказал вам что-то неприятное,
И вы думаете, что я могла ответить, что я могла сказать.
Вы понимаете, что сразу нужно ответить, что нужно сказать.
Как пересекать вообще тех людей, которые к вам не очень хорошо обратились.
Хорошо, но это так сделать с уважением.
С уважением.
Как должен получать в бизнесе этот контракт, то есть про кордоны.
Далее мы поговорим про мотивацию.
в чем люди и как вам
замотивировать команду себя и
других для того, чтобы они дошли
к мечте.
Видели ли вы когда-то, например,
SEO-компания, которая
говорит, я сказал
так делать.
Я сказал так делать.
Почему вы так не делаете?
Было у вас так?
Ну, хорошо, один раз сделали,
полгода сделали,
а год потом все умерли.
И SEO говорит,
Я же говорю вам, делайте, делайте так, а вы сейчас не работаете.
Я вам покажу, как сделать так, чтобы вся команда работала на вас.
Знаете, у меня всегда говорят и спрашивают руководители там,
Влад, а объясни мне, а что меня, слушай, что-то я, может быть, не допишу,
что-то они меня не делают, что-то не оправдают мои ожидания.
То я научу вас, как сказать другим людям,
или как научить бизнес общаться таким образом,
Да, чтобы они не освободились потом, не сделали себе там, ну, иногда из-за того, как все разговаривают,
потому что иногда, когда я смотрю на руководителей, знаете, у меня такие ощущения, что, может быть, ну, я понимаю, то бизнес, то деньги, то все такое,
Но есть эти отношения, и я вас научу, как мотивировать других людей так, чтобы они работали с вами в кайфе, в удовольствии, делали еще больше.
Хорошо? Это же интересно, на мой взгляд, чтобы они еще не освободились все.
Что мы будем говорить? Там классная история про игры. Игры в работе, в коммуникации, в жизни.
Например, почему что-то там не складывается, почему что-то идет не так.
Например, были ли у вас такие друзья, или кто-то, кто сказал,
«О, у меня такое жизнь, тяжелая».
Да?
Ну, как будто все нормально, все хорошо, а вот они приходят,
и ты хочешь попить каву, или водички попить, поспорить с ними,
а они всегда «все плохо, все очень тяжело».
Вот когда и так кто-то делает, снова и снова, это называется игрой бедняжка.
То есть люди привыкли, что их жалеют.
А жаль, что не есть любовь.
То я научу, как не играть в такие игры.
Добре? Это же интересно, да?
Я думаю, это очень круто.
Я вам покажу, какие есть игры, какие есть игры в бизнесе, какие есть игры в родине.
Почему мы общаемся, я не знаю, на вечер начинаем,
свариться с любимцами,
почему мы, ну, вообще,
почему мы свариваемся с другими людьми, да,
и почему это мы делаем.
Знаете, почему?
Чтобы получать внимание.
Люди играют в игры,
потому что они хотят очень много внимания.
А я вас научу,
как не играть в игры,
не свариться с другими,
а как получить то, что вы хотите,
без сварки.
Это же классно?
Классно, да?
и как это получить от компании.
Далее, симбиоз, то есть, когда у нас какие-то нездоровые отношения.
Вот это мне так интересно, это в бизнесе, знаете,
когда руководитель говорит, так, сделайте вот это, вот это, вот это,
или даже в жизни, вы говорите, сделайте вот это, вот это, вот это, вот это,
и вы не можете дочекаться, до того, как люди сделают это.
И через одну минуту уже вижу, волосы развиваются,
И вы бежите и делаете это за других. Было так?
Потому что они что-то делают не так, как вы захотели.
Я вам покажу, что смешно, да, Лера?
Мне так же смешно, потому что волосы развиваются.
Нет, не так, оно не так.
Как не створить симбиоз, а как дойти до автономности?
Потому что вообще лучшая цель транзакционного анализа – это развить свою личную автономность.
Автономность это не означает, что я там все независимая, и вы мне все не нужны.
Автономность это когда я понимаю, кто я такая, кто я такой, и что я хочу отрабатывать далее.
И нормально общаюсь с другими людьми.
Вот такие у нас будут темы с транзакционным анализом.
А еще поговорим про сценарий.
То есть вы увидите, какие есть сценарии.
Например, сценарий с бизнесом, тоже очень интересный.
Стив Джобс.
Заработал много денег
Сделал, да?
Сделал большие корпорации
Умер
Передчасно
Чьи это сценарии победителей?
Ну, да, не очень
Не очень, потому что когда я достигла цели «померла», это совсем не про победу, то я научу,
как вам не умирать, а жить, хорошо? То есть сценарий он-он и для себя и для других.
Интересные темы? Нормально? Подходит? Немного поняли, что такое транзакционный анализ?
Супер.
Тогда начинаем учиться.
Готовы все.
Будем делать упражнения, будем изучать.
Сейчас начнем с контрактов.
Про то, что я вам уже сказала, как это должно быть.
Сейчас, минутку.
Идем дальше.
Смотрите, вы уже начали думать о том, кто я такой, какие у меня вопросы и что я хочу отрабатывать от нашей сотрудничества.
Почему нам нужны контракты?
Для того, чтобы знать, куда идти.
Сейчас, пожалуйста, дайте ответ, дополняйте те вопросы, которые вы уже начали изучать.
Как я могу саботировать или гальмовать свой личный развитие?
Потому что у каждого из нас есть история, когда мы гальмуем что-то.
Как вчера слышала кейс у одной клиенты, она говорит мне, слушает, я хочу этой цели, но я не понимаю, почему я туда не дохожу.
То есть, как вы сами себя можете гальмовать на достижение вашей цели?
Занотуйте, пожалуйста.
Например, очень поспешаю, переключаю внимание, думаю, что это уже неважно, думаю, что другие сделают лучше, думаю, что это не на часе.
Я не знаю, кто там что думает, но свое, особенное, пожалуйста, занотуйте.
Далее, когда, почему так происходит, хотите я вам расскажу?
Вот завжди запомните, это классно для вас и для бизнеса.
Мы себе запрограммировали какую-то мету.
И мы начинаем, идем, идем, идем, и тут в одном кроке до успеха провал.
Провал. Что-то идет уже не так.
Почему?
Потому что у каждого из нас, представьте, есть свой личный скафандр,
который мы надевали на себя.
И он формирует нашу личность.
И иногда очень страшно снимать этот скафандр и остаться голым.
А другого скафандра мы еще не нашли.
Поэтому есть скафандр, или платье, если тут есть женщины,
или, я не знаю, там, сурочка, переможца.
Мы вдягнули, мы уже, например, находимся в каком-то своем скафандре,
из него выросли, он уже рвется,
но мы говорим, нет, это же мое, это же улюбленное,
не буду я достигать этой цели, и что-то меня остановит.
То вот всегда в шаг от успеха наступает такой состояние,
что у меня что-то не выходит.
Например, повышение цены своих услуг,
или, как Сео говорит, у меня есть этот потолок.
Вот до этого дошел, дальше не иду.
То нужно снимать старое, даже когда тебе очень больно.
Но ты всегда будешь говорить, что нет, нет, уже в одном случае, я остаюсь в том, что я.
Поэтому это и называется гальмуванием.
Подумайте про это, как вы будете себя гальмовать.
И напишите сейчас, как вы себе поможете при этом гальмувании это все скинуть,
себя поддержать, зафиксировать, например, что вы сейчас подсознательно или уже осознанно это все гальмуете и идти дальше до цели.
Кто там что написал? Интересно мне. Скажите, пожалуйста, как он себя гальмует.
Так, так, Ань, скажи.
Так, я старалась быть честной с собой в первую очередь, это не оценивание уже сделанного, то есть всегда за высокие ожидания от себя, и даже уже когда я чувствую, что мой организм даже не вывозит такого темпа, я все равно внутренне хочу большего от себя.
И то, что вы проговорили, это может быть сравнение себя с другими.
И, в основном, через это формирование взаимоотвратительной тревоги,
которая, в основном, немного дестабилизирует состояние и может в этом заважать, да, в достижении цели.
Хорошо, Аня, очень быстро сейчас подумайте, занотуйте себе, что вы будете делать вместо того, чтобы сравнивать себя с другими.
Хорошо. И подумайте о том, что есть нормальные ожидания. Пожалуйста, давайте вернемся к реалиям жизни. У нас иногда есть слишком большие ожидания. Юля, я слушаю.
Так, смотрите, у меня, переключаю вагу, то есть, знаете, когда что-то делаешь, делаешь, ты такой, ой, это мне, это не нужно, тут остановимся и пойдем еще туда что-то попробуем, и там, ну, то есть, перемыкание очень быстро, и второе я записала, я не до, то есть, я еще не доросла, я еще там не до, там, учила, и вот эта классическая история, вот такая.
Я не до, да, не на надто досконало.
Это оно.
Да, добре, то тогда нужно сейчас, Юль, остановиться и сказать, я до, да, мне уже досталь, и этого достаточно, и подумать о том, что будете делать, когда в следующий раз увидите,
потому что это очень большая такая история, когда мы перемыкаем в увагу.
вы скажете себе, я сейчас перемыкаю
вагу, то я, может быть, не хочу
быть счастливой, не хочу быть богатой,
не хочу быть какой-то, и я
остановлюсь и пойду делать. Это возможно, Юля?
То есть, ставить так и так.
Умочка, добро, София?
У меня страх критики
на большую аудиторию.
Угу.
Критичевая.
Страх критики, да.
Угу.
То есть, у меня уже не так.
Просто уже давно могла расти
в аудитории, а не расту,
именно потому что я думаю, что, ну, вот,
есть такое внутри, да, что если я вырасту,
и там вот меня начнут критиковать,
тут-то, ладно, я разберусь.
Как ужасно, да, да.
София, я очень хорошо
это понимаю, не критикуют только
те, кто ничего не делает.
Да, ну, что
уж делать. Мои дети, они
выучили одну фразу, и она очень
хорошая. Они говорят, если кто-то злой,
наверное, его мама недолюбила.
У меня все просто с этим. Это их персональное дело, поэтому подумайте, пожалуйста, над тем, как вы себя будете поддерживать в тот момент, когда вас кто-то хейтит. Хорошо? Окей. Василий, слушаю.
Доброго дня. Я саботаю, переключаясь в телефон, само собой, Инстаграм иногда моментом, езжу, мне сразу ум вспоминает, что я голодный, плюс мое саботование происходит через изменение внимания и я обнаруживаю новый фокус, новый подразник.
Чи це дитина, чи це щось сталося, чи, чи, чи. Тобто ум сразу, типа, у меня, я тикаю.
Добре, то шо будете робити замість того, шоб брати там инсту, дивитись, шо будете робити?
Мені одразу висновок. Шо будете робити заради цього?
Ну, найперше, типа, шоб не воювати с цим, я прийму себе, шо, окей,
мені потрібен зараз легенький перефокус, але усвідомлений.
Запытаюсь, что я хочу, запытаюсь себя, какая моя цель и что я могу сделать для себя, чтобы продолжить идти к своей цели.
Ну и сказать, что я молодец, что я не в вечности.
Посмотрите, то, что я уже сделал, а не критиковать себя.
Мне очень нравится последнее, не критиковать себя, поддерживать себя, но я буду с вами отвертой, можно?
Да.
Усель, не сработает история, когда я буду это смотреть или перефокус.
Перефокус вы сделаете тогда, когда вы выполните эту работу и сразу скажете себе, что я молодец.
Потому что это такая ловушка, и она может работать так, что сегодня на минуту, завтра 2 минуты, а послезавтра 3.
Но если у вас есть самый тотальный контроль над собой, тогда я вам верю.
Но на начале рекомендую просто откладывать куда-то, знаете, Василий, у меня уже лет 10 нет никакой нотификации на телефон, никакой.
Потому что сначала я делаю работу, та, которая для меня приносит удовольствие и деньги, а потом все другое.
Рекомендую, выключайте все. И тогда все будет хорошо, тогда вы будете достигать цели, договорились?
И поешь, пожалуйста, не надо ходить голодным, это классно.
Добре, спасибо. Юль.
Здравствуйте.
У меня страх проявленности.
И за счет этого выплывает страх о том, что скажут другие люди.
Особенно те, которые меня знают, скажут, что что-то я не так делаю,
куда-то я там не туда иду, и это всё неправильно.
И также у меня есть, когда я сравниваю, допустим, себя с кем-то,
кто уже чего-то достиг больше, чем я,
и я такая, а, не, ну всё, тогда ничего не выйдет.
И вот я закрываюсь, и мне не хочется ничего делать.
Это ужасно, ужасно.
Значит, правило номер один для всех в нашей группе.
Мы никогда никого ни с кем не сравниваем
Единственный человек, с которым вы себя можете сравнить, это вы сами
В вчерашнем дне
Пишите себе большими буквами
Больше в моей жизни нет ни одного сравнения с кем-то другим
Запомните навсегда, у нас нет конкуренции
Конкуренции реально нет, мы все разные
Кого-то вы любите лучше, больше, кого-то вы любите меньше
Мы все абсолютно разные
Единственный человек, с которым вы себя будете сравнивать
Отныне и во веки веков
Это я вчера
Я вчера не была на этом курсе
Или не был на этом курсе
У меня что-то не сработало
Окей, а сегодня я теперь знаю новую информацию
И буду действовать по-другому
Созразумила
Жодных
По ревнянь
Юль, и первое, что там было
Я забыла, очень интересно
что подумают другие все я отвечу да по-русски так как спрашивали так отвечаю послушайте есть
грустная новость все готовы грустные новости если вы проявляетесь вас не будут любить вам
будут завидовать вас будут хейтить вас будут ненавидеть вас будут не понимать вас будут
обижать теперь вдохнули и выдохнули и поняли что есть люди которые когда будут видеть вас
будут любить вас будут ждать вас будут ожидать вас и будут ожидать именно вас это нормально
Это нормально, потому что они ждут только вас, никого другого, но на самом деле будьте к этому
спокойны. Это их персональная точка зрения, это их история. Знаете, через 16 лет один мой коллега
Коллега сказал, Березянская, слушай, ты такая умная.
Я говорю, тебе 16 лет понадобилось, чтобы ты понял, насколько я умна.
Ранило ли меня это? Нет.
Я-то знаю, что я умна.
Это история других людей.
И она к вам не имеет никакого отношения.
Поэтому вас могут не любить, вас могут не принимать.
И это нормально. Хорошо?
Алина?
Привет.
Перед тем, как сказать то, что я с самого начала написала,
я хочу прям подсветить тот момент, насколько круто
работают полы.
Когда уже предыдущие люди говорили, да, и прям каждый
раз ответ в точку, да, оно вот все отгукывалось, и
все было про меня.
Можливо, что-то одно-два, да, какие-то пункты, которые не отгукнулись, а все остальные прямо вау.
Поэтому очень благодарю за эту возможность.
Что я делаю, как я саботую? Я переключаюсь на другое, расфокусируюсь, думаю, что я не смогу быть идеальной в этой сфере, в каком-то направлении,
но идеальной и не нужно быть, достаточно быть такой, как я есть.
И, ну, наибольшая моя, певно, какая-то проблема, да, с наценением властных достижений. Я, на самом деле, я каждый раз себя верну до того, да, сколько всего я сделала, какой я была тогда, тогда, тогда и какая я сейчас.
Какой уже большой багаж я уже имею со своими плечами, но мне нужно каждый раз себя туда вернуть.
Это хорошо. Я вас научу. У нас будет тема очень классная про то, как мы можем начать себя целовать. Это третий семинар. Я вас научу. Будете целовать себя.
с другими первое что я написала потом потеря фокуса но опять-таки когда меня отвлекают по
работе или по семейным обстоятельствам это нарушение границ тут я стараюсь как-то уже
работать и выделять себе это время боязнь признания тоже моя тема как я с этим буду
работать и я буду признавать свою точку на карте видеть что это мой путь и я иду шаг за шагом и я
становлюсь лучше лучше замечать и признавать это присваивать ну и не сравнивать себя с
другими действительно сравнивать себя только с собой что и дать себе право идти в своем
темпе вот супер я очень рада этому поддерживаю молодец умница лера я скажу то есть чем я уже
павлик часто целая цвета и действо что можно саботовать оба гальмовать это вне цены не моих
досягнений моим на и большим уточнением а чего на а то а только я креста кирилл а можно же было
еще больше. Я уже научилась с этим работать, я себе эту историю привлечу. У меня всегда при мне
сервис прекрасный, на котором написано «Пала и Мала», и я постоянно к нему вернусь, я его
никогда не снимаю. И тут вы уже много подсветили, отвечая другим участникам, на что следует обратить
свою внимание. Я себе тут позанотовила, что можно с этим еще делать. Это супер, это супер,
очень рада так Юля у меня также уже может была ответ на мои вопросы потому что тем чем я себя
саботаю это расфокус переключение внимания и как бы эта имитация много делать но не цельное не то
что нужно типа же я делаю но не цельное у меня есть страх продавать и я уже поняла почему это
есть страх быть какой-то нехорошей девушкой для всех типа знаете быть такой хорошей,
потому что если ты там где-то что-то продаешь, где-то что-то больше хочешь, ты уже не такая,
ты уже отличаешься, поэтому работайте. Нормально быть нехорошей, да, я нехорошая девушка,
когда я нехорошая, да, я и хорошая, и нехорошая, но главное, какая я для себя, потому что если вы
Если вы хотите быть хорошей, я писала работу, кандидатскую по психо-онкологии, можно померть немного раньше. Не нужно быть очень хорошей, понимаете?
Вот такие думочки мои. Добрый, Юля.
Добрый день. У меня есть такие думки, что, как вы говорите, остановиться за шаг до, это что я не смогу быть вагонным, что я не смогу быть затребованным, например, в какой-то профессии, в том, например, что я сейчас начинаю, в коучинге.
И вот эти думки меня могут откидывать назад, я могу переключаться в то, что их предыдущие участники сказали.
В принципе, тоже какой-то Инстаграм, делать какие-то дела, которые не ведут меня к цели, к тому, что мне нужно, а которые меня здесь остановят.
Я переключаюсь, откладываюсь.
Всё хорошо. Слушайте, есть для вас у всех единственное желание.
Запишите себе.
Бояться и действовать — это параллельные процессы.
Слушайте, мне иногда было так страшно, когда ты только что-то начинаешь,
Но боишься и действуй всегда.
Это очень классный параллельный процесс.
Я буду говорить двумя словами, какие-то очень важные термины.
Потому что, когда мы начинаем для себя что-то интегрировать,
нам нужно интегрировать это на язык, который разговаривали с вами родители.
Поэтому я буду дублировать информацию важную на русском языке,
потому что я вижу, что некоторые говорят по-русски.
Бойся и действуй.
Бейся и руби.
Это ваш слоган.
Боюсь, вдохну, або мне очень страшно, вдохну, выдохну и пошел работать.
Да, оно не будет восстановлено, это нормально.
Люда, я слушаю.
Да, замечательно видно. Какие я написала вещи? Не подпускает к себе близких людей. Я считаю, что это саботаж, наверное, нужно будет проговорить его детальнее.
Далее, я иногда движусь в ритме других людей, и я понимаю, что это тоже может меня саботировать. У нас с мужчиной очень разные ритмы, мне приходится адаптироваться, и где-то я иду против себя.
Добре, это нормально. Мы же все люди адекватные, да, и нам нужно подлажтоваться, мы без этого не можем.
Мне очень тяжело, потому что я такая женщина, которая сядет, мне сразу же нужен результат, и мне прям это очень тяжело дается.
Могу долго принимать решения, хотя делаю это быстро.
А можно на секунду остановиться, люди?
И все, кто там у меня находится в таком невидании, хочу результат сразу.
Пожалуйста, покажите мне сразу накачанный пресс.
Или найдите мне, пожалуйста, какую-то магическую палочку.
Для того, чтобы его накачать или сделать себе красивое что-то,
потребуется время.
Пожалуйста, если у вас есть ожидания от меня, от себя,
что у вас завтра будет чудовый пресс с кубиками,
это не до меня.
Он качается, а на манекене, да, сразу есть пресс.
Но он пластиковый, не живой, потому что его так вылили.
На меня, чтобы оно так было, нужно год занять.
Да, давайте, люди, себе это занотуйте.
Я не люблю, когда есть какие-то ожидания.
Я вас очень поддерживаю.
Но выдыхайте, пожалуйста, и достаточно ожидать от себя.
Тем более, когда мы начинаем, знаете, такой high level.
Нет его. И это нормально. Уявите себе, ну это я с любовью говорю, с любовью, правда, что вы бейбики в этой профессии сейчас.
Ну в этом направлении, это же нормально быть, да, родиться. И когда ты родился, покажи мне хоть одну дитину, которая родилась, и она уже на второй день бежит, марафон, 42 километра, и выиграет.
Есть такие? Нет таких. То есть давайте снимем эти ожидания. Люди совсем разные, наша задача
понимать, что мы разные, и нам нужно просто быть в добром разуме, подлежать другим, не порушивая свои
кордоны. Это важно. Спасибо. Очень классные такие идеи.
Есть ли еще что-то такое особенное? Я еще хотела дать одну вещь. Какую?
Я могу долго принимать решения, хотя делаю это относительно быстро. Супер. Решения мы принимаем долго,
или мы долго думаем, и это нормально, или мы боимся. У нас уже есть один слоган от меня.
Бояться и действовать, это параллельный процесс. Понятно? Кто боится, так и делай. Хорошо, спасибо. Снежана.
Спасибо за возможность. Ну, многое я думала, подходит, что говорили мои предыдущие, но все это привело к одному.
На самом деле, корень в том, что я боюсь проявляться на публику, потому что я боюсь осуду, и сегодня такая же ситуация, что я фотографию выклала, и ты по третий день учения, и я счастлива.
И одна пишет, Боже, какая натянутая смеха, а другая пишет, Боже, Снежана, какая ты прекрасна, тешусь за тебя, но вы меня вылечили, я ввела себя червоным и великими буквами на стол. Думка других про вас не имеет к вам никакого отношения.
Спасибо. Это прямо слоган, который я беру себе, не знаю, где раздрюкаю, потому что это меня больше стопорит.
Я рада, что вы это поняли. Если кто-то говорит, что у меня не такая смех, я не то говорю,
это его личный внутренний диалог. Он себя считает с плохим смехом и не то говорит.
и мне не нужно свою проекцию отдавать.
Это для меня не имеет никакого значения, это правда.
Спасибо. Олена?
Я сначала написала про кристинацию, выгорание, не удержу фокус.
Сейчас, когда говорили предыдущие участники,
я поняла, что есть еще вот эти моменты,
например, там, снять себя на видео, это же страшно,
потому что мне не очень нравится, как я выгляжу, или как звучит мой голос,
потому что для меня внутри он звучит по-другому.
И это как раз касается того, что вы сказали, что бояться, то делать, это параллельные процессы.
То есть, сразу уже, как бы, дали такую штуку, как с этого выходить.
Потому что я понимаю, окей, ну там уже на 20-м видео, может, уже мне и понравится,
Если я буду делать это регулярно, хотя бы для начала, для себя, да, там, ну, как какой-то путь, что, ага, первое видео было вот такое, а 20, о, уже классно, мне нравится, можно уже выставлять, ну, принаймнее так до этого идти, я так понимаю.
Хорошо, тогда вернёмся к началу. Мы родились сегодня. С днём рождения вас.
Да, мы сегодня родились. Это наше первое, или не первое видео.
Но я вам скажу отвертно. Хотите, скажу отвертно?
Скажите, пожалуйста, вот вы видите меня сейчас такой.
Я вам или понравюсь, или нет.
Это же первая наша встреча, да?
а если вы меня увидите вот такой, это будет влиять на наши отношения. Мне так не нравится.
Мне тоже нравится, потому что независимо от того, где у тебя хвост, я говорю, да, или у тебя надёгнуты сегодня окуляры,
тебя люди или любят, или нет. И мне всё равно, это моё первое видео, дай мне покажут всегда своё первое видео.
а потом мы поговорим, если у него нет видео, а у меня оно есть, то я кто?
ПЕРЕМОЖИТЬ!
Поэтому, независимо от того, как вы выглядите,
или хорошо, или хвостом, я говорю, я своих студентов всегда научаюсь,
справа или слева, или ты сегодня намалевана,
или у тебя нет того мейкапа, все равно,
или ты стоишь где-то там, я не знаю, снимаешь там на фоне,
или стоишь на улице, все равно.
Бо є люди, які тебе або приймають, або ні. Ті, які не приймають, ти завжди будеш не такой, як треба. Але це їх особиста історія. Я потім вам поясню, в чому.
Тому давайте, пишіть свої відео, викладайте матеріали. Нехай вони просто заздрять. Оце моя особиста думка. Я це знаю вже. Дякую, дякую, Лен. Анастасия.
добрый день сказано вас к только выведу тогда то что еще не озвучено лично для меня важно я
могу физически не вытянуть то есть у меня нет стопов если у меня есть большое желание и цель
у меня физически складывает чаще всего то есть я без то я не отвлекаюсь ни на что а так новая
нас об украина ролик так мои любимые трудоголики послушайте меня нам не надо много денег посмертно
от того какой вы гроб себе красивые богаты закажите ну потому что вы физически много
всего делаете будет всем безразлично как вы в нем лежите но итог конечно вот получилось три
операции вот из последнего на и тот же на и все кто такой у меня очень трудоголик то послушайте
это очень важно я люблю живых людей и вот эта история про баланс она очень важно хватит
зарабатываться до смерти надо страдать и семья и баланс нарушен в итоге и получается потому что я
да это абсолютно верно простите нас я перебиваю да вы будете учить других людей вы коучи а вы
ваша задача быть конгруэнтными конгруэнтными это значит то что я транслирую на психологическом
уровне она подтверждается на социально если я пришла куч по счастью говорим
нравствуйте но сейчас я вас на утру бы счастливыми сейчас мы будем делать счастье всем садитесь
слушайте или все слышите или если я к вам заехала в красивым вера белым гробу заработав много-много
много-много денег про что это нет моя история она очень простая да есть время для работы есть
время для отдыха и никто никто следующая новая новость не будет о вас заботиться даже у вас
есть большие ожидания вы мне все взрослые это ваша персональная ответственность позаботиться
о себе с этим я работаю уже более полугода именно в терапии именно с этим именно конкретно с этим
то есть я членских трудоволекам сдала а второе то что у меня это потеря свободы у меня появляется
страх потери свободы то есть чему-то какой-то придя к цели нужно что-то сделать то что не
присущи тебе или ты не хочешь этого делать но обязан вплоть до на деловые переговоры надо
там одеть галстук дать затянуть его здесь и тебя он просто душит просыпается бунтарь просыпается
делать потеря такой свободы да то есть нужно выглядеть к там в кадре как-то не так или что-то
одеть не так то есть меня это сильно сковывает запирать и я сразу иду в бунтарская такое значит
вообще не буду делать чудесная новость а никто не может забрать у тебя эту забор свободу кроме тебя
самой поменять то не заберет моя свобода да и а то чему я буду учить вас у каждого из вас будет свой
персональный личный стиль хотите придите на переговоры в кедах захотите придите в переговоры
на переговоры в пиджаке захотите без пиджака пришла опыт у меня подсказывает но есть такие
кадры к что у тебя обязывает чтобы instagram работает так и его алгоритмы он работает так
как вы работаете вы и люди идут к вам исключительно на вашу энергию если у вас нет энергии люди к вам
не идут и третье основное это польза а если в том что я делаю и моя цель польза для меня и для
общества и что их но вот быва и когда сталкиваешься с такими моментами ты зависаешь и то что ты делаешь
и твоя цель и если от этого польза себе и другим это же может быть как бунтарь подниматься что
зачем тратить время и энергию жизнь очень короткая если это не полезно для себя и для кого-то а я не
знаю если для этого польза если на это не будет дано какое-то время я никогда не выращивая ни
один цветок за один день это невозможно и если польза тех людей в которой я инвестирую свое
время и энергию я увижу спустя время когда они вырастут я это буду видеть вас когда вы вырастите
польза есть тогда когда мы любим и когда мы в безопасном пространстве когда мы растем когда
мы развиваемся когда мы передаем что-то дальше а если от этого пользы каждый решает из нас отдельно
дала ответы на ваши вопросы и василию наустанок и далее будем удоробливать и цю вправо текала в
У меня к вам вопрос.
Последние два дня звучит, что в сотрудничестве с клиентом мы не можем ничего говорить, кроме вопросов.
То есть, вопрос, вопрос, вопрос.
Сейчас в работе с вами, от вас шли такие флешбеки, в определенном типе, возможно, даже оценка, нормально, ненормально.
Как складывать в своей голове, где идти с вопросами,
и можно ли в какой-то сессии ответить примерно так, как вы?
Вы также где-то были, поделились своим досудом.
Потому что есть вот это, ну, типа, понимание, что где-то это есть в сессии,
насколько это нужно или выкоренивать, или нет, чтобы играть по правилам,
или играть за клиента, наиболее, а не по правилам.
Классное вопрос, спасибо, даю ответ.
Да, есть тема контрактов, есть разные виды контрактов, мы об этом будем говорить.
Один из контрактов – это на развитие, там, где есть вопросы, вопросы, вопросы, а есть контракты на нормализацию.
Это также контракт.
И если… А есть контракт, Василий, еще и на поддержку.
И поэтому нужно всегда идти за клиентом.
Поэтому я вас сегодня и научу, что от меня хотят люди.
И если я сейчас посмотрела на нашу группу, я поняла, что у нас есть несколько уровней контрактов.
То есть, я задала вам вопрос, что есть то, что вас будет остановить.
И нормально другим поделиться своими чувствами.
И то, что говорили, говорили, мне страшно, мне страшно, я боюсь, я нехорошо выглядаю.
Это контракт на нормализацию того, что с тобой все хорошо.
НЕМАЕТ ПОВНОГО РОЗВИДКОВ, КОЛИ ТЫ ЗАЛЯКАННЫЙ.
ТОМУ ПОТРЕБНО ПОДОВИТЕСЯ И ЗАПИТАТЕ В КЛИЕНТА, ЯКИЙ В НЕГО БУДЕТ КОНТРАКТ.
СЮГДНЯ Я ВАС НАВЧУ, ЯК ПРО ЦЕ ГОВОРИТЕ, ЯК ЦЕ ПРОГОВОРИВАТЕ. ДОБРОЕ?
ДЕ? МЫ ДАЕМО ЗАВЖДЫ, ЗНАЕТЕ, В МЕНЕ ЕЩЕ УЛЮБЛЕННЫЕ ФРЕЗЫ.
Я всегда готовлю людей тем, что они любят.
Я всегда классно, очень люблю готовить еду.
Но я не даю людям то, чего они не хотят.
И это называется не только контракт, но и контакт.
Потому что вас будут научить контрактом, а я вас научу.
контакта, чтобы вы понимали, что люди от вас хотят получать.
Хорошо?
Молодцы, гумочки мои, гении мои.
У меня к вам на встанок единственное вопрос.
Кстати, то, что мы с вами сделали сегодня, вот сейчас вам показываю,
это и называется контрактом с другими.
Это уже есть инструмент, что вы хотите получать.
в нашей работе, как вы будете это гальмовать, это работающий инструмент с вашими клиентами,
с чего начинается ваша встреча, когда мы говорим привет, что ты от меня хочешь сегодня
утримати, як ви себе або я вас можу підтримати, і взагалі шо ви від мене бажаєте, це ж важливо.
І зараз на останок шось смачненьке, занутуйте собі, будь ласка. Як ви себе сьогодні побалуете, шо ви для
для себя однажды сделать что-то классное, офигенное за то, что вы начали изучать и учиться.
Занотуйте. Той, кто себе... Там иногда тяжело это записать, знаете, эти желания, вот это, что я себе сегодня сделаю красиво.
У меня уже есть целый лист, виш-лист. Я уже себе там занотовала, что я должен сделать сегодня на конец дня.
Поняли? Занотовали? Юль, мне сейчас нужна помощь. Мы объединяемся по 4 или по 3, сколько там у нас людей, да, и идем на 10 минут.
И мы говорим один к одному, как я себя сегодня побалую, что я для себя сделаю.
Добре, я хочу побачить вас всех, вернувшись, с думками про то, что будет на конец сегодняшнего дня.
И, кстати, пожалуйста, не нужно мне писать завтра, или послезавтра,
или у меня еще сегодня учеба до 10. Все равно подумайте так, чтобы день закончился, а мой подарок,
про который мы уже с вами договорились, он остался с вами, хорошо? И можете, кстати, там наш чат,
у нас же есть там чат, да? Накидать фото своих подарков, это будет классно. Знаете, это, кстати, вайпово,
Посмотреть, как мы можем себя баловать на конец этого дня.
Это самомотивация.
Юль, распределяем.
Да.
Вы можете приединиться.
Сейчас даю еще новый.
Не тробы зрозумити, зараз вправа буде, троба трошки
Витя, ну так он...
Так, чтобы я могла его затоять.
Вас видно! Да, меня видно, но мне нужно, чтобы меня было видно, как мне нужно.
Так, девчата, у меня сейчас будет работа. Будем ее делать, мне нужен пространство. Слушайте, я сейчас
Я сейчас сделаю ротацию и перейду просто в другое место, хорошо?
Да, как вам срочно.
Так, сейчас я... У меня есть интернет.
Я пошла, пока они там раздумывают.
Ищу себе вайп, где я могу это все сделать так, как мне нужно.
Сейчас посмотрю.
О, собаку оставила тут. Пошли куда-нибудь.
Я всегда с вами, да? Или это парень? У меня две собаки, просто младшая собака и забрала
дочь у этой собаки. Сейчас включат, мне нужно где-то сделать вправо. О, нормально, да? Да, класс тоже.
Светло, красиво? Да, светло, красиво, вы видите все. Я подошла и меня хоть видно. Сейчас я
мужу скажу, чтобы он просто сюда не заходил, девчонки. Хорошо.
Всё, всех предупредила. Сейчас делом займёмся. Сколько ещё минут?
33 минуты. До 12.30. Нет, нет, я иду в зале. В зале и 4 минуты. Я думаю, я аж душно стала. Думаю, 33 минуты.
Так, хорошо. Раз в 4 минуты я пойду там поправлю, чтобы потом сразу преподавать.
Идет?
Да.
Настя, ты тут?
Так.
Надеюсь, если я закреплю Владу, тебе будет видно?
Так будет лучше?
Нет, на жаль, если ты закрепишь Владу, то только для себя,
а для всей группы не выйдет закрепить.
Если только нет отдельной кнопки для того, чтобы прикрепить для других, но я про такую не знаю.
Нет такой кнопки, девчонки.
Да, ее только просто закрепляют.
Ну, тогда вот так.
Чудо.
Все нормально, сейчас дело сделаем и пойдем.
сяду посыщу тут вам давай давай ой как справилась мы сидим слухаем а я уже ловлю свои инсайты а
ты же добра обожню инсайты колывана я дуже тикалом здесь на душе я рад имени потом
Заворотный связок, знаете, что...
Давайте после сессии мы с вами сделаем звонок короткий,
буквально 5-10 минут для синхронизации,
заворотного связочка, что дальше делаем,
и я вас отпущу.
Доброе? Зручно вам будет?
Я должна ехать потом на встречу.
Если я буду без видео, нормально?
Взагалі нормально, действительно.
Тогда так и сделаем.
Да, очень действительно интересно. Я вижу, как студенты такие заняты, они, может, отработают, так себе разговаривают, подключаются. Это круто, круто, чтобы мы налагали такие их комьюнити.
Надо налагать комьюнити, контакты, чтобы они больше общались.
Потому что это всегда ресурс. Мои студенты обожают.
Они потом так плачут, когда они идут, они говорят «Вау, вы не ходите, вы не хотите никуда идти, дайте еще что-то, дайте еще что-то!»
Они говорят «Предумайте, пожалуйста, какую-нибудь новую тему!»
и не хочет отдыхать, и потом я еще и придумаю 129 тем.
Закрываю залы, у нас 30 секунд.
Ой, рада вас видеть, что занотовала себе, что хорошо будете делать.
Ввешали листы, списочки, все есть, да?
Добре, давайте с вами пограем, давайте с вами сделаем что-то такое интересное.
Сейчас я вам покажу, зачем эти контракты, добре?
Я вам покажу, специально сделала релокацию, спустилась в другую комнату, чтобы у меня было много места.
Пожалуйста, хотите, я вам сейчас покажу, как работают контракты и как работает гипноз в целом?
Потому что я еще гипнолог по обучению, да? Интересно, да?
Вы есть, не страшно? Хорошо, я рада. Давайте. Мне нужно, чтобы все встали.
Вставайте, хоть посмотрим один на одного. Сейчас я их отступлю тут.
Встали?
Отдуси, доченька, вставайте, вставайте, да, досить там
уже сидите, засиделись, как бабуси и дедуси.
Девица, простяните, будь ласка, правую руку вперед.
Ноги закрепите на, на подлозе, так?
И повернитесь за часовой стрелкой и посмотрите, где ваша была правая рука.
Запомнили?
Повернитесь назад.
Сейчас я вас начну, научу гипнозу.
Ставьте руку, посмотрите на руку и скажите,
кто какой язык с собой разговаривает, и скажите,
моя правая рука а правая рука ты ты зараз маешь повернутся на третину больше ниш поверталась и
доцова ты сейчас должна повернуться дальше на 1 3 чем поворачивалась до этого я твей хозяин
хозяйка я тоби наказываю а ты то робишь зараз заплющить будь ласка очи и уявить
себе, что ваше тело стало дуже гнучким. И что вы смогли настолько прокрутиться на 180 градусов,
даже так не крутимся, но представим, что видите свою руку настолько гнучкой уже перед собой,
то повернулися на что-то у той годинник зараз расплющить и очи девицы на руку не повертайтесь
назад и кажись моя права рука за рст и повернешься дальше далее ниш поверталась а до чего сказали и
И вернемся, вернемся, вернемся, вернемся, но ноги стоят на земле, увидели, что ваши руки вернутся больше, так, дальше не будет, давайте, аплодисменты себе за то, что мы гипнологи, я уже вас научила директивному гипнозу.
Вот, сейчас буду подниматься, да, и буду вам дальше рассказывать, для чего нужны контракты. Контракты, они нужны для того, чтобы вы смогли поставить себе цель, поставить себе цель и достигать ее.
Это понятно? Если вы, вы сейчас гипнологи и коучи, и все у вас сразу, если вы не научились ставить цель и проговорить, вы не будете достигать результата.
Поняли?
Как вам курс гипноза?
Нормально?
Смотрите, вы уже можете себя гипнотизировать.
Так, кайф, да?
Я очень рада, что вам кайф.
И что мне кайфово.
Сейчас я все подключусь, чтобы потом с вами не потерять связок.
И начинаем работать.
Так.
Все, идем дальше.
Готовы?
Что делаем, что делаем?
Вы это нотировали как инструмент для работы?
То есть, когда мы встречаемся один к одному, мы говорим привет и дальше начинаем разговаривать.
Что вы от меня хотите получить, как вы это получите, что дальше будет хорошим результатом.
И особенно важно себе поблагодарить, когда вы достигаете этого мотива.
Это первый инструмент. Идем дальше.
Разумеется, что это первый инструмент работы, это называется контракт с собой или контракт с
с иншими. Зробили скрины? Добре. Зупиняю, идем далее.
Что далее? Давайте я вам буду показывать презентацию.
Контракт с собой мы уже сделали. История контракта, как это все началось. Это главный
организатор всех контрактов и вообще транзакционного анализа Эрик Берн.
Много лет назад он начал изучать транзакционный анализ и он сформулировал метод контрактов.
Это как другой путь становления контакта и контрактов с другими людьми.
Он всегда сказал, что контракт – это когда двое людей договорятся о измене,
а не о том, что кто-то ведет, а другой держит курс.
Это было что-то новаторское, это было очень бунтивное.
Потому что когда раньше люди договаривались о чем-то, это выглядело так.
Я к тебе пришел, я бедолажка, вылечи меня.
То есть я к тебе пришел, а ты меня лечи.
В транзакционном анализе, и вообще, я думаю, это можно использовать где-то, есть другие идеи и другие теории. Это когда мы встречаемся один с одним и один с одним, как взрослые, говорим про изменения.
Мы открыты к диалогу, мы открыты к общению, мы открыты к тому, что будет между нами.
Поэтому нужно понимать и начать разговаривать, что такое контракт с транзакционным анализом.
Это главное. Давайте, это классно. Нотуйте себе, берите себе это и используйте.
Это договоренность двух взрослых людей, где каждый из нас берет обязательства.
Это важно.
Это важно, потому что когда мы начинаем работать в коучинге, что мы чувствуем?
Сегодня вы сказали, что я недосконала, или я не достигну, или я не достигну цели,
или у меня будет что-то не так.
То есть это договоренность двух взрослых людей.
Если мы работаем с руководителями, если мы работаем сами с собой,
мы добавляем до того, кто из нас на себя берет какие-то обязанности.
И это важно.
50 на 50, то есть 50% моей ответственности.
50% вашей.
Сегодня я с вами складывала контракт, я вам задавала вопрос, что вы хотите получить, что сегодня, какие у вас ожидания, это я уже контракт.
Я приношу вам свою работу, свои инструменты, свои навыки, свои знания, но и вы должны что-то делать.
Потому что очень часто в организациях есть такая гипотеза. Я тебя вызвал, ты и делай. Или, как мне говорят, вы же психотерапевт, вы же изменяете. Нет, нет, нет. Мы работаем вдвоем.
Наша коммуникация открыта. То есть все, что я записываю и нотирую себе в любой работе, это записывается и нотируется таким образом, чтобы мой клиент, когда он открыл этот файл, он увидел, что мы нотировали, что я нотировала.
И это было из позиции «я окей, ты окей».
Скажите, пожалуйста,
вы делаете свои надписи так,
чтобы их можно было открыть,
с кем бы вы не общались,
и увидите, что вы там написали?
Не всегда.
А история в транзакционном анализе,
что мы общаемся один с одним
из позиций «я окей, ты окей».
то есть нет кого-то, кто сверху, над мной не может быть руководитель сверху,
або я над ним, мы в равных позициях, один с одним, я окей, ты окей, у меня есть опыт,
в тебе я желаю его использовать, это главная позиция,
Поэтому мы занотовываем все открыто и берем каждый из нас на себя 50% ответственности.
50% ответственности.
Так, Ира?
Одна думка мне пришла. Вы говорите занотовывание, прописывание, чтобы потом клиент читал.
У меня вопрос. Вы позволяете, например, делать регистрацию вашей сессии, вашего разума, то есть это видео или аудио, то, что потом вы сможете и ваш клиент прослушать, переслушать?
Это можно запропоновать. У меня есть очень много клиентов, которые говорят, слушай, я так люблю с тобой проводить время, можно я себе занотую,
потому что у меня потом догоняют инсайты. И оно действительно так есть. Вы можете запропоновать и сказать, вы хотите запись?
Вы хотите, чтобы у меня открыта работа. Если у меня клиент попросит, дай мне посмотреть, что ты там пишешь.
Потому что, когда я веду сессию, на начале я всегда что-то записываю. Что сегодня будет главным для тебя?
Это уже первый контракт. Что ты хочешь от меня сегодня получить?
Есть главный контракт, который мы вместе обговориваем, когда мы видим один одного, как стратегию нашего общения и работы.
Но есть контракт на каждую встречу.
И вот это контракт на каждую встречу, а сегодня что будет важным?
А сегодня, почему это важно? Потому что мы идем в след за нашим клиентом.
Я понимаю, что у вас есть какая-то стратегия, но вы говорите, что у нас главная стратегия такая, что сегодня что-то изменилось или нет?
Возможно, ты хочешь что-то добавить. Это называется гнучкий контракт.
Потому что, когда мы видим один друга в первый раз, мы иногда в распахе, мы не знаем, что нам захотеть, что мы хотим получить, а потом нас догоняют.
Поэтому, делайте записи, напишите свои, чтобы можно было посмотреть. Пропонуйте клиентам записи, если они хотят.
Но если вы часто работаете с СЕО или с руководителями, они имеют перенадлежащий взгляд на эти записи.
И могут сказать, нет, я этого не хочу. Но ваша история, вы можете сказать, желаете? Делайте. Не желаете? Не делайте.
Я иду за вами. Это главное. Я дала ответ на это вопрос? Да, Ира? Хорошо.
То есть позиция я окей, ты окей, нотуем все так, чтобы можно было подивиться потом и понять, куда мы пришли, и нам не было сомнений.
Далее, то, что важно. Контракты мы можем использовать, как вы понимали, везде.
В семье, в организации, в общении с друзьями. Как будет выглядеть любой контракт?
Скажите мне, кто что уже запомнил? Контракт то про что? Одно слово скажите мне, любой контракт, который вы можете уже сегодня поговорить с кем-то, даже в комнатах общаясь.
Так, София, слушаю.
Правда, ответственность с двух сторон.
Добре, что еще?
Каждый берет 50% ответственности.
Да, да, Снежин.
За «я окей, ты окей».
Все в этом на равных.
На равных, так, Снежина.
Умоленность на смену.
И я сегодня сделаю хороший контракт
со своим сыном-предлетком.
Я уже знаю про что.
Да, да, до речи, есть такая классная штука.
Я также вам рекомендую, знаете,
только для бизнеса, но и для жизни, семейные контракты. Лера. Для меня еще про ожидания. Кто что от один одного
ожидает, чтобы было понимание, что я тогда могу тебе дать и про что тогда договоримся. Круто, круто. То есть любую встречу мы
начинаем с чего? Привет! Что будем сегодня делать? Поняли? Это уже контракт. Как ты хочешь провести
этот час? Если вы хотите иметь нормальную, классную, конструктивную встречу, будь с кем, скажите ему, задайте
вопросы. Это и есть классное вопрос. Что ты от меня ожидаешь? Как ты хочешь? Я подлежу тебе, я
Я сделаю это рядом с тобой.
Я буду делать это вместе с тобой.
Но давай кайфово, интересно, продуктивно проведем тот час.
Это понятно, что есть контракт?
Хорошо.
Разумники мои, боже мой, гении, как мне повезло.
Вот всегда ко мне приходят гении.
В бизнес-контексте, что такое контракт?
Контракт показывает то, что есть и то, что вам нужно просто знать и понимать.
Дивиться.
Це угода про зміну.
Що змінюється, як змінюється, яка поведінка, який формат.
Все проговорюємо.
Друге.
Відповідальність сторін.
Кто за шо відповідає.
Третье.
То ціли.
Ясні ціли.
Какой результат? И главное, извините, откройте двери, потому что у меня пришел менеджер, заходьте, заходьте, в общем, цели.
И как мы понимаем, что мы достигли этой цели? Как выглядит конец результата?
На минутку остановлюсь.
Играем в игру. Играем? Хочете? Что-то интересное.
Почему... Мне холодно, тут у меня есть контур.
Почему важно понять, какой должен быть результат?
Друзья, пожалуйста, представьте стол.
Какой-то стол.
Представили?
Добре. Кто, какие?
Круглый. Кто, какие?
На скольки людей?
5, 10, 2 на 10. Добре.
Деревянный, чистый, там, скляный.
Ага.
Белый, чечерный.
Видите, посмотрите, пожалуйста, в каждом из вас стол разный.
Поэтому, если мы не поедаем, не общаемся о том,
какой мы стол видим в конце, результата хорошего не будет.
Потому что, если я представила романтичную вечеринку для двух,
А другой уявил бизнес-партнерство на 20.
И накрыл это все на 20.
А я пришла на вечер для двух.
Понимаете мое разочарование?
Поэтому, когда вы начинаете общаться с другими,
сразу нотуйте, как вы понимаете, что мы достигли результата одного.
Что у нас цел один на двух.
Без этого объяснения не будет хорошей работы.
Потому что, знаете, иногда слышишь историю, какие-то кейсы.
О, мы сначала договорились о том, что мы работаем в целом как единственная команда.
И это просто, знаете, иногда в меня вызывает смех.
То команда, то как?
В кого-то команда один работает, а пятеро отдыхают.
В кого-то команда, они все сварятся, потому что это в него команда.
То есть, объединяйте столы, объединяйте конец результата.
Это понятно? Это важно.
Будьте смелыми, задавайте вопросы, как вы понимаете, что мы достигли этого результата.
Далее, то, что важно в любом контракте. Что каждый из нас делает? Кто за что отвечает?
Можно обратно слайд, пожалуйста? Я не успеваю сфоткать. Вы же выключаете, и мы не видим.
А я хочу на вас смотреть.
Я его повертаю.
Вы уже его сфоткали, я вам скажу
отвертно. Это все же тот
первый слайд.
Поняли, София? Я буду сказать
следующий слайд, хорошо?
Хорошо, хорошо. Вы уже его сфоткали.
Я просто хочу вам объяснить.
Смотрите, кто за что
отвечает.
Уявим историю. Мы с вами
бизнес-команда.
Мы работаем над проектом. Проект, например, я не знаю, что там, что-то интересное сделать.
Сделать нам пати сегодня. Мы же классные сегодня, много работаем. Давайте, на вечер у нас отдых.
Я говорю, у нас сегодня напрокин будет вечер.
Давайте дальше объединить, кто какую вечеринку ожидает. Это первое.
Да, чтобы не было потом разочарования. Это я показываю, как должен выглядеть
конец результата. А дальше я говорю, все встречаемся в 20-е где-то.
Зрозуміло, начебто і вечірка має бути, але хто за шо відповідальний? Якщо немає відповідального,
немає результата. Кожен з нас має зрозуміти, за шо ми відповідальні.
Коли ми зустрічаємось, я кажу, добре, хто за це буде відповідати? Я, ты, вона, хто?
И то, что важно, дедлайн. Когда это будет готово? Я, ты, она.
Потому что в бизнесе, как и в родине, есть одна большая проблема.
Если мы договорились выховывать кого-то, или поддерживать кого-то, или помогать кому-то,
но не говорим, кто за что ответственный, это не про что.
Если мы договорились с вами о вечерке, но не сказали, когда, кто, за что отвечает и когда в него дедлайн, это не про что.
Это крах бизнеса, вечерки, родины.
Все поняли?
Хорошо.
То есть мы договорились о времени, мы договорились, кто что делает, мы договорились о том, что мы будем делать дальше.
Идем за нашим слайдом.
Что у нас там далее есть сейчас?
И мы поделяем ответственность, и мы договариваемся до конца результата.
Принаводжу пример.
Есть основатель компании, и он хочет отдать часть своего управления.
Он приглашает к себе, это такой кейс, который у меня был недавно, своего операционного директора, и говорит ему,
Слушай, я хочу тебе отдать руководство, хочу уйти из бизнеса, ты сам решишь, что делать. Я тебе доверяю, я тебе очень хорошо доверяю. Ты все делаешь. На одну минуту вернусь к вам, потом снова покажу этот слайд.
И смотрите, что происходит. Прошло два месяца, и руководитель говорит, слушай, Влада, что-то у меня не работает. Я говорю, чего? Он говорит, что он меня бесит. Чего он тебя бесит? Потому что он не делает это так, как я хочу.
Как вы думаете, был ли контракт с операционным директором?
Нет.
То есть три месяца бизнес не работал.
Оно так не работает.
Если я что-то хочу, нужно сделать четкую структуру, что я хочу отрабатывать от тебя.
И это может выглядеть даже с операционным директором так.
Есть часть твоей зоны.
Например, ты анализируешь цифры, ты решаешь, как мы работаем относительно цифр, что нам нужно сделать,
если, но мы с тобой разбираемся каждую неделю, или если он уже пошел из бизнеса каждого месяца,
у нас есть такие задачи, один раз в месяц мы с тобой разбираемся, если ты не понимаешь, что делать, ты приходишь
до меня. У нас такие дедлайны, у нас такие результаты, мы доверялись. Если ты понимаешь, что делать, ты
делаешь то самое. То есть я всегда, когда с кем-то общаюсь, я ему говорю, у меня такие ожидания.
Все понятно? Да. Встречаемся один раз в неделю? Да. Доверяем наши результаты? Да. Чему еще
Если нужно записывать ваши встречи с клиентом, для того, чтобы посмотреть, иногда бывают клиенты, которые не ценят, как и вас, так и себя.
И, например, вас пригласили в компанию, и через месяц говорят вам следующее.
О, ничего с вами не изменится.
а вы каждый раз встречались с ним и делали отзывы.
Ничего не изменяется.
Например, в изменении личности, когда мы встречаемся один с одним,
когда у нас клиенты работают в психотерапии, они вообще забывают,
какие они были до этого и как они выглядят сейчас.
Иногда проходит полгода, и человек может мне сказать,
слушай, я что-то не вижу изменений.
Я говорю, правда? Я тогда открываю свои нотки и говорю, слушай, когда ты к мне пришел, ты вживал алкоголь, у тебя не было денег, твоя компания была на грани краху.
Это же я правильно все занотовала за тобой? Это же ты мне говорил?
Так, так. Твои співробітники, вони звільнилися. Так, так. Твои обороты были такими. Так, так. Добре, пришло півроку, шо зараз є в тебе?
Ну, слушай, что-то есть. Я уже полгода не пью. У меня появились отношения, не только моя компания, а и моя любовница, с которой я всегда общаюсь. Да, у меня появились там отношения, я хожу на побачения.
О, слушай, я плачу, да, я подивился, операционный директор мне принес информацию, что взрослые прибыли. Я говорю, то есть не все так плохо выглядит? У нас была проработана очень большая работа.
Да. Поэтому делайте нотки, записывайте, фиксируйте, доверяйте. Вы имеете на это право. У нас осталась одна минута. Скажите, есть ли у вас какие-то вопросы относительно того, что я вам уже рассказала и сказала? До перерыва. Нет?
Я уже не веду в блокнотах очень много рук, потому что за безопасностью, за этикой мы не
мы не должны сделать доступ к никакому нашему блокноту.
Все записи, они должны быть запараллеливаны.
То есть я не использую блокноты, потому что тебе потом нужно будет делать пожар в себе на подвале,
и это все за этикой, чтобы оно сгорело, чтобы его никто не увидел.
Или через эту штуку, которая там, бумагу, знаете, у нас есть, я не знаю, как она называется,
это все пропустите, потом сгорите,
потом забудьте, чтобы никто
до этого не дошел.
Сделайте электронные нотатки,
но сделайте много пароля.
На каждого клиента
свой личный файл,
где вы пишете дату,
когда вы
начали с ним
общаться, имя
и всю основную
информацию про него.
Або про себя.
Я дала ответ на вопрос, Маша?
И никто не имеет доступа к этой информации.
Это лично.
Обучайте, пожалуйста, всех своих семейных окружающих,
что есть правило, если вы работаете как куча конфиденциальностей,
Никто не имеет права брать ваши девайсы в руки.
У вас там должны стоять пароли,
не потому что вы параноидальны,
а потому что у вас есть клиенты.
Особенные папки, на которых есть пароли.
Двоэтапная аутоинтификация.
Это важно, потому что представьте себе хаос,
если кто-то заберет ваш аккаунт.
И про какие-то особенные вещи, которые действительно особенные,
предупреждают иногда владельцев компаний,
что они должны писать вам особо, без помощников и секретарей.
Потому что это что?
Контракт на безопасность.
Ни одна помощница, ни один секретарь не должен знать, когда вы с ним общались.
Это конфиденциальность.
Вы не можете говорить про своих клиентов.
Это правило.
Представьте, вас пригласил владелец бизнеса,
а вы потом в инсту выставили, а я обслуговывала,
или отдала консультацию, это будет трэш.
Поняли?
Идем отдохнуть, вернемся, прошу прощения, за 2 минуты перерыва,
вернемся в 2 минуты следующего часа, все будет за таймингом.
Не запоздняйтесь, будьте вчасны.
Спасибо, до встречи.
Да, закончила немножко позднее. Я всегда даю эти 2-3 минуты на отдых.
Да, да, да, можно отпускать всех. Перекусили, отдохнули, сейчас одну минуту на сборы.
что делали, пока все встречаются, доходят. Я уже сделал то, что мы вечером. Я в поезде буду назад,
хочу Капучинку и тортик. Я уже скинул фотографию, все как должно быть. О боже, как хорошо. Люди, кто голодный,
не заходите, пожалуйста. Потому что Василий отправил Капучинку и тортик, и тогда у вас будет очень много сливок.
Но класс, это класс. Кто еще, что успел сделать? Я поела. Я послушала Василия, что он иногда голодный, потом подумала, нам еще работать, нужно иметь много сил, и я поела.
Доброе, доброе.
Так, все, начинаем. Давайте я подведу подсумки.
Правильно я поняла, что многие из вас только начинают этот путь, как в работе для коучинга или для себя, да?
Давайте я тогда, так как вы начинаете впервые, да, вы новички, я где-то вам проговорю.
То есть, подведу подсумки, как мы встречаемся с нашими клиентами.
Добре?
Такой протокол.
Мы говорим один одному «Витаю».
Далее, проговорим контракт завжди про конфиденциальность,
что вся информация, которая будет надана тут, она и конфиденциальная.
Добре?
Это протокол, когда вы начинаете общаться.
Следующее. Вы задаете вопрос, в каком формате вам лучше работать, ты или вы. Это про договоренность. Как вам лучше, что вы хотите. Нормально и ты, и вы. В зависимости от того, что вы действительно хотите с кем-то общаться на ты или на вы. Сами решите.
Далее следующее. Записи. Скажите, что вы будете делать записи, если это нужно клиенту, потому что есть информация, но она конфиденциальная, какие-то нотки про вашу компанию, чтобы я вспомнила потом, через некоторое время, да, или смотреть результат нашей сотрудничества и получать согласие.
Хорошо. Если есть клиенты, которые вам говорят, что я не хочу, чтобы вы что-то записывали, у вас все равно должен быть запис.
То есть, заканчивается встреча, вы сами для себя занотовываете всю информацию.
Это понятно? Для того, чтобы, когда у вас один клиент, вы помните, когда у вас много клиентов, вы не помните.
это понятно?
хорошо
и дальше
приходим к тому, какие есть у вас ожидания
это то, что я вам сказала
это практический инструмент
что бы вы хотели получить от нашей сотрудничества
с этого начинается ваше общение
так, сейчас посмотрю, что здесь
Досье, да, заводим досье с паролями. Но к этому досье у нас еще должна быть история потом. Что это за компания, какая она, как мы к этому пришли и что мы будем делать. Олена.
Влад, я хотела спросить. Вы перед перерывом сказали, что не можно транслировать в соцмережах, с кем я работаю.
У меня вопрос. Как тогда знакомить, например, новый клиент, и он спрашивает, какие у вас есть кейсы, чтобы я понимал, что вы...
Какие у вас есть кейсы? Вы запрашиваете у клиента разрешение всегда на трансляцию любого. Вы. Если он против, вы за контрактом безопасности, потому что я слышала такой кейс, и это был очень плохой кейс одного коуча от моего клиента.
Они встретились вместе, тот достал телефон, начал записывать и сразу выклал прямой эфир.
А он говорит, вот с какого он это выклал.
Я с ним даже не работаю.
Понимаете, какая история? Дозвол.
Без дозвола не можно это делать, вы работаете как-то.
Есть дозвол – работаем, нет дозвола – нет.
Если вы хотите, чтобы я немного вам дала структуры, это относительно психотерапевтической такой истории, да, потому что вы будете знать иногда очень конфиденциальную информацию.
Если вам посмехается клиент, где-то вы встретились, случайно, вы посмехаетесь в ответ. Если вам не посмехаются, вы не посмехаетесь. То есть вы не бежите с другой стороны ресторана сказать, эй, хай, привет. Это понятно? Потому что это этика.
Что такое, Василий? Что я такое смешно говорю? Слушайте, у меня тут всегда какие-то, типа, уведомления выскакивают из нашей группы, да, там, из кем я. Что я смешно сказала? Правда, прикольно? Такие кейсы есть, да, когда там кто-то бежит с ресторана и кричит «Хей, привет!».
Если к вам бежит клиент, вы раскрываете обеимы и говорите привет.
Но вы так ни к кому не бежите.
Хорошо? Это занотовало, это безопасность.
Аня, слушаю.
Да, я хотела спросить, а если без имен,
без, скажем, не идентифицировать клиента,
а просто говорить о кейсе, это считается разглашением?
Просто как вот у меня была такая история,
когда кто-то как-то что-то, но без имен,
без каких-то уточняющих моментов.
Обязательно, Аня, без имён.
Никаких имён их вообще не должно быть.
Я могу без имён рассказывать какие-то кейсы в своей практике?
Минутку.
Так, чтобы информация никогда не была никем опознана.
Например, когда мы работаем с организациями,
мы как супервизоры рассматриваем работу наших учеников с организациями,
у нас есть определённые требования.
Мы просим никогда заведомо не указывать название организации.
Если вы даже в супервизе, это в моём регламенте работы,
то есть я не знаю, как у вас работают, но то, что у нас заведомо есть.
Мы не разглашаем название компании.
Например, я работал с компанией Air France, и вот такой результат.
Ни в коем случае.
Вся информация, даже на супервизе, она должна быть изменена.
есть каким образом я работал с компания есть такой кейс если они этот кейс знает половина
рынка надо подумать как его изменить таким образом чтобы его никто не опознал я могу
рассказывать о каких-то кейсах о каких-то практиках конечно но я вам привожу вот пример
вы услышали имена моих клиентов нет вы поняли хотя бы одного где-то идентифицировали отлично
Значит, у меня хорошо получается с этим справляться.
Чего прошу и вас очень желаю.
Очень желаю сохранять безопасность с вашими клиентами.
Контракт на конфиденциальность.
Если вдруг случайно вы встретились в отпуске, на улице, где угодно,
для себя, как кучи, как тренера,
запомните, вы даете обратную связь, улыбку, знак, понимание.
едете вы летите в одном самолете с ними только после того как ваш клиент дал вам
информацию что он вас индифицировал я понятно говорю об этом это очень важно возможно вам
об этом будут рассказывать как-то по-другому но возьмите пожалуйста мой опыт я очень вас
прошу объяснено очень-очень обратите на это внимание это единые мировые стандарты в работе
с другими людьми ни одной личной информации все кейсы обезличены название компании обезличены
если мой клиент сказал ты можешь меня публиковать я даю тебе разрешение пожалуйста публикуй только
Тогда хорошо. Окей. Самое главное я вам сказала. Головное сказала. Подсумки подвела. Идем дальше. Все
поняла? Хорошо. Смотрите, я хотела вам рассказать о том, как вообще контракты, они формировались в
В транзакционном анализе вы уже понимаете, что относительно Эрика Берна это я окей, ты окей.
Мы вместе взрослываем, ответственность на 50% на каждом из нас.
И мы таким образом работаем.
Давайте сейчас вернемся к вам, к вашей истории.
Я предлагаю вам небольшую рефлексию в парах, где вы подумайте о том, что, например, у вас не работает.
Что у вас не работает в общении с другими людьми, да, или в бизнесе, если вы занимаетесь бизнесом?
Что на самом деле, вот то, что мы сегодня, Василий, уже проговаривали, да, от вас хочет клиент?
Чи он хочет поддержки, чи он хочет нормализации, чи он хочет вопросов?
И почему ваш контракт не сработал, или разговоры с кем-то не сработали, или были понятны конечные результаты?
Интересная работа.
Последите, пожалуйста, что там у вас есть, берите любые кейсы, или рабочие, или личные, или домашние, все что угодно.
то берем любую договоренность, лучше про бизнес, если вы в этом учаетесь, и начинаем думать, почему это не сработало,
находим опору, взросление и пишем, что будем делать по-другому в следующий раз.
На все про все у нас будут швидкие вправы, 8 минут, по 4 минуты на каждого.
Працуем в парах.
Супер, я створю залы.
Молодец, дуже дякую.
Скажите, будь ласка, ещё разочек слайд.
Показываю.
Дякую.
Будь ласка.
Да, слушайте, интересно, столько пиклований, я занотовала себе сразу расклад.
Добрый, супер, возможно, у вас не было.
Ана, с этим таймингом все хорошо, да, если запозднилась или затрималась 2 минуты плюс, если пошли, то я все себе посмотрела, что мы до 15.30, потом у нас перерва, но, кстати, хочу сказать единственное, нужно делать между этими встречами небольшую перерыв, хотя бы 5 минут, 1,5 часа на обучение, очень большое напряжение может быть.
Добрый день. У нас сейчас в зале, поэтому тут осталось совсем мало времени. Я вас не буду уже призначать до жадной залы. И также подпишите себя именем и фамилией.
Не слышно.
Секундочку, прошу прощения. Каждый раз она переписывает имя. Сейчас где-то найду, где оно стационарно, потом будет.
Будем смотреть, передам Анастасии, что и справдии.
Я скажу сразу, то, что у меня есть, то, что у меня есть.
Година 15, мы отдыхаем хотя бы 5 минут, хотя бы пописать и сбегать к кому-то.
Это обычная нормальная вещь.
А потом водички взять, потому что теряется внимание.
Да, возможно.
Кстати, давайте я запишу нотки, и мы...
Можно сделать, например, первую эту перерыв, которая есть, не 30 минут, а 20 минут. Ей достаточно, чтобы поесть.
И распределить еще между этими двумя часами.
Между тем, 10 минут дать на отдых.
Година 15, мозг, он ловит информацию.
Година 30, уже немножко тяжелее.
Люди втомлены, они засиделись, им тяжело.
Даже если они общаются в кабинетах, им действительно тяжело.
Воздух большой.
А информации слишком много.
Очень слишком много информации.
Поэтому нужно немного отдохнуть.
Значит, такая компетентная информация.
Это же не просто послушать, надо вникнуть, и мозг уже просто на отказе.
А, от Кати, да?
Да, да.
Потом говорят, что я не могу, я втомился, да, ну, то есть, очень большой такой потек, если ты действительно работаешь, да, там, не на вайпе, таком релаксе, там, давайте поговорим просто, как вы, а если ты передаешь много информации, я бы сделала бы так, да, такую рекомендацию, то есть, 12.30, там, 12.50, и далее эти 10 минут нужно просто перенести между этими встречами.
Будем смотреть, потому что вчера я смотрела, у нас была встреча с Ланой, и мне уже было даже тяжело так рассматривать, потому что, ну, действительно, очень насыщенный график, и тем более, когда они по 2 часа сидят, немного тяжело можно воспринимать эту информацию.
Никто не понимает. Сразу говорю, у меня уже был опыт многих разных с тем временем семинаров, и я для себя сделала эту структуру.
Година 15, отдохнули, 10 минут хотя бы, година 15, отдохнули. У меня всегда по 15 минут перерывки, все поели, все попили, салат кто-то ел, кто-то отдохнул, кто-то ходил, общался, решил все дела.
потому что потом начинаются кордоны, да, порушение кордонов, не из-за того, что человек ничемный, а из-за того, что она уже утомилась.
Ей на только секундочку, я тут подпишу.
Вот могу открывать наступный модуль, чтобы было уже всем так комфортнее.
Да, можно начать там немного раньше, да, но я сегодня думала даже про это, да, там, начало с Европы, это на час раньше,
Но я смотрела, у меня и из Нью-Йорка в 2 часа присоединились, если есть мотивация.
То есть, просто так, поделить пары, сделать их не очень большими.
У нас кто-то в залах по трое вышло сейчас, потому что они начали присоединиться, и тут не достаточно.
Все нормально, все нормально, они, главное, себе проговорят, кто не стих, не жаль, так бывает.
Но ничего страшного нет, потому что мы повторяем какую-то информацию, через другой фокус мы закрепляем то же самое.
У нас еще 40 секунд, я уже буду закрывать сейчас зал.
Я вижу, я уже разобрала этот кайф, когда я вижу 36 секунд, 34 сверху, там в иконочке я.
А, и такая еще штука у меня тут выскакивает.
Зал 1, зал 2.
Угу, угу.
Прикольно.
Так, то есть, нужно все сделать, как вообще, с нуля.
Хорошо, сделаем.
Как вы? Что вы поняли? Есть какие-то вопросы?
И по капитальным акциям для меня, я буду на русском, это для меня первая такая информация, но очень интересно, верно читала, тоже понять это было очень сложно, я пересчитала, наверное, раза 4, сначала 20 лет мне было, потом 5, с каждым разом я думала, сейчас я глубже войду, но все равно нужно больше знаний, мне понравилось, что мы сокращаем, потому что это мой главный пич, я не умею сокращать информацию,
когда курс, это все так объемное,
люди не понимают, а вот так вот,
как вы говорите, вернитесь к одному слову,
что это, что это, что это, вот, стыдно
говорить, особенно даже, если это надо там
потом в массы, да, в рилс или
что-то, я не могу составлять рилс, потому что
мне надо все рассказать, видимо, теряют
эту мысль по дороге уже.
Только одну фразу услышала,
спасибо, структурируем,
ставим точку.
Все, Миша,
мой момент, за которым я пришла.
Василий, слушаю. Не слышу, не слышу, потому что глухая, нет микрофона.
Спасибо, уже слышите. У меня вопрос практически по кейсу. У меня была клиентка, проходила мой курс, и она ехала к человеку, и она завагитнила, она год не могла завагитнить.
И я ей спросил, ты ей сказала, это благодаря твоему проекту, мыслению и т.д. и т.п. И я ей спросил, может ли я озвучивать твой пример без имен, без ничего? Она забронила, пока не родится, ну, в основном, пока не родится ребенок. И я не имею права это все равно озвучивать без имен, без кто, что и как, потому что она четко сказала, что нет и все. Правильно?
Так, все верно, она можно.
Жаль, дякую.
Потому что, когда она будет следовать за твоей страничкой, а у нас клиенты и не следуют за нашими страничками, то будет тебе кредит, если сказать.
А тет-а-тет в коле других людей тоже все равно лучше не делать?
Нет. Смотрите, вот сейчас у нас пространство. Началось все с чего? С моего контракта с вами на конфиденциальность. Я спросила, все согласны? Если кто-то не согласен, я бы не начинала дальше проводить семинар, даже с уважением к вам.
Вы мне все пообещали, говорим только про себя.
Это понятно, я еще раз на этом наголошу.
Хотите идти, хотите нести это в массы, я говорю про себя.
Никакого кейса.
А мне моя соседка сказала по комнате.
А мне кто-то рассказал.
Нет.
Просто нет.
Это про безопасность.
Говорю про себя.
Все, что хочу, говорю.
Нет разрешения, не могут это сказать.
Это понятно.
Вот это главное. Знаете, почему? Сейчас расскажу вам.
Один одного мы на 93% считаем невербально.
Вы ко мне пришли, вы только 7% слушаете то, что я вам говорю.
Все остальное вы уже из меня считали.
Если я вышла и начала о вас рассказывать, все это знают.
Не думайте, что люди дурные.
Будьте с повагою до них.
Это всегда так. Так оно и есть.
Есть исследование, на 93% мы считаем один одного невербального,
то есть без слов.
Поэтому моя концепция очень простая.
Я не брешу, я говорю все, что думаю, сразу прямо.
Потому что и не проговорю за спиной иншой людины,
Вы, как будущие коучи, ничего плохого.
Занотуйте это себе.
Даже если вас накрыло хвилей, вам было тяжело работать с этой людьми.
Вы пришли и сказали мне, Влад, я уже не могу, все, все, капец, не могу.
Я сама заплачу деньги, чтобы вы только не видели эту организацию, эту людьми.
Вы говорите это только так, тут и с повагою.
Один с одним, когда мы разговариваем, даже в группе, мы говорим только с позиции «я окей, ты окей».
Не можно обговоривать за спинами других, потому что у вас не будет клиента.
Это понятно?
Я бы не пришла к человеку, который бы выключил зум и пошла мне сказать, какая я не такая. И вы бы не пришли к таким.
Поэтому я вас очень прошу, будьте честными и честными.
Спасибо. Лера.
Если можно, я поделюсь своим опытом и кейсом, касательно это делиться или не делиться.
Когда заборонено поделиться, даже какие-то похожие кейсы, то есть это не твой, но человек может где-то какую-то долю читать и подумать, что это могло бы быть про нее, и также могут быть вопросы.
Хотя ты честно про другую женщину, там, где позволили, там, где все окей, что-то там отгукнуло, пошли какие-то свои интерпретации, а это вот у меня там что-то было, и иногда также возникают вопросы, поэтому я пытаюсь даже споредненно, в общем-то, эту тему не высказывать, потому что могут читать и сказать, все же таки я там для себя зловила что-то про меня.
Так, и оно так может быть.
До речи, Василий, знаешь, как я говорю всегда, у меня есть своя хмаринка где-то на небе,
когда кто-то что-то от меня получил что-то доброе.
То есть я не буду говорить про это, если мне человек не позволяет.
Я себе где-то скажу, боже, как круто, как классно, благодаря моему мыслению,
родилась дитина.
Это что, офигенно, скажи?
То есть ты уже дедушка.
Дедушка, понимаешь, это офигенно, потому что когда я смотрю на тех людей, на те пары, которые встретились, и когда мне на мой день рождения отправляют фото моих, до которых я присоединена, то я же такая бабушка, уже сто лет мне в обед, и ты идешь, и ты чувствуешь кайф.
Поэтому молчим, это этика. У нас не будет такого семинара про этику, но я бы действительно вас научила делать это круто. Как работать с эротикой, как работать, когда ты увидел или не увидел клиента, это общие стандарты в мире.
Когда я проверяю какие-то экзамены своих студентов в Европе, да,
с никакой информацией.
Кстати, главное, если у вас есть пара, мужчины, женщины и дети,
особенно любимые, ваши партнеры,
привчите сразу, в какой специализации вы работаете.
То есть, если к вам подошел клиент, женщины или мужчины,
и говорит, например, там, к Василию подбегала какая-то девочка,
И он говорит, ооо, Вася, я так рада тебя видеть, чтобы тут женщина его не убила.
Как только эта клиентка пошла, это может быть.
Вы хорошие женщины и мужчины.
Если у вас есть клиент, и он запросил эту конфиденциальность, и вы, например, это реальные кейсы из жизни.
Сижу где-то в ресторане на своем отдыхе, поехала в отпуск.
Мой любимый мне говорит, Владуся, смотри, что-то на тебя один человек смотрит.
Я говорю, не знаю, не знаю, не понимаю.
Он смотрит же очень.
Ты его не знаешь, не знаешь.
То есть, учите, чтобы кто на вас не смотрел.
Ваши любимые, ваши половины не делали вам потом после этого вопроса.
Кто это? Что это? Кто пришел? Как пришел?
И откуда ты его знаешь?
Учите сразу поводить себя чумно.
Как это выглядит?
Я работаю с людьми.
Это то, что я делаю каждый день.
Поэтому, пожалуйста, любимый, любимая, не волнуйся.
Ты для меня единственная.
Но когда ко мне кто-то подходит и со мной общается,
мы всегда приветствуем чумно,
Мы говорим «так» и делаем вид, будто это кто-то из моих знакомых, друзей из университета или где-то еще.
Понятно? Этот посыл коммуникации.
Нет же никаких вопросов?
Или есть?
Хорошо. Не брешите никогда. Говорим «добре».
Свои половинки, пожалуйста, подготовьте.
И детей также подготовьте, чтобы никто не кричал там, а моя мама коуч, она всех ликует, чтобы такого не было.
Просто сделайте это вовремя, потому что вы будете работать в этой профессии много лет, это ваш опыт, это ваша компетенция, это ваше обличие как профессионала.
Все хорошо? Все понятно? Я могу идти дальше, да?
Смотрите, мое задание познакомить вас не только с транзактным анализом,
а показать, что в нем есть еще такие вайпы, разные школы.
Есть классика, вот то, что мы с вами сегодня говорили про Эрика Берна.
Он сказал, контракт, это я и ты, мы вместе взрослеем, все ок.
Но есть очень классные, интересные другие направления в транзакционном анализе.
То есть отношенческий ТА. Что это такое? Сейчас я вам покажу. И такое может быть в бизнесе. И вы можете как сами, как бизнесмены, например, когда вы работаете со своей компанией, выбрать свой собственный стиль руководства, как он может выглядеть.
То есть, реляционный, да, и он выглядит через то, что мы сначала формуем контакт, и контракт мы формуем только после того, как у нас произошли отношения.
Отношения относительно мы поняли один с одним.
Потому что за классической школой это просто договор. За отношениями – это когда мы становимся более глубоким контактом одним с одним.
Например, если мы смотрим на бизнес, это стиль лидера, который не кидается сразу, так, ну-ка давай, сколько денег мы сделаем.
Это про то, что он ставит связок, то есть, когда вы с ним видите, когда вы его научаете, вы ему скажете, давай мы будем с тобой взрослеть автономных людей.
И тебе нужно, или это твой стиль, научиться говорить так.
Как ты видишь свою роль?
Это про автономию.
Что тебе важно в нашей работе?
Какой у тебя есть опыт в этом?
И как ты это будешь делать?
Поняли разницу?
За классикой мы сразу записываем результат.
За реляционным ТА, за отношением, мы делаем контакт,
то есть добавляем дополнительные вопросы.
Что для тебя важно, как ты себя в этом видишь,
и потом, как ты это реализуешь.
Как вы думаете, что лучше будет работать?
Другая, да. На мой взгляд, да. У нас сейчас все такие уже развиненные, прошаренные. Людям не всегда нужна только одна структура. Знаете, как я говорю? Структура – это не душа, это не отношения.
Структура дает спокойствие, но пока мы не понимаем, что другая людина для нас безопасна, мы не хотим с ней проговорить очень важные вещи.
И сейчас мы возвращаемся относительно этого контакта к этой школе, там, где про отношения, про отношения, к очень интересной информации, о которой есть контракты.
Вот то, что сегодня
Записывал
Ну, запитывал Василь
Есть проясняющий контракт
Это информация за Шерлотой Силс
Это, когда к нам пришел клиент
И он говорит
Я не знаю, чего я хочу
Но он может
Описать свои, знаете, какие-то эмоции
Какие-то реакции
Но не понимает
И в чем есть проблема?
То есть есть прояснение.
Нам нужно задавать ему вопрос таким образом, чтобы он понял, что он от нас хочет получить.
То есть прояснение.
Это означает так.
А в чём проблема на твой взгляд?
В чём история, которую ты хочешь решить?
И есть другой контракт, очень интересный контракт – поведенковый.
Клиент понимает, что именно он хочет изменить.
Тут нас все, что находится, что не зрозумело, а тут в нас за цеею осью уже есть,
что мы отримали классно у клиента, что он понимает, что он хочет изменить.
Т.е. в первой части мы исследовали, не исследовали, а объяснили, вот так правильно,
объяснили какие есть ожидания, а в другой он, например, нам говорит, я хочу
Я хочу изменить то и то, и то, и то, и это называется поведенковым контрактом. Понятно?
Например, берем такой случай. Не может понять совсем наш клиент, в чем есть проблема.
Вот не понимает, он сидит и говорит, я не могу понять, я не могу объяснить, я не могу.
мы с ним договоримся о исследовательском контракте. Как это выглядит? То есть, человек понимает, что
у него есть боль. Каждый из вас понимает, где ему болит. Вы же понимаете, что вам болит? Когда вам болит,
вы понимаете это? И я понимаю. То есть, вы понимаете боль, но мы делаем контракт, что мы исследуем,
Звідки ця біль прийшла до вас? Звідки прийшла ця проблема?
Тобто ми домовляємось про дослідницький контракт, коли ми анализуємо,
звідки це прийшло і як це можна назвати.
Й є дуже класний контракт, який є в організаціях, і він класно працює, на зрутання.
Вот вы сейчас к нам пришли, да, и исследовать, и объяснить, и изменить свою поведенку, и взрослеть.
То есть вы делаете запрос на раскрытие своего потенциала, опыта, на взросление, на формирование автономии.
Все понятно в этом?
Все понятно. То есть, есть четыре разных уровня контракта. Вы можете заключить любой с кем-то.
Хорошо. Идем дальше. Контракт может быть журналистическим. Так, Ира, слушаю.
Скажи, пожалуйста, мы имеем эти виды контракта, которые заключаются, то есть это время разговора с клиентом.
То, что он приходит с запросом, мы для себя понимаем, какой это вид контракта.
А ему, например, мы не передаем, что сейчас мы будем с тобой исследовать вот такой, то есть контракт будет у нас исследовательский или еще какой-то.
У нас для себя определение, в каком мы секторе находимся и какие вопросы, какая стратегия должна быть построена для клиента. Правильно я понимаю?
Для клиента это мы понимаем для себя, а потом говорим нашему клиенту. Я вижу, что мы сейчас не можем понять, в чем есть проблема.
Да, это действительно так? Да. Хорошо, как вы ставитесь к тому, чтобы мы исследовали, что есть проблема?
Ну, поискали, да, сформировали это все. Да, это классная идея. Хорошо, тогда давайте с вами договоримся, что сейчас, на следующую встречу,
которая должна быть следующей, мы будем исследовать, почему и что есть проблема.
То есть, тут мы будем задавать много вопросов.
То есть, другим форматом, но мы ему показываем, какую мы стратегию выбираем вместе с ним.
Да, Ира, я не понимаю, с чем мне работать, и я ему это проговорю. Я не знаю, он не знает, а я откуда знаю.
Да, я же не могу знать, в чем у него, где его болит, поэтому я всегда задаю вопрос, сейчас мы не поняли, это очень хорошо, но мы знаем, что мы можем исследовать.
Хорошо, исследовали, нотировали, класс, мы уже знаем проблему, что вы хотите изменить, да, вы знаете, что с этим делать, да, я понимаю, я хочу понять, там, например, у меня есть проблемы в общении с профессионалом, да, там, с другими людьми,
они не хотят со мной общаться, я не могу их мотивировать.
Хорошо, что вы хотите изменить?
Я думаю, что я могу изменить, что для вас лучше, поведение, например.
Хорошо, а какие вы к этому?
Давайте подумаем, почему ваш персонал от вас освободится?
Потому что я гневаюсь.
О, то у нас уже есть проблема.
То есть мы исследовали, что от вас идет персонал,
потому что вы гневливая личность.
Вы с Люкой. Ну, если между нами.
То давайте с вами
разъясним, что мы изменим
в вашей поведенце, чтобы они
с вами остались. Я не знаю,
что мы можем изменить.
Пусть они подлаждаются.
Пусть работают.
Хорошо, но вы видите, что это не работает.
Хорошо, хорошо, не работает.
А что же работает?
А я-то знаю, что работает. А вы знаете,
что для вас работало? Нет.
Это ваша работа. Нет, это не
моя работа, это ваша работа. Давайте
подумаем, как вы будете
сполкуватись с иншими таким чином,
чтоб вони ставилися
до вас повагою и не боялися.
Ну, добре, добре,
я буду их хвалить чистейше.
Добре, а как часто вы их хвалите?
Ну, он три месяца
тому написал своей команде,
что они крути,
что они молодцы.
Я говорю, это офигенно.
Три месяца
тому, да?
Все как три месяца тому
идти на встречу и думать, что он меня ждет, потому что я его жду. Классно, супер. А что, не
можно чаще? Нет, не можно, мотивацию терять. Хорошо. А если вам что-то хорошо сказать раз в три месяца? Нет,
что-то мне это не подходит. Мне нужно это чаще делать. И вот так вы переналожтируете, например, его
поведенку с разуме лапши макрос контракт это то паши и кобула там я как с законами юрист
менеджера контракт четко сада и что за растут просто за себя на ксерос это по-иншему ира
и надели у дымы и с вами кожи нас ведь чувак якусь бель нам шось болеть або мы мае му проблему а
Або нам что-то так, и мы не понимаем, что так.
Поэтому нам нужен час, чтобы понять, с чем мы будем работать.
И это не вы за них делаете, это они за себя делают.
А вы задаете хорошие вопросы, как вас научили вчера.
Поняла?
Я рада этому, очень рада, что тут у нас еще в чате.
Так, все нормально, все погодились, идем дальше.
То есть есть жесткость, есть мягкая договоренность, мы смотрим на это и мы это изменяем.
Смотрите, есть очень интересная вещь, она также классно работает в бизнесе, то есть не только о отношениях, а и о динамике, есть такой психодинамический транзакционный анализ.
Что это такое?
Заткнулись мы, две люди. Это такие разные школы, хочу вас сразу научить, чтобы вы это поняли.
И мы взрослые, но мы работаем с человеком на трёх уровнях.
То есть это то, что будет происходить с нами в контакте с другой людьми.
«Чи було в вас колысь» – это три уровня контракта.
Его придумали Мозе и Новеллино.
И мы работаем всегда на трех уровнях.
Тобто, что есть между нами сейчас?
Как ты действуешь в своем жизни сейчас?
С другими.
И как это повторяет твой опыт с прошлого?
Сейчас остановлю и все расскажу так, чтобы вы поняли.
Когда мы с вами общаемся, встречаемся,
вы даете себе время посмотреть на то, что сейчас происходит между нами в отношениях.
Чи вам цикаво, чи вам не цикаво.
Чи ви можете тримати контакт, чи ви не можете тримати контакт.
Тобто шо відбувається з вами зараз.
Те, що є між нами зараз, ви де саме робите з іншими людьми навколо вас.
Иногда мне говорят, слушай, что-то у меня как-то так, ну, нет такого контакта с другими.
Но когда мы встречаемся на встрече, человек не держит контакт, он поводится так сверху, ему неинтересно.
Она закрыта, она даже не делает эти шаги до контакта.
Она смотрит там, я не знаю, свой телефон сто раз, двести раз на кота, пятьсот раз, я не знаю, на кого-то другого.
но она не в контакте со мной, ей даже не интересно или ей страшно устанавливать со мной контакт.
Это означает, что так же она делает с другими, с всеми, кто вокруг нее, потому что это единственная копинг-стратегия.
И как этот опыт, почему этот опыт пришел к ней и как он коррелируется с ее детством?
Это повторение
Так, как было в детстве
Так мы будем общаться в взрослом жизни
И так мы общаемся с другими
Если Сео кричит
То на Сео кричали в детстве
Единый способ коммуникации
Это контроль и гнев
Вы же иногда видели руководителей компаний, когда они начинают только контролировать. У меня единственное вопрос, когда он сейчас меня контролирует в нашей разговоре, как он контролирует других людей вокруг себя и кто его с детства сам контролировал.
Я понятно вам объясню?
Это очень классный опыт для понимания через контакт
с другим человеком, что у него было.
И эти три уровня, они всегда повторяются.
Завжди, если человек не прошел психотерапию, не прошел какие-то свои личные возрастания, не изменился, или у него не было какой-то очень важной жизненной кризис.
Потому что если он кричит все жизнь, как этот белый леденец, и ему никто не сказал, слушай, мне с тобой неприятно общаться, потому что иногда вы как-то будете конфронтироваться с вашим клиентом.
У меня был один клиент, он есть еще и до сих пор, но с ним очень прикольно, он, когда не в гуморе, не в душе, он говорит, так, все, все, я наговорился, все, достаточно, все, мне достаточно, мне достаточно уже, я не хочу разговаривать, сколько мне еще нужно перерабатывать тебе денег, я не хочу, все.
Мы можем закончить нашу встречу, особенно, когда я ему что-то не очень приятное говорю, то, что нужно для того, чтобы он взрослел. Я говорю, шшш, остановись, что ты сейчас делаешь?
Ничего, я уже утомился, я не буду с тобой общаться, я не хочу с тобой общаться, я не хочу, я говорю, я тебя уважаю, ты можешь со мной не общаться, но смотри, что в тебе за трэш происходит в жизни, если что-то происходит не так, как ты захотел, то что, ты дальше не общаешься, ты не хочешь даже про это поговорить?
Ты не проговоришь это ни со своими подлогами, ни со своей дружиной, ни со своими детьми. Давай пофантазируем, до чего это дойдет на конец твоего жизни.
Он говорит, ну, хорошо, все, умолкла, я вернусь.
Я говорю, я не умолкла тебя, я знаю, что ты сейчас такой, ты сердитый, я тебя понимаю,
не все так классно, как бы ты хотел, так, я тебя поддерживаю, я понимаю тебя.
Это нормально, давай немного остаемся и немного еще поговорим.
Я же сказала, я не хочу.
Я говорю, я тебя поняла, давай, выдыхай и продолжим.
Вы понимаете? Есть этот опыт. Как это было в его прошлом?
Его родина, когда он общался, никогда его не слушала.
И когда действительно была очень большая проблема, что делала его родина, дитячая, в которой он вырос?
Ваш вариант ответа.
Скажите, Маша, скажите. Да, можно там голос сказать, да.
Только криком он мог как-то думать, что его почувствуют, и на него кричали.
Молодцы, гениусы. Поняли, как работают три уровня контракта.
Почему вы приходите, и вы, как тот локатор, начинаете общаться с другими людьми, с собой, и потом настроите это все.
Хорошо, давайте для того, чтобы переключить внимание, вы сейчас пойдете в личные кабинеты в двойках на 6 минут, по 3 минуты в каждую сторону.
И подумайте, пролинкуйте то, что я вам рассказала относительно этих трех уровней, да, здесь, сейчас, с другими и детство.
И вспомните, возможно, какие-то кейсы, которые подтверждают эту информацию.
Доброе?
Понятно?
Можете посмотреть на друзей,
можете посмотреть на клиентов,
можете посмотреть на кого-либо.
Я бы вообще вам дала пабрейт,
но еще очень рано,
когда мы начинаем общаться
и объединяемся один с одним.
Посмотреть на общение один с одним
в контакте сейчас.
Но на это нужно больше времени.
Если вы хотите, вы можете сделать другой вариант этой работы.
Посмотреть, как вам разум в комнате.
И подумать.
Это для тех, кто хочет какого-то высшего обрейта, кому неинтересно вспомнить про прошлое.
Посмотреть, как вам сейчас эта людина.
Но говорим один к одному, очень нежно, очень с уважением и говорим так, у меня есть такая фантазия, такая фантазия, но нужно немножко подналаштоваться один к одному.
что тебе со мной сейчас или интересно, или не интересно.
В твоем жизни, которое вокруг, у тебя такое же происходит с другими?
И все, на этом ставим крапку.
К родителям не идем, хорошо?
Домоглись, потому что это опасно.
Все, давайте, делайте любую работу на выбор,
то буке из клиента оба у тебя на велики да такие рефлексии один за одним на все про все
удвичках давайте 8 холонок раз висим холоночек по двое в паре по двое в ким нахи даку
Елена, мы вас дадим третью
до кого-то.
А, возможно, и
вот тут постараемся.
В шестой зал.
и такие красавчики и красивые
что-то мама твоя пришла
юлия заросли открыли двери закрыли там собака стоит
проход у кого-то висит и висит и в руках и меня хорошей девчонка
это у них старшая собака зашла и провела я
лада а я не пойму меня не подключили комнате потому что я вижу вас и ваш собаку я знаю ли
он я тоже вас вижу хоть на вас посмотрю знаете я не знаю наверно пока еще форму формируется ссылки
я так думаю, выкинула с комнаты. А, выкинула, Лен, наверное, там надо как-то по-другому перезаходить,
я не особенно сильна в этом, да, по-моему, надо зайти в какую-то другую комнату, а потом пойти туда,
но если вы не зайдете, можете со мной отрефлексировать, я только в радость. Давайте с вами,
потому что я понимаю, что я тоже не очень сильно в этих переходах. Да, ну давай, давайте с вами,
как для вас вот то, что есть контакт, да, мы сидим сейчас, вы на меня смотрите, я на вас смотрю.
Это очень приятно вас слушать, очень приятный голос, очень приятная информация.
Ну, он пишет мне, что додали меня, но что-то я не вижу, что мне додали. Ну, ладно.
Там нужно было уйти, у вас там с повещения такое приходит, и вы могли уйти.
Я нажала на него.
Поступным разом выйдет все.
Ну, в следующий раз вообще я не вижу в этом никакой проблемы. Никакой, Лен, абсолютно.
Вообще без проблем, но мне что-то сделать надо.
Да, Лен, знаете, что интересно?
Я могу очень интересный формат вернуть.
Бывает ли у вас в жизни так,
ну, это я так размышляю, чисто гипотетически,
что вы, например, готовы что-то сделать,
но вдруг потом вас выкинуло с этого процесса?
Ну, отлично.
Нет, нет, нет, бывает ли так?
Бывает ли так?
Ну, бывает, конечно,
но не так, чтобы глобальные какие-то процессы.
По мелочам, да, бывает.
По мелочам, вот, классно.
Ну, хотите, дам тоже классную, интересную рефлексию, ну, ВКонтакте, да, с вами, раз мы остались.
Знаете, я наблюдала за вами, и мне было интересно на вас смотреть, я видела, что есть какие-то технические изменения, да, возможно, я думаю, интересно, вы зайдёте, вы не зайдёте, вы есть там или нет, но когда остаёшься с вами ВКонтакте, вот в этом, да, то, что есть здесь и сейчас, действительно возникает заинтересованность, и мне понравилось, как вы сразу сказали, а почему я не зашла, Влад, а можно?
Ну-ка, расскажите, это очень было и структурированное, и тепло.
Ну, нормально, да, то есть классно.
Нет такого ощущения, что где-то что-то идёт не так.
Хотя, в принципе, ну просто выбило из комнаты.
Как для вас то, что я говорю?
Ну, как отвлекается, конечно, тут вообще как бы в моей жизни нет проблем.
Есть вопросы, которые надо решать.
Это я уже давно себе взяла, и поэтому, ну, значит, так должно быть.
Я рада, я правда рада.
Получается ли у вас в отношениях с другими людьми то же самое,
когда бывает, что иногда вас выкидывают из контакта с ними,
ну, например, да, но вы делаете первый шаг, и дальше всё стабилизируется?
Не бывает, что меня выкидывают.
То есть я делаю свои выводы, да, если у нас какое-то недоразумение с кем-то там происходит,
и я просто отхожу на расстояние вытянутой руки.
Вот у меня в жизни...
В моей жизни я никогда ни с кем не поругалась, просто мы отошли.
Но если я встречаю на улице человека, я всегда могу поздороваться,
то есть я не прихожу на сторону.
Окей, тогда раз мы вместе с вами, можете ли вы, например, отрефлексировать такую историю,
что когда у вас что-то не получалось в вашей родительской семье,
было ли у вас так, что вы просто отходили в сторону?
я там всю жизнь была в стране да я знаю могу я вам дать классный такой апгрейт классную
вещь которую вам стоит делать ой конечно даже спрашивайте почему мне это не получилось и
возвращайтесь в контакт с другим человеком не переходите на другую сторону не отходите от людей
спасибо пожалуйста как для вас то что было сейчас фиксируют но это как бы чуть-чуть как переход все
таки какой-то вот сейчас сейчас попробую как сформулировать не могу сказать что это
Это непривычная ситуация для меня будет, но не выход из зоны комфорта.
Это просто определенный вывод, вот так, наверное.
Я рада. Используйте этот вывод.
На следующем модуле расскажите, какие у вас новости. Хорошо?
Да, хорошо. Спасибо большое.
Отлично, супер. Аня, я слухаю.
Хотела бы вернуться к этому заданию, задать вопрос.
Давайте.
Я так понимаю, что мы должны были фиксировать у человека, с которым мы ведем беседу.
Абсолютно верно. Можем так или кейс.
Да, но у меня тогда такой вопрос.
Если с разными людьми мы же ведём себя по-разному.
Абсолютно верно.
С некоторыми нам становится скучно,
а с некоторыми мы в запое вот так садимся, слушаем и не можем переслушать.
То есть всё же зависит от того, насколько полезен нам человек.
Ну, будем говорить откровенно, да,
каждая коммуникация нанесёт для нас некую выгоду,
эмоциональную, ментальную, финансовую, любую.
То есть если мне человек неинтересен,
он ничего не может мне дать.
Конечно, мне будет с ним скучно.
Аня, есть один секрет.
Хотите, расскажу?
Да.
Если этот человек вам неинтересен,
значит, он был неинтересен в своей родительской семье.
Всё просто.
Есть люди, Аня, когда ты видишь,
ты смотришь на них,
и ты не можешь рот закрыть,
насколько тебе интересно.
Тебе хочется просто побыть с этим человеком.
Ты успокаиваешься, ты растёшь, тебе интересно, тебе в кайф, тебе в удовольствие.
Ты посидел и ушёл, и ты такая думаешь, какой кайф.
Было же такое? Независимо от денег.
Ну да, но мы получили другую эмоциональную выгоду.
Но эмоциональная выгода иногда намного дороже денег,
Потому что тут деньги ты взял, использовал, и они ушли, а ощущение осталось.
Аня, я про вот эту историю, насколько интересно с другим человеком,
и как это будет фонить с его историей из родительской семьи.
Хорошо, а если со мной человек, один человек со мной чувствует себя безумно скучным,
а с другим человеком, другой человеком...
Классный вопрос, классный вопрос, очень классный вопрос.
Это будет следующими нашими темами, когда мы встречаем людей, с которыми нам интересно, на кого из людей из нашего прошлого они нам очень похожи.
Ну правильно, получается, что если эти два человека по-разному ко мне отреагируют, то это же не говорит о том, что у моей семьи было вот так.
Было и так, и так, Аня, абсолютно верно это значит.
Это значит, что, например, ну, вы сидели, да, там, мы сидим, коммуницируем друг с другом.
Например, там, мама была в восторге от коммуникации с вами, сидела и слушала.
Ну, например, да, гипотетически, допустим, вы, например, с женщинами похожего типа, руководителями, тоже можете легко установить контакт.
там например с кем-то кто похож может быть это и не женщина это может быть
мужчина может быть кто угодно вы с этим человеком восторге потому что он вам
резонирует с кем-то из вашей родительской семье а с папой или там с
дедом до был не очень хороший контакт и если вдруг у вас появился seo который
собран и напоминает, ну, у меня в жизни такие кейсы очень часто происходят, да,
у меня часть моей семьи, она была очень строгая, структурированная,
очень такая на бизнесе заточенная часть, семья, она была очень эмпатичная.
Поэтому, когда я встречаюсь с кем-то из своих клиентов, я сразу смотрю на отклик,
что есть у меня, это история, часть моей истории, и как ему со мной, это часть его истории.
Ну, то есть в любом случае это про человека, про твоего собеседника.
То есть то, что ему откликается, это его роли, жизни, его паттерны.
Когда он говорит о том, как он функционирует со мной, это его история.
Когда я говорю ему, как мне с ним, это...
Это моя история, конечно.
Ответила на вопрос?
Да, да.
Отлично, отлично. Оля, слушаю.
Спросить, правильно ли я понимаю, если, допустим, человек постоянно перебивает,
ну, не дослушивает фразу до конца и постоянно перебивает,
то это значит, что его родители не слышали,
и ему приходится вот так обратить на себя внимание, да или нет?
Есть несколько вариантов, Оля, классный вопрос.
Первый вариант, когда его родители не слышали,
А второй вариант, когда он из многодетной семьи.
А третий вариант, это когда у него есть драйвер спеши.
О драйверах мы будем говорить позже.
Есть люди, которые не могут дослушать дальше,
потому что они говорят, я не успеваю.
У меня есть один клиент, он владелец огромной корпорации.
Его время необыкновенно, необыкновенно дорого.
Но он больше про структуру.
но мало про то, что наполняет эту структуру.
И он говорит, так, следующий вопрос, так, следующий вопрос, так, следующий вопрос.
И если ты о чём-то говоришь, говоришь, давай вернёмся к тебе
и посмотрим, что это не важно, следующий вопрос.
Но это говорит о многом.
То есть когда он и коммуницирует со своей командой,
его команда сыпалась.
Не все такие про следующий вопрос.
Я говорю, а теперь так, останавливаемся, идем немного не в структуру, а в контакт.
И когда он апгрейднул эту область контакта, весь бизнес изменился.
Они вышли на IPO.
Ответила на вопрос, Оля?
Как вам школа транзактного анализа? Интересно?
Мне хотелось вам просто всё сразу показать, рассказать такие интересные новинки.
Знаете, как можно посмотреть на это по-другому.
Смотрите, есть тоже классная история.
Мы это используем в контексте бизнеса.
Дальше следующая школа, она про интегративность.
То есть как мы находимся партнёры, как партнёры в процессе.
Что здесь главное в этом партнёрстве?
Мы вместе постоянно с тобой меняемся.
То есть мы вместе передоговариваемся про то, что мы будем делать.
Мы установили контакт с другим человеком,
и мы начинаем вместе творить.
Вместе.
То есть наш акцент на вместе.
Ты, я, мы.
И это не про симбиоз, это не про слияние.
Это про то, как две энергии наши объединились,
и мы работаем в контакте с другим человеком
и всё время подсвечиваем его уникальность.
Теперь вопрос на засыпку к вам.
Кто сегодня рассказывал про ценность и про возможность,
да, и про то, что есть?
Это называется интегративно.
Это значит, что мы в контакте с другими людьми.
и мы подсвечиваем уникальность других людей.
Вспомните, пожалуйста, кого-то из бизнес-партнёров,
если нет бизнеса, из своих клиентов.
И запишите, пожалуйста, три уникальные вещи,
которое им присуще.
Занотуйте, будь ласка,
три уникальные речи,
какие им самым притоманны.
Добро.
Зараз апгрейд высшего ревня.
Разбиваемся на пары.
На иначе пары.
На 6 хвилин.
Вы смотрите одна или один на одного.
И говорите две какие-то вещи, которые вам интуитивно понравились вашему співрозмовнику.
Будь-якие.
Можете помолчать вместе минутку.
Можете подивиться один на одного.
Но 2-3 какие-то, ну, то, что вам дух подобен.
Потому что мы иногда мучаемся один с одним.
И не можем, знаете, выдавить один с одним, что нам в другой людьми нравится.
Это понятно?
Ну, если нет камеры, ну и что? Можно же что-то сказать, если нет камеры.
Мы же всё равно как-то разговариваем. Голосом можно поговорить.
Сказать, вот у меня сегодня нет камеры.
Мне очень жаль, прости, не получилось, не сложилось.
А ваша задача, она очень легка и очень важна для вас.
Научиться видеть в другой человеке ее уникальность.
Хотя бы одну вещь занотуйте.
Хорошо?
Открываем залы.
Юрий, вы тут?
Юля, сейчас вернусь, пойду воду себе возьму, потому что уже все хорошо.
Да, все супер. А у вас как?
У меня тоже все хорошо. Очень рада быть с вами в контакте.
И спасибо, что вы мне помогаете. Без вас было бы очень сложно.
Вы, умничка, не утомились?
Нет, Боже, это же только, у меня же всегда семинары, они по 12 часов,
то только одного выкладывания без перерыва, поэтому это окей.
А вы утомились уже?
Нет, нет, не утомилась пока только, очень интересно вы рассказываете.
Хорошо, берите себе водичку.
Да, сейчас вернусь, сейчас, Юля, я вернусь, потому что хочу иногда попить,
а уже нет ничего под стакан. Весьма хорошо?
Конечно.
Доброго дня.
У нас распродел по сессийным залам и осталось буквально 2 минуты,
поэтому я вас не додаю.
Очекаем оттуда.
Гений, как ваши дела? Инсайты есть? Воззрение есть?
Все хорошо. Такой инсайт, мы даже успели проговорить на конец,
как каждому из нас было в моменте этой тишины, что ты почувствовал.
Мне хотелось, даже не голосом, но хотя бы какой-то внешней реакцией
ее заполонить смешкой, каким-то взглядом, и даже в какой-то момент хотелось себе сказать
«Аня, дыхай, просто дыхай, вот в этой тишине, подыхай».
Это круто. Так, это хорошо, хорошо, хорошо, хорошо, очень рада вас всех дальше видеть.
Ну что, готовы? Готовы дальше идти, да?
Возможно, есть какие-то инсайты, зрения, что-то на вас пришло, что-то новенькое.
Я там почитала чат, Александр говорит, что все, готов, все, может сразу хвалить.
Саш, как это происходит? Легко хвалить или нет?
Ну, наверное, пускай Ульяна скажет, это будет тогда объективно.
Просто я сам себя сейчас захвалю, скажу, что мне все легко.
Пускай она скажет, как это получилось.
А, нет, нет, разговор только про себя.
Можно себя похвалить, Саш, я к этому тоже окей.
То есть получается, легко хвалить.
Я поняла.
Да, в целом не сложно.
Окей, хорошо, рада это слышать.
Давайте перейдем дальше, идем далее.
У нас дуже классная речь об рейту для керевников.
Это называется глубинный особистый контракт.
Сейчас я вам его покажу.
Замерел Джеймс.
Это вы можете сделать сейчас сами для себя.
И это очень классно работает в коучинге,
работает в терапии, работает в любом месте.
Как это выглядит?
Вы задаете вопрос сами себе.
На початку, сейчас.
Что вы хотели бы усилить или изменить в своем жизни?
Что тебе нужно изменить для того, чтобы это достигнуть?
Что ты сам будешь делать, чтобы достигнуть этой цели?
Как другие понимают, что ты изменился?
То есть, как я посмотрю, я лично посмотрю твою измену.
То, что мы уже с вами делали, как ты себя обижаешь, вы уже это знаете.
Как ты себя вынагорадишь?
И дадам еще несколько вопросов на будущее.
Как ты будешь проводить время после достижения этой цели?
Где и как ты можешь получить поддержку за свои изменения?
Это понятно?
Вы уже часть этого написали.
Пожалуйста, дайте ответы на вопросы, которые вы еще не записывали.
Потому что у нас есть информация про самосаботаж, у нас есть информация уже про то, как мы себя побалуем, как мы будем радоваться.
Но, пожалуйста, дайте информацию о ваших личных глобальных изменениях.
Что бы вы хотели изменить.
И сразу, Юль, мне нужно разбить нас в пары.
Вы будете и отвечать один одному, и рефлексировать, и занотовывать.
И тогда вы к мне вернётесь уже с пропрацованным этим контрактом.
Это есть и практикой, и инструментом работы.
Юль, на 10 минут в пару, по 5 минут в каждую сторону.
Придумайте, если вы хотите еще какую-то...
Сейчас даю слайд.
Пожалуйста, сделайте скрин.
К сожалению, у вас это все должно быть методично.
Раздрукуйте себе.
Но сделайте слайд.
Да, у нас есть платформа о том, что...
Да, да, все на платформе, все есть, ничего мы не заховали.
Все, на 10 минут.
Хорошо, я тут еще распределяю вас и створю комнату.
Да, не будет, Юля, сегодня вам со мной спокойно.
Будете всегда распределять, встречаться, идти, приходить, ну что делать, такая работа сегодня у нас.
А я миксую, чтобы постоянно были разные.
так так миксером а миксером а донбасс
сайла жена давать
Всё, всё.
Повертаем уже всех назад.
Бачо.
Як вы?
Нормаль? Добре?
Рада это слышать, рада это видеть, рада это понимать.
Сейчас все вернутся.
Есть ли какие-то вопросы?
Нет, хорошо.
Так, Аня, есть вопросы, слушаю.
Здравствуйте, снова я.
После рефлексии.
Я была в качестве задаваемого вопроса.
И у меня такие моменты, то, что я в себе отследила.
Могу ли я подсвечивать и возвращать клиенту то, что я услышала, и интерпретировать на свой лад?
Я спросила, могу ли я вернуть вам то, что я услышала, и подкорректировать.
То есть уже клиент может задать вопрос, откликнулась, не откликнулась.
То есть это не будет считаться навязыванием чего-то своего,
либо включением вот этой экспертности, либо там спасателя.
Отличный вопрос.
И как я себя должна чувствовать?
То есть не помогла ли я ему прийти к этому инсайту?
Или всё-таки я должна была задать этот вопрос для того, чтобы...
Этот вопрос задаётся всегда, правда.
Будьте здоровы.
Будьте здоровы, точно.
вопросы дается в том случае если говорят что да тогда возвращаем если нет мы молчим
если он хотел бы это услышать или получить только в этом случае если не тогда все молчим никому ничего не рассказываем
наш большой секрет
добрый идем далее делиться давайте я
Подводим уже подсумок, почему нам этот контракт в самом бизнесе.
Он снижает тревогу, он выбирает манипуляцию,
потому что мы понимаем, куда мы идем.
Он запобегает симбиозу, то есть нет такого,
что я делаю одна из двух, или другие сливаются,
и он створит ясность.
Какая формула контракта?
Контракт, это как защита, он складывается из нескольких направлений.
Ясность, согласие и взрослость.
Помним, да?
Ясность, четко проговорили, что хотим.
Согласие, как сейчас меня Аня спрашивала,
я могу спрашивать другого,
может ли я вам это подсветить?
Если да, то есть согласие.
И дорослость, это когда мы общаемся как дорослые личности.
То есть, что мы решили,
что мы договорились обоих,
и есть ли у нас пространство коммуницировать просто прямо,
а не ображаться где-то мовчки и там что-то недоговорить.
Это понятно, как формула контракта,
как защита и как ясность.
Так? Так.
Далее.
На что мы
звертаем увагу
за Штайнером
про контракт?
Три-четыре основные
вымоги контракта, будь
какого контракта. Дивимось.
Первое. Взаимная сгода.
То есть мы не гоняемся
за кем-то и не говорим,
сейчас я тебе врятую твой бизнес.
То есть, чтобы не
врятовать друг друга. Взаимная сгода.
Она попросила, я пришла.
Не попросила, я не пришла.
Адекватная
винограда.
То есть то, что будет
давать ресурсы, энергию,
мотивацию делать что-то дальше.
Компетентность.
То есть, чтобы у вас
были навыки
работать с этой компанией
без других людей.
Компетентность, это очень важно. И законность, то есть контракты всегда вкладываются из этического кодекса, это относительно того, что я вам сказала, мы не проговорим истории наших компаний, клиентов без разрешения.
И чинное законодавство.
Если у вас кто-то попросит прийти в организацию и сделать что-то, что есть административной или криминальной ответственностью, что вы скажете?
Нет.
А если скажут, что мы дадим вам много денег?
Какие деньги? Нет. Нет. Нет. Потому что если вы сделаете один раз, все люди сшитят информацию с вас невербально. Это означает, что следующий раз вы притянете такую самую людину, которая будет... Не за какие деньги, да. Это очень разумно.
Смотрите, всегда это проговорите, знаете, для вашей собственной безопасности.
Когда мы встречаем клиента, мы говорим, что существует контракт на конфиденциальность.
Но если есть административная или криминальная ответственность,
за законом вы должны проинформировать других, что это может произойти.
Поэтому вы проговорите, я работаю в межах этического кодекса, я коуч, я понимаю, что такое этика, и согласно законодательству.
Это понятно, потому что это будет в 100 миллионов раз дороже именно для вас.
То есть, когда... Да, Ира?
Сразу у меня вопрос. В течение сессии открыли какую-то речь, которая незаконна.
Поэтому нужно до того, как открыли какую-то речь незаконную,
сказать всем, за чинным законодавством,
и я работаю таким образом, что если есть уголовная ответственность,
криминальная ответственность, я должен про это сказать.
Вы имеете в виду, что это сказать, сообщать органы соответствующие для обвязывания...
Юль, это законодательство нашей Украины и любой европейской Украины, поэтому я всегда говорю клиентам, если вы хотите, чтобы я вам помогла, пожалуйста, знаете, первое, что есть, если есть какая-то криминальная ответственность, то тогда соучастник, я не хочу быть соучастником, да, если кто-то там планирует убийство.
Нет. Два партнера встретились, один на одного ненависть, и начинается мочилово.
Оно вам нужно? Мне нет.
Так, Василий, слушаю.
Если имеется в виду в сотрудничестве с клиентом, склад злочина уже был,
я бы до него не причастен, он просто делится.
Немчего, вот так это стало.
Он не может вам рассказать, Василий, всю историю.
Пусть он рассказает таким образом, чтобы вы его поддерживали,
но историю не знали.
Поэтому для вашей особой безопасности, с всей уважением для вас,
я всегда говорю, когда мы встречаем первый раз клиента,
мы говорим, что мы работаем конфиденциально.
Но я просто хочу наголосить информацию,
что если есть какая-то административная или криминальная ответственность,
я прошу ее меня до этого не притягивать.
То есть, расскажите мне информацию таким образом, чтобы я была или был эффективной для вас.
Но эту часть информации, если она у вас есть, мы же не можем, у нас есть люди очень антисоциальные,
мы не можем им заборонить что-то, что-то не делать, они будут это делать.
Но, пожалуйста, не нужно мне об этом рассказывать.
Далее мы будем говорить, когда есть в компании риск, вам также
риск, знаете, там суициду какого-то, не дай бог, вам также нужно на это будет обратить внимание. Я
Я научу вас, как на это обратить внимание.
Добре?
Трошки позже.
Эта информация, понимаете?
Это важно.
Это ваша особая безопасность.
Я всегда говорю, скажите только то, что можете сказать.
Да, потому что у вас нет психотерапевтов,
но психотерапевты за запросом органов
могут отрабатывать любую информацию.
Поэтому важно получать для себя безопасную информацию.
Это также очень-очень-очень-очень на это обратите внимание.
Еще важно, я вас не боюсь, но думайте всегда, куда вы идете работать.
И с кем.
И если даже вам запропоновали, как коучам, очень большие деньги,
Но завтра у вас не будет, я очень отвертно вам говорю, я говорю вам о том, что было в моей жизни.
Подумайте о том, что вы на это согласны.
Хорошо?
И давайте я вас научу очень хорошей штуке.
Есть иногда такие деньги, которые лучше не получать.
Для меня это очень важно.
Каждый из вас имеет свои личные ценности, но есть деньги, за которые ты потом не будешь очень счастлив.
Ищите сами, с чем вы согласны. Это ваша личная ценность, ответственность.
Но когда идете к клиенту, открыть кейсы, посмотрите, что все было хорошо с его партнерами.
Все живут, все здоровы.
Задается такое
питание, кто там, как закинчивает,
как отбывается атмосфера
далее, как эти контракты
доводятся до конца.
Если, не дай Боже, вы почули,
что кто-то здесь
остановился
не там, где нужно,
помер,
что-то произошло,
пожалуйста, скажите «нет».
Я все разъяснила вам, дала знать,
да? Доброе?
Хорошо. Рада вам это передать. Я вас не боюсь, но это реальная жизнь.
Когда-то мне предлагали работать в команде Януковича.
Я поняла, что это будет, я не знаю, год моей работы, а потом меня не будет.
Я такого не хочу, поэтому и вам этого не предлагаю. Хорошо?
Я очень открыто с вами разговариваю. Пожалуйста, будьте к себе с любовью.
Далее идем.
Вы знаете уже уровни контракта, знаете, как нам работать, какие есть контракты и как мы про все договариваемся.
Посмотрим на этот слайд. Очень классный.
Есть административный контракт, то есть где, когда и как я вижу, сейчас я вам это объясню.
А есть контракт психологичный и профессиональный.
Как они формуются?
Административный контракт, он себя включает.
Как, где, когда мы работаем?
Онлайн, оффлайн, длительность?
Что мы делаем, когда у нас есть форс-мажор?
Кто-то пришел на встречу, отсутствие.
Как даем обратный связок?
Когда действует оплата?
Кто платит? За что платит?
Какая конфиденциальность?
Кто принимает решения?
Кто несет за них ответственность?
И кто я говорю с серым кардиналом?
Кто там главный?
С административным все понятно?
Хорошо, вам нужно сейчас подумать, на каких условиях вы будете работать со своими клиентами.
Дайте ответы сами на эти вопросы.
Какая цена ваших услуг? Сколько вы работаете?
Что будет, когда людина не пришла к вам на встречу?
Когда вы не пришли к ней на встречу?
И какие есть форс-мажоры?
Запозднился.
Как вы будете реагировать, если, например, ваш клиент вызвали его на встречу к президенту?
Чи есть это форс-мажором?
Чтобы не было так, например, что у вас есть договоренность платить, когда сессия не произошла, если вы не продаете себе пакетами.
А человеку когда-то вызвали очень-очень-очень, я не знаю, там, в поважном месте.
Або в человека родилась дитина.
Что вы скажете?
Он едет там до пологого дома.
Так, Саша тут пишет.
Дать свои рекомендации, Саша.
Я думаю, что там не особенно будет рассказывать, да, про рекомендации.
тем более что он клиент обычно когда он придет президенту он показывает что он сам всегда был
таким не это это не его проблемы он точно будет показывать что он таким родился он таким был и
вы лично персонально не всегда имеете к нему отношения потому что очень многих клиентов
есть ощущение стыда да например и они на самом деле не видят ценности иногда в чем-то и не
показывают я таким всегда был у меня были проблемы никогда в жизни я такой вообще с пелёнок
хорошо каждую среду на встречу с президентом но мне нравится
юмор правда даже покажите слайд пожалуйста а так показываем
Занотовали?
Відповіді собі дали?
Я иду далі. Я вам покажу усі рівні контракту, усе, що ми там проговорюємо, шо ми робимо, а далі у вас буде невелика рефлексія.
Відносно професійного рівня, які завдання ми вирішуємо?
Причина, система, проблема.
Приклад. Покращить коммуникацию в команде не про что.
А вот структура, да, ввести что-то в тижневые one-to-one,
научить там трех лидеров давать фидбэк без оценки,
это уже имеет сенс.
Это понятно, как оно должно выглядеть в коммуникации, да?
Добре. Что есть успехом конкретно, мы можем это вымерять, и как мы это проверяем, и когда.
Какие инструменты мы берем для каждой проблемы.
И главное, что есть важное. На что мы не будем вытрачать время.
Это занотовало для себя просто, как информацию.
Это пишет про структуру.
А, видимо, Саша, я там дочитала, да, это его проблема, он провинился.
Мы не должны никогда преследовать клиента за его успехи.
Иначе это будет про нашу зависть.
Если у него есть успехи, он там оказался на встрече с президентом или у него родился ребенок,
знаете, есть такое понятие форс-мажора и обыкновенной человечности.
Или если у меня клиент едет куда-то на похороны, да, и у него кто-то умер, не дай бог.
У меня нет такого, да, что все, ты мне обязана платить.
Есть понятие обыкновенной человечности, это не про спасение.
То есть каждый уровень, на каждом уровне мы решаем самостоятельно, как мы это делаем.
И вы понимаете, иногда есть порушение границ, тогда нет, тогда, пожалуйста, сплотите.
Когда вы чувствуете, что где-то брашут, а иногда есть просто жизнь.
Это понятно?
В относительно профессионального, понятно?
Добре, а зараз найголовне. Я це обожнюю.
Психологичный рівень контракту.
Навіщо ви насправді там?
Це про те, що люди не говорять.
Це про підсвідомі очікування.
Что это означает?
Это то, что мы сегодня с самого начала говорили.
Вы до меня на социальном уровне обратились рассказать о том, что вас не выходит,
или чего вы боитесь.
А на психологическом уровне вы обратились ко мне до нормализации, до поддержки.
До чего-то того, что даст вам энергию для взросления.
Это понятно.
И люди всегда смотрят на психологический уровень контракта.
Что от меня на самом деле хотят?
Да, да.
Почему к мне пришел этот клиент?
Что он от меня хочет?
Чи он хочет что-то от меня, чи нет?
Сейчас, на 4 минуты, отрефлексуйте,
чи умеете вы бачите свой психологичный уровень контракта.
И если есть какие-то особенности относительно административного контракта,
Юля, может, не на 4, а может, немного больше, на 5.
Подумайте, что вы хотите проговорить.
Или цена, или время, или что-то то, что вас больше волнует.
Это понятно?
На 5 минут психологический уровень контракта,
если вы его видите, и административное, то, что вас волнует.
Поверните, пожалуйста, слайд про психологическое.
Добрый день, по двое людей, 5 минут комнаты.
По двое, да, да.
Створю.
Можете заходить.
Нужно заходить.
Можете еще раз секунду слайд показать?
А вы сейчас зайдете из своей группы и вы проговорите то, что нужно.
Нужно проговорить, что на самом деле вы умеете схватывать информацию
из другого человека, как психологическое
потребление.
я почему нас кто-то не приеду на все вы тут да то есть там приедутся
юрий и катя и оксана на заходы переформуют
Хочется себе еще часа на все это.
Часа больше не хватает на все.
Да.
Так, до меня приехал курьер с квитами, я сейчас вернусь, хорошо?
Да, хорошо.
Хорошо, сейчас.
Для себя что-то занотовали интересное?
Про цену договорились на 100 миллионов сексильонах?
А цену вы себе вказали?
Снежан, слушаю.
Да, мы забыли про административный поговорить.
Очевидно, там все добре.
Мы про психологичный с моей партнеркой поговорили.
И у меня, знаете, такая, Влада, запытание.
А как правильно створить этот психологический контракт?
Задать вопрос, что на самом деле ты от меня хочешь получить?
Нас в коучинг-хабе учили, скажи, пожалуйста, любым клиентам, как ты хочешь, чтобы я проявлялась как коуч, это туда?
Да, но я думаю, что тут нужно просто прямо спросить, что ты бы хотела от меня получить, от меня на самом деле.
Но это означает, Снежана, что мне скажут, что от меня хотят получить поддержку, нормализацию, валидацию, то есть свою собственную ценность.
Люди нигде не понимают. Ваша задача — понимать, что под этим стоят.
Угу, угу.
Была ответственность?
И главное будет самая эффективность в том, как выполняется этот психологический контракт.
Да, Олена слушаю.
Ну, я же могу, например, как в вашем первом примере, да, про лидера, который хочет признание,
Я же могу, например, сказать, что, там, можно ли я поделиться с тобой, как я это слышу?
Это про признание мы сейчас говорим, или нет?
Про ценность. Не признание, а ценность.
Подсветить, поддержать.
Ну, то есть, грубо говоря, я могу задавать вопросы, чтобы понять, какая его потребность сейчас, да, и в чем его ценность, правильно?
Да, да, ну, там, если он не говорит об этом, то просто спрашивайте, но где-то себе занотовать, хорошо?
Это понятно?
Это то, что не проговорится.
Смотрите, психологический уровень контракта, это означает, что на самом деле стоит за этим запросом и какую потребность люди хотят от вас получить и удовлетворить.
Юль.
Хотела уточнить, то есть, эти все разные виды контракта, о которых мы сейчас поговорили, административные, профессиональные, психологические,
мы все устанавливаем на первой ознакомленной сессии или до нее.
Только на ней.
Нет, если у вас есть такая история, что у вас есть за много времени,
но я говорю, что мой время имеет свою цену.
Все, что мы хотим узнать, мы про это говорим на первой встрече.
И еще, как докупаться до этого психологического контракта?
Потому что тут мне немножко сложно понять в этом вопросе.
Послушать другую женщину, что она хочет от тебя понять. Например, сейчас вы хотите от меня понять ясность, что нужно делать, но на самом деле психологический уровень контракта, это дать вам поддержку, что вы смелые, что вы понимаете, что вы пойдете и будете работать. Вот это и психологический уровень контракта.
так и лера я правильно разумею счет психологичный вен может выйти на поверхню в павлий моменты
часа может не но с прикладой из бишь предмет но на приклад в коучингу я хочу там бельше
прачевать им иначе кто-то говорим и говорим о лица одно сквозить постельно там в каждой
и другой фразе ресурс и мы можем повернуть это и это будет психологическим контрактом но умовно
кажучи слушайте хочешь про мету про цели про там досягнение аллея чую и про ресурс че цены в ту
историю а психологичный ревань контракту означает так я бачусь а зараз тубе на высочай а сын да
цель я разумеет и контракт официальный вен выглядая так хочу працюва ты хочешь досягти
этой цели, но я подсознательно чувствую, слышу от тебя, ты всегда хочешь получить какой-то ресурс, то есть
когда ты хочешь получить этот дополнительный ресурс, что это означает для тебя? Ну и затем сверка, куда дальше
нужно посмотреть в большинстве, ну это я же сверить, супер. То ресурс, возможно, я твой ресурс, да, о чем я не ресурс,
Хороший ресурс, хорошая ресурс, давай тогда себе ознакомимся, что я тоже есть твоим ресурсом, да, то есть, час провести, отрефлексовать, побудить, что есть для тебя этим ресурсом.
И нехай тогда людина говорит, что есть ресурсы.
Хорошо?
Класс.
Вы велики, молодцы.
Склайд повертаю сейчас.
Еще раз.
Посмотрите, что есть с психологическим контрактом.
Это понятно.
Рада это слышать.
Идем дальше.
Есть такая история, когда контракты не будут работать.
Это называется сценарный контракт.
Что это за штука?
Как вам на ней не попасться?
Смотрите.
Есть родственный контракт.
То есть я должен что-то делать, потому что так нужно.
Я могу что-то делать, потому что так нужно.
Это понятно? Никогда не будет работать.
Контракт на смену других.
Сделай так, чтобы он...
Фокус не на себе, а на контроле внешнего средства.
То есть я хочу заменить кого-то другого.
Это не работает.
Следующий – это игровой контракт.
То есть, когда вас просят сделать выбор так, чтобы эта компания или эта людина уничтожалась.
То есть, поддержать ее несчастливый сценарий.
Например, взять кредит на 100 миллионов, который он никогда не отдаст.
АБО ВЗЯТЕ НА РОБОТУ КОХАНКУ В HR-ВИДДЕЛ, ЯКА ЗРОЙНОЮСЬ ОРГАНИЗАЦИЮ.
ЦЕ ЗРОЗУМИЛО, ШО Я ТАКИМ ИГРОВЫМ КОНТРАКТОМ.
ТОПТО ПИТВЕРДИТЬ МИНИ, БУДЬ ЛАСКА, ТЕ, ЧО БУДЕТ ДЛЯ МЕНЕ ПОГАНО.
И наступный – это вечный контракт.
Очень интересная штука для тех, кто любит быть досконалым.
Я сможу быть только тогда, когда полностью что-то сделаю.
То есть никогда.
Я пойду и буду делать то только тогда, когда то.
Вечный контракт на те, что не работают.
Если что-то работает, где-то работает, то оно работает уже сегодня.
Это понятно?
Повторение.
Какие четыре вида контракта не работают?
Кто что запомнил?
София, слушаю.
Бачу, шо перша там сценарні, батьківський контракт, коли для підтвердження болю якогось, на відкладання життя, вічний контракт, да?
Вічный контракт, добре.
А, и на зміну інших, все.
Супер.
Так, Олена?
Ну, я сказала бы, ты сама, София, все сказала, дуже добре.
Молодці, молодці.
Лера? Все? Руки опустили. Молодцы.
Добре, идем дальше. То, что важно.
Классное вопрос, когда мы начинаем вообще вкладывать в другую контракт.
Знаете почему? Мы можем понять их сценарий.
Это так интересно.
Смотрите, когда ты вкладываешь контракт в другую людину,
ты можешь сделать уже ее диагностику.
По-перше, че людина дозволяй соби бажати?
Якщо людина не може сказати, шо вона хоче, вона не дозволяй соби бажати.
Че може сам зрозумити, шо він може змінюватися?
Або тільки адаптується?
ЧИ МОЖЕТ СКАЗАТЬ Я ХОЧУ? ЧИ ШУКАЕТ ДОЗВОЛО?
ЧИ ЧЕКАЕТ ЧЕГОСЬ, ЧТО ЕЕ ХТОСЬ ВЫТЯНЕТ АБО РОБИТЬ САМА?
И что несет этот контракт страх, такую осторожность или какой-то протест.
То есть этот контракт, он как лакмус.
То, что человек, как он установляет и записывает для себя этот контракт,
это говорит и про ее сценарий.
Это понятно?
Сейчас, поедали в тройки.
На 6 минут, по 2 минуты на каждого.
Проговорим, можете ли вы сказать другим, что вы хотите.
Чи вы адаптуетесь, чи ви не адаптуетесь.
Оцей слайд, який був до цього, по 2 хвилинки на кожного обговорим.
Чи можу я бажати, чи можу я зминяватася, чи можу я сказати, шо я хочу.
Чи беру я на себе відповідальність, чи чекаю, шо за мене хтось щось зробить.
и какие у меня в целом стиль поведения.
Обережный, не обережный, смелый.
Кто-то там у нас горит, как сверничок, да, и пылает.
Кто-то нам там молчит, ничего не может сделать.
6 минут в двоечках.
В двоечках и в троечках.
В троечках, в троечках так лучше.
Нехай люди почувствуют один одного.
Это же страшнее сказать на трех, что я хочу.
Давай, челлендж.
Супер, подъедаетесь.
Оксана, я вас уже також могу подъединивать, итак?
Юль, я сейчас, я сейчас вернусь, потому что доставляю эти квиты, которые мне отправили, да, Настя, да, да, и они где-то там рядом, сейчас я пойду и встречу, я вернусь.
Юлю.
Вы уже тут?
Ой, я как красава.
Да, скажи.
Боже, вот поделитесь, я вам покажу, это я вся тут в этом букете.
Бачите, вертиши за нами.
Класс, а вам их достаточно.
Я тоже, дякую, тоже, тоже, тоже, тоже.
Зараз вот сяду сюда и поставлю себе его.
Вот тут.
Там вот все будет.
Так.
Пидбера, знаете, пидсук, не бачите?
Да.
Я вам зараз покажу, я хаян.
Ой, заходим, заходим.
Давай, сиденько.
Ой, Боже, и Мэрлин сюда идет.
Люха, ты також до меня пришла?
Витаю, Мэрлину.
Давай, присоединяйся к котику.
Давай, да.
Девчата, привет!
Смотрите, меня уже как учительку отзначили, вашу академию отправили. Я всем покажу, знаете, смотрите, я такая маленькая, и это больше за меня.
Видите, видите, скажите, красиво, очень?
Да, красиво.
У меня еще есть кишечка, я очень благодарна, очень благодарна, очень-очень.
Не знаю, что роскошнее, вы или троянды.
вот только так то есть рубицкий мини скриншот
все хороши так и посмеяюсь 3-4 супер
боже собака слякалась и все слякались добрый зараз а че я и кисть питания все
Я потом научусь это сохранить. Я не такая еще продвинутая пользователь.
Относительно сценария и относительно того, что можете вы это все делать, желать, хотеть, сказать, какие-то про себя инсайты
злове ли добрая вот таким чином вы и диагносту и ты ищешь и дам модель а так
Так. Что важно? Давайте поговорим про то, что есть сценарий, как это нам помогает работать с контрактом. Мы будем про это более детально говорить дальше на наших семинарах.
Но сценарий – это неизвестный план жизни, который сформирован в детстве, как психологическая договорность между родителями и детьми. Это контракт. Это контракт между родителями и детьми.
В сценарии всегда есть, где и как я помру, чего я никогда не сделаю, что я буду делать часто, как я буду жить, как я буду ставиться к себе и другим.
Это означает то, когда мы начинаем работать с собой и с другими, что в сценарии то, что человек должен делать с собой, он будет делать с организацией.
Это понятно или нет?
Это хорошо. Рада это слышать.
То есть это какое-то неосознанное решение.
А контракт, когда мы начинаем об этом говорить, дает нам возможность это все изменить.
То есть сделать то, что не явно, явным.
И работать так, чтобы наш сценарий был таким, он-он.
Горно. Смотрите, на что еще нужно обратить внимание.
Покажу сейчас. Очень классная вещь. Собе занотуйте.
Знаки прихованных контрактов.
То есть, когда люди работают в команде и они формулируют свои желания без обязанностей.
Это прихованный контракт на невыполнение того, что хочет организация.
То есть, когда человек говорит, я попробую, возможно, если выйдет.
Единственное, когда вы можете сказать, я попробую, только тогда, когда вы тестуете какую-то еду.
Все другое, или так, или нет.
Знаете почему?
Потому что, когда вы говорите «я попробую», вы не достигнете этой цели.
Когда другое говорит «я попробую», это означает, что возможно не будет изменений.
Олена, слушаю.
Вот знаете, я вспомнила, у меня подлежащая была.
И вот она всегда так сказала.
Анечка, пойди, сделай. Я спробую. Я говорю, не надо попробовать. Пойди и сделай.
Помнится. Для меня лично вот эта фраза, я постараюсь, я попробую, это не про что. Для меня все
очень просто, или так, или нет. Не нужно мне сказать, я когда-нибудь попробую, это не работает. Скажите мне, пожалуйста,
Я это сделаю или нет? Все. Это понятно? Это не будет работать, когда вам напишут контракт, я попробую изменить себя или команду, или что-то другое. Не сработает.
Да, отстань. А у нас, знаете, в транзакционных аналитиках, эта фраза «я попробую» или «я постараюсь», она звучит для нас, как нас немножко послали.
У нас, в общем-то, есть такие драйверы, я вам про это буду рассказывать, стараться.
Ну, как мне сказали, ты пошел ты, ты пошла ты, знаете, вот так, между нами я вам это говорю.
Это очень-очень плохая вещь.
Хотите играть со мной в игру?
Почему не можно сказать, я попробую?
Кстати, я сейчас проявлю свою идентичность не как транзакционный аналитик, а гипнолог.
А хотите?
Я покажу вам, как работают, в общем-то, слова.
Заплющите очки все.
Ничего страшного будет, все будет в кайф.
Заплющите очи, отпустите.
Уявите себе двери.
Будь какие двери.
Опишите мне эти двери.
Или скажите себе, что эти двери выглядят так.
Я не знаю, как это сказать, как к вам обратиться.
Заплющите очи, пожалуйста.
Просто, если вы не делали эту работу, это будет прикольно для вас.
Уявите двери.
Проговорить, как выглядят эти двери для себя.
Открыть двери, расплющить очи.
Видите, сразу открыла, это хорошо.
Это классно.
Смотрите, сейчас одна минута, куда-то внимание на что-то другое.
На шторы, на, я не знаю, на котов.
Так, зараз ново. Заплющить очи. Уявить двери. Опишить, будь ласка, ці двери. А зараз старайтесься, намагайтесься, дуже сильно намагайтесься, спробуйте відкрыти, відчинити ці двери.
И когда вы пытаетесь, может, когда-то у вас это выйдет, когда вы это сделаете, расплющатся очи.
Но много раз пытайтесь.
Как вы?
Все нормально? Все хорошо?
Пытались?
Попробовали?
Понятно, гораздо тяжелее, потому что оно не работает. Если я пробую, я никогда этого не сделаю.
Знаешь, я в конце результата махнула рукой, обернулась и открыла очки.
Вот такие инсайты.
Я говорю, я всегда, как гипнотерапевт, нужно использовать именно эти фразы,
которые помогают нам взрослеть, да, то есть помогают нам изменяться.
Не нужно говорить, как усердно, не нужно говорить, так я это сделаю,
або я не сделаю. Я очень люблю честных людей, не нужно мне брехать.
Не можете сделать, скажите, нет, я вас и таким принимаю.
Это нормально, это окей, но не нужно говорить, что вы пытаетесь.
Хорошо. У нас осталось 2 минуты до перерыва. Какие у вас есть вопросы?
Да, София слушает.
Мне очень интересно, как вы объединяете все ваши роли, и, как вы сказали, и гипнотерапевты,
я увидела, что вы еще сексолог и так далее, и транзактный аналитик, и я так понимаю, что это не все.
Вы в работе используете это и вообще в вашем оппозиционировании, оно у вас складывается в единую картину?
А как же, смотрите, знаете, когда у вас есть много инструментов для работы, вам не нужно сказать, что у вас есть все.
Вас люди как хотят, так и видят, но если вы что-то умеете, вы видите, что сейчас это будет в порядке, например, я вам показываю, как элементы работают в слове, это про гипнотерапию, это про гипно, это про правильное формулирование слов в целом.
Я использую это. Как поединять роль? Она единственная. Это я. Какие я беру инструменты? Это моя особенность. Я использую то, что лучше для моего клиента.
То есть, когда я с ним общаюсь, я использую гипнотерапию для изменения его подсознанности, как и с вами это я делаю, на благо других людей.
Экологично.
Когда мне задают некоторые вопросы, я знаю на них ответ.
То есть, я беру ответы как из шкатулки, как из сундука, да, относительно того, что меня спрашивают.
Или дала я ответ, София, на ваши вопросы?
Я, наверное, знаете, думаю, с привода позиционирования,
то есть вы главные позиционирования делаете как психолог, правильно?
Потому что она сейчас психотерапевт.
Да, психолог, психотерапевт, но я работаю с руководителями компании,
там больше я работаю как коуч, да,
потому что меня же не называют,
они приглашают психолога работать в компании.
Больше это коучинг, он так называется,
или я корпоративный психотерапевт, но никто не любит ходить к психотерапевту,
поэтому называют ментором. Кто хочет, тот и так и называет, мне все равно, чтобы я имела классный результат,
а я его имею. А сейчас я с вами в идентичности тренерки.
Добре. Відпочинок. До зустрічі в 46 хвилин.
есть какие-то вопросы? Нет? Хорошо. Как вы мне нравитесь, это же классно, что вы у меня такие интересные,
что мы будем с вами делать? Классно. Я думаю, что я вам расскажу такое что-то интересное,
Такое, что интересно. Как мы что делаем? Смотрите, очень просто и очень интересно.
Контракты, вы уже поняли, есть равные, есть разные. Можно и всегда нужно вкладывать контракты на обучение, на супервизию.
Вы же будете дальше учиться проводить супервизию?
Да?
Да.
Давайте я вас подготовлю, у меня есть очень классная
история.
Контракт с ментором и супервизором, то есть, что я хочу исследовать,
какой запрос я буду приносить, как мы будем работать вместе
и какие есть ожидания.
Этот контракт может быть и для вас, как для ментора,
как к супервизору, как к работе, так и к... Вы сами можете формировать такие контракты.
То есть, всегда, когда идете к другим, сразу начинайте разговаривать с вашими разговорами,
с вашими ожиданиями. Это понятно? И к супервизору также.
Вот приходите, говорите, хочу ты, ты, ты. Можете мне дать? Так, делайте, пожалуйста, давайте.
Контракт, есть контракты на социальный контроль, и он, этот контракт может быть в коллективе. Что это означает? Например, вас приглашают на такую роль, когда есть какой-то хаос в команде, и вам нужно быть фасилитатором, который помогает договориться в команде один с одним.
Або вы приходите, смотрите на эту команду, думаете, чего ей не достаточно,
або они утомились, або им сложно, або они не понимают, або есть какой-то харассмент.
И вы начинаете работать с ними, то есть социально контролируете других людей
и даете фидбэк к руководству.
Что это помогает? Снижать тревогу, дать более прозорые роли, вернуть до ответственности тех людей, которые должны ответить и формировать доверие.
Для тех, кто, например, будет работать с аграми, такими, знаете, такими злыми людьми, можно сформировать такой контракт, да, каким можно допомогти. Я беру на себя обязанность отрабатывать свои агрессивные поведения на встречах. Это для тех CEO, владельцев бизнеса, которые не могут быть спокойными.
И не вести, смотрите, это прям кейс из реального жизни, сейчас я вам его покажу, у меня есть один руководитель, который очень злой, и он очень любит переписываться и писать своим подлеглим,
Вспомните, когда? Только в выходные и только после 21-го. Как работать с этой человеком? Мы с ним сформулировали контракт, что он берет на себя обязанность держаться от этой агрессии на встречах, то есть хвалить других людей, сказать что-то доброе, не вести листы после 21-го и приходить на работу в твердом состоянии, а и не под кайфом.
Да, потому что иногда и так
есть какие-то процессы
относительно того,
это я вас для всех
так и сделала, знаете,
общий контракт, например,
если вы будете работать с CEO,
помогите ему не только
сформировать контракт,
но и дать психотерапевтическую
поддержку, если она ему нужна.
Если вы видите, что он не умеет
контролировать свою агрессию,
есть какие-то проблемы с прошлым,
дайте ему возможность и это попроцевать,
Вы должны быть в контакте с психотерапевтом, с психиатром, на всякий случай, даже в организациях, это очень важно. И иметь такой небольшой уровень безопасности для себя, то есть защищать себя через сотрудничество с другими людьми, с другими профессионалами.
Хорошо. Если вы видите, что вы не справились, что-то вам сложно, перевозите эту людину к кому-то другому.
Або если есть какие-то психиатрические проблемы, на это также нужно делать легкий натяк.
Как это делать? Хотите, я научу?
София, да.
Но когда кто-то сидит, знаешь, в фантазиях таких, которые не совпадают с реальностью,
или начинает рассказывать на встрече, или он пришел к вам под кайфом. Также есть такие кейсы,
люди не всегда понимают, знаете, у нас такой темп жизни очень быстрый, что иногда руководители,
они могут использовать допинги для того, чтобы много работать. София, что такое я себе говорю,
это реальное жизнь, я вам говорю про реальные кейсы. Как вам работать с человеком,
который пришел к вам под допингом и это не кава, нужно остановить эту встречу.
Это нужно сделать, потому что не будет нормальных...
Слово допинг очень экологично, так, я же не буду вам сказать что-то такое, ну, я же выкладочка, понимаете?
Это мои идентичные средства.
Поэтому остановите эти встречи, потому что эта сессия, она не будет работающая.
Попередьте, пожалуйста, если у кого-то есть какая-то зависимость с руководителями или в компании,
Попередьте, пожалуйста, скажите так, для того, чтобы наша встреча была очень эффективной,
я вас прошу, пожалуйста, всегда приходите ко мне на встречу в добром состоянии, в хорошем состоянии.
И если вам нужно отменить эту встречу, или вы можете быть под, я сказала прямо своим руководителям,
Кажет, я вас не буду с вами працевать, когда вы приходите до меня в состоянии алкогольного, наркотичного спьянения.
Это небезопасно для меня и для вас.
Не будет результата ни для компании, ни для ничего.
Поэтому нужно найти слова и остановить. Это первое.
Потом, как понять, что нужен психиатр?
Психиатр может быть нужен тогда, когда в компании могут происходить суициды.
И вам нужно, это возможно, как такая история, ее также вам могут ввести на работу, сказать,
«Добре, у меня есть специалист, который поможет, я не знаю, какая была история,
руководитель подлеглый на высшем уровне в одной компании, он сделал суицид, пробу, пробу суицида.
И его прямо до меня привели, да, как работать с ним дальше для того, чтобы сделать валидацию, нормализацию, то у вас всегда должен быть в пакете какой-то знакомый, психиатр, если это экстренная какая-то ситуация, а вас попросили, потому что вы как-то, да, там, возможно, обратиться на это, ну, там, обратиться, работать, побудет, побудет нормализовать.
То если вы понимаете, что это не ваша компетентность, скажите, у меня есть лучший руководитель, лучший профессор, который хорошо с ним проработает.
И переориентируйте эту людину на психиатра, как на медикаментозную поддержку.
Если, например, дам ответ, София, на это вопрос, как понять, что у него что-то не так.
Вот есть такое чувство, что что-то не так.
Вот что-то не очень доброе, вам начинают говорить про голоса какие-то, про связки какие-то, про что-то такое, что не относится ни к корпоративной культуре, ни к чему-то другому.
За этим нужно следовать, и это может быть загострение в весенне-осенний период.
Это загострение психологических расходов.
Поэтому, скажите, уровень моей компетенции не может мне позволить сейчас работать с вами.
Потому что лучше идти куда-то, чем остаться.
Это также про безопасность.
або залучить другого специалиста. Это понятно?
Так, Олена, слушаю.
Я слышала, что среди руководителей, владельцев топов, есть много нарциссистических личностей.
Это так? И как с ними работать?
Вы знаете, единственное, о чем я сожалею, что я не могу передать вам весь опыт,
Потому что на самом деле среди руководителей есть и нарциссы, и пограничники.
Это те клиенты, с которыми вам придётся работать.
И возможно, возможно, если вдруг будет у вас такой запрос,
хотя бы, ну знаете, основную конву, как работать с этими людьми,
запросите, пожалуйста, организаторов.
Если у них будет возможность, я добавлю вам.
Но это вызов.
Сидите на реале жизни.
Ну, в общем, это определенное расстройство личности,
с которыми стоит держать границы
и хорошо хотя бы работать,
хотя бы знать технику безопасности язык.
На жаль, не сможет зараз вам это расповести.
Давайте я пройду до дуже классной истории
относительно контрактов, что я хотела вам сказать.
Сейчас ищу.
Смотрите, есть формальные и неформальные договоры.
Что это означает?
Мы уже об этом говорили.
Формально, письмово, чётко говорено, за договоренностью.
Неформально, те, что есть, какие выникли в процессе.
Также их легализуйте, проговорюйте.
Проговорюйте, завжди, чтобы увидели новое, говорите про это.
Что-то не понимаете, говорите про это.
Будьте смелыми завжди, задавайте такие вопросы.
«Че правильно я вас разумею?», «Че правильно я бачу, шо курс зменився?»,
«Че правильно я це разумею?» и отримайте подтверждение.
Когда угода не работает, шо мы робимо?
Показываю.
Каждая договорность должна иметь план А, план Б и план С.
Сегодня вы задавали мне вопрос, кто вы за идентичностью.
Я вернусь назад. Не волнуйтесь. Если нужно закрыть гештальт, сделайте фото. Я подожду.
А теперь переходим к тому, что есть.
Каждая договора и каждая работа, она должна быть вам проподобна через несколько шляхов.
Как вы думаете, что означает, как можно отразить победителя от проигравшего?
ваши пытания о вашей думке ваши думки
победитель никогда не и даже если он упал он все равно становится с колен то есть он
не перестает пытаться уже с другим подходом до с предыдущим опытом дойти к своей цели классно
А как можно отличить хорошего коуча от плохого коуча?
Хороший коуч, мне кажется, найдёт суть клиента и увидит её,
и с помощью неё вместе с ним простроит это видение результата,
что для тебя будет победа не для кого-то конкретно для тебя чего ты истинно хочешь
отлично а теперь я вам скажу очень важная вещь если вы хотите быть хорошим коучем у
вас должно быть как минимум несколько вариантов работы с этим клиентом я называется план a b c
несколько вариантов победитель это тот который имеет несколько вариантов решения
одного и того же вопроса.
Это не значит, что он упал, свалился,
потом встал. Да, это тоже одна из его
стратегий. Это не означает, что
переможец, он упал, и потом встает,
и все, и он работает.
Переможец это тогда, когда у тебя
есть несколько планов,
как ты будешь
работать с одним
и тем запятом
со своим клиентом.
Часом вы научитесь
видеть клиентов и понимать,
я могу с ним работать,
тремя разными направлениями.
Это означает, что план B, когда план А не сработал,
мы идем к плану B.
Это понятно?
Всегда на любую историю ищите несколько решений вопросов.
А как понять, что план А точно не сработал, что уже пора переходить к плану Б?
Задать вопрос.
Задать вопрос тем, с кем вы работаете, как вам сейчас.
Первое, вы чувствуете, что что-то идёт не так.
У вас есть ощущение, что есть тупик.
Тупик – это когда вы не видите, куда дальше идти.
Нет обратной связи, посмотрите, сейчас я вам покажу очень интересный слайд, как вообще есть вот динамика работы.
Мы делаем, а мы працуем вот таким чином, контракт, формуем доверу, спильность, переформатуем контракт,
если нам нужно, и потом действуем, то есть всегда доверяем.
Если у нас что-то, если у нас что-то не произошло, не так, как должно быть, за действием, мы идем к другому плану.
Как мы можем понять, что он не сработал?
Когда есть потеря мотивации, команда не делает.
Есть сигналы, что для людей это не окей.
Есть конфликты.
И уже есть неповага.
И иногда, когда люди уже начинают чувствовать о контакте со своим лидером ссором, протест, страх, после этого ничего не работает, никогда ничего не растет, если есть вокруг много страха.
Вы согласны?
То есть главное, что нужно сделать, сделать атмосферу безопасности.
Есть план антикризовой договора, когда что-то не работает.
Как про это?
Так, Таня, слушаю.
Я хотела спросить, тут под планом Б и С и так далее,
«Что имеется в виду? Реконтракт или другой подход к плану А?»
Другой подход.
Другой подход к плану А.
То есть, если, например, мы говорим, я не знаю, там, про достижение цели.
Мы можем это достигнуть через вопрос.
Мы можем это достигнуть через сотрудничество.
Мы можем достигнуть цели, если мы остаемся и работаем с одной человекой.
То есть, если что-то не работает, мы ищем совсем другой подход.
Но, если, например, в команде кризис.
Что мы делаем?
И вы знаете, что будет сложно.
Мы предупреждаем о том, что иногда будет непросто.
Мы говорим, что иногда у нас, это я вам даже сейчас говорю, у вас будет спад.
Нам нужно договориться, как давать обратный связок, когда что-то не ок.
Это нужно делать с нашими клиентами.
То есть, когда что-то происходит не так, вы не чувствуете энергии, вам нужно поговорить об этом с вашим клиентом.
Сказать, я чувствую, что у нас сейчас нет энергии в нашей работе, что-то не так, скажи мне.
И отрабатывать от него обратный связок.
Або человек может исчезнуть.
Задаете ей вопрос, что все хорошо.
То есть мы это все проговариваем и предупреждаем, что мы работаем так, чтобы давать один одному честный обратный связок и поддерживать один одного.
Есть контракты на безопасность. Переходим сейчас к очень интересной, но закрытой информации.
Контракт психотерапии, как контракт на безопасность, это антисоциальный контракт.
В организациях это называется антивыгорание, антиавария, антизникнение.
Что это означает?
Смотрите, когда каждый из нас был маленьким, мы учились, каждый из нас, как справиться с агрессией.
И в каждого из нас, вас, меня, есть жизненная позиция.
Что это означает?
Как я себя воспринимаю относительно света?
У нас есть несколько жизненных позиций.
Я окей или я не окей?
Скажите, пожалуйста, какая жизненная позиция у вас?
Окей.
У нас есть надежда, что все говорят, что я окей.
Но это не так.
Мы можем думать, что, возможно, у нас позиция «Я окей».
Но подсознательно не считать, что мы окей.
Как это формуется?
Когда вы были маленькими,
напомните, пожалуйста,
когда вы ссорились со своими родителями,
со своей родиной,
вы могли им сказать честно, спокойно,
что мне не нравится в возрасте от 3 до 6 лет?
Не очень.
Нет.
Если вы не могли это сказать, то подсознательно может быть позиция «я не ок» и это означает не то, что вы плохие, что с вами что-то не так, это означает единственное, что когда вы были маленькими, вы научились всю агрессию, которую вы почувствовали в момент сварки с родителями, направлять внутрь, до себя в тело.
И когда у нас стресс, или стресса слишком много, эта агрессия начинает нас уничтожать.
Не то, что мы хотим, но оно так вылезает.
Скажите, пожалуйста, насколько вы сейчас чувствуете стресс в своем жизни от 0 до 10?
10, то максимально.
Так.
9, 7, 7.
Видите, мы живем, ну, там, в кого-то 4, в кого-то 5, да, в кого-то по-разному.
Это не означает, что кто-то там более здоровый или меньше здоровый.
Это означает просто реальность жизни, потому что они очень изменяются.
И когда у нас слишком много стресса, как и у руководителей,
у нас включается выход из стрессовой ситуации.
И мы можем, когда много стресса, убить себя, убить кого-то другого,
или съехать с густого по-разному.
И именно через эти позиции «я окей», «ты окей», «я не окей», «ты окей»
или «я не окей», «ты не окей» формуется то, как мы будем выходить из стресса или кризиса.
И поэтому есть три аварийных лёгких, которые открываются и у руководителей компании, и у нас, когда стресса слишком много.
Когда вы так спокойно сказали «вбить кого-то другого».
Вбить кого-то другого – это также есть, к сожалению.
Как это формуется, сейчас объясню. Это когда дитина маленькая, и она с самого раннего детства, так бывает у руководителей, они начинают, дитина, да, она начинает всю агрессию выкатывать на других людей.
И эта агрессия убивает.
Не завжди.
Чи булава с энергия далі діяте?
Це важко.
І ми як люди, як професіонали, як куче, як керівникім,
ми іноді не справляємось з цим життям.
І частина людей, вона починає вбивати себе.
Інша частина людей починає вбивати інших.
И другая часть просто отходит от реальности и едет с разумом, потому что это безопасно.
Для людей это безопасно.
Поэтому, когда вы начинаете работать с другими людьми, вы можете понять, кто убивает себя.
Знаете, как узнать, как люди себя убивают?
Интересно или нет?
Интересно, может, вам неинтересно.
Вы же пойдете
Працевать в компанию
Интересно, хорошо
Если у руководителей, или у вас, или у людей
Есть плохие привычки
Вот то про допинг
Как я сказала, это про убийство себя
Ездить на
Великой скорости
Руководители тоже это любят
Даже если водители их возят
Они могут ехать там 180 км
Не пристегиваться
это аварийная любовь убить себя. Перепрацовывать, это убить себя. Заставлять
работать всю команду 24 часа на 7, это убить себя и других. Захвореть на невеликовую
то есть понимаете, что ты очень много работаешь, но ты не можешь остановиться и идешь себя ревновать.
Почему это безопасно для психики? Потому что очень сложно бороться с этой психической энергией,
То есть ты не можешь с ней бороться, и люди подсознательно начинают или убивать себя, или убивать других для того, чтобы выплеснуть эту агрессию.
Олен, какие вопросы?
А игромания, это тоже для себя?
Да, убивать себя, игромания, сидеть в компьютерных играх, за много, то есть за очень много, это может быть и про уход с разума, то есть не жить в реальном жизни.
Вы сказали, что это про агрессию, про то, как ее выплеснуть. А как научить человека выплескивать ее безопасно, как-то более в формате эффективном? Не знаю, как это правильнее объяснить. Я думаю, вы поняли.
Я поняла, насколько смогла дать такую ответственность.
Нужно дать осознавать руководителям, что он делает с собой.
Потому что то, что он делает с собой, он делает и с организацией.
Если у него есть открытый люк убить себя, то он убьет себя, помрет раньше всего.
Организация, возможно, помрет.
Я всегда приходю, начинаю свою сотрудничество с того, что я молчу и следую.
и задаю очень много вопросов, что у вас, как оно было, какие у вас истории,
потому что то, что было ранее, самого детства, будет повторено сто раз.
Поэтому нам нужно научиться это делать, нам не нужно сказать, что вы себя убиваете.
Можно и так сказать, тем, кто подготовленный.
Или вы свою агрессию убиваете и других.
Также, если у вас установленный терапевтический, знаете, такой, хороший рабочий альянс,
вот так это называется.
Если вы понимаете, что вы можете это сказать.
Но, если у вас этого нет, вы только себе занотовывайте,
потому что это будет дальше вашей проблемой.
Скажите, пожалуйста,
хотите ли вы общаться с человеком, который умирает?
Нет.
Потому что это страшно.
Сейчас вы понимаете, почему иногда до некоторых людей в компанию идут люди, а почему нет?
Потому что нет жизненной энергии.
Потому что мы присоединяемся к сценарию один к одному.
Если, например, в семье есть женщина, которая спасает своего мужа,
спасает его всю жизнь, а он там, например, ну такой обычный пример, алкоголик, то она убивает себя,
потому что она не выдерживает всю эту агрессию, а он убивает и себя, и ее.
Почему это безопасно? Потому что психика, она не может найти выход, и поэтому за голдингами
открываются эти аварийные люки.
У меня была клиентка,
которая получила большие подвышения,
но в ней открылся аварийный люк
вбить себя.
Не вбить себя, а съехать с разума.
Она 8 раз подходила
к дверям, открывала двери
и смотрела, закрыты ли они или нет.
Поэтому нам
нужно научиться
проговорить такие вещи
безопасно с нашими
клиентами.
Если вы видите,
что есть какие-то истории, связанные с тем, что это вас вызывает тревогу.
Смотрите, когда мы заключаем такие контракты с детониватом,
есть кто-то депрессивный.
Кто-то кого-то... Василия, выключайте микрофон, потому что я слышу.
Я выключаю.
Я кто-то депрессивный, я кто-то с зависимостью, я кто-то с импульсивным поведением, тем, кто себя рискованно поводит, тем, кто не дает о здоровье.
И с теми людьми, которые вы слышите их, они представляют самовыборство или проявляют агрессию.
Нам нужно защитить себя, людей и организацию от того, чтобы это было разрушено, чтобы людина была разрушена.
Как мы это делаем? Мы вербализируем то, что мы видим.
Я вижу, что ты много работаешь. Я понимаю, что это социально вызывает много удобрений от тебя,
от твоих сотрудников, компаний. Но ты согласен, что это убивает тебя?
Да. Иногда SEO говорят, у меня нет отпуска, потому что я мандрую всегда.
Ты согласен, если ты не отдыхаешь, то ты не дашь возможность отдохнуть себе и другим?
Да. Ладно, давай поговорим о том, как создать такой work-life balance,
и ты будешь немного больше пиклеваться и про себя, и про других.
Потому что, когда вы научаете людей пикловать про себя, они начинают обеспечивать других.
Это есть в компетенции коуча?
Вы будете дальше работать с этой компанией.
Вам нужно просто понять, что может быть сценарной динамикой.
То есть, чем это все закончится.
И это не означает, что вы должны делать психотерапию другой человек.
Это означает, что когда вы видите, что где-то что-то разрушается, вы проговорите с другой человеком, с вашим клиентом о том, что я вижу, что ты себя разрушаешь. Давай ты остановишь это.
Вам не нужно дальше ничего делать, вам не нужно проработать это все, вам нужно просто обратить внимание с этичностью, осторожностью и спеклением о развитии этой людины и компании.
Тогда это будет ваша компетенция. Я дала ответ на это вопрос, да или нет? Лера, слушаю.
Да, у меня вопрос. Мы имеем, условно-экологически, про это подсказать, подсветить, но если человек не признает, иногда есть такие аспекты, типа, да нет, это вы что-то там выгадали, оно там не сильно видно.
Пью не много, то так кажется, езжу не быстро, то там нормально, играю не часто, это так же способ расслабиться.
Как действовать в таком случае, когда оно все равно повторяется?
Классное вопрос, нужно сказать.
Я всегда наводжу статистику, если ты, например, за требованиями ВОЗ, ты пьешь каждый день, то это уже алкоголизм.
Я всегда для таких людей, я достаю просто статистику, да, то есть ездить безопасно за правилами 100 километров, 200 это уже небезопасно, согласен? Согласен.
Но кто-то придумал какие-то правила пристегнуть себя, да, а скажи мне, пожалуйста, а ты свою дитину тоже не пристегиваешь? У меня был такой интересный кейс, он говорит, да мне пофиг, я еду 200, что мне, я говорю, а когда у тебя дети? Нет, уже не 200. Добре, то вези себя как дитину.
То есть, это не означает, что мы начинаем давить на эту людину, сказать, я вижу твою проблему.
Мы запытываем, хочешь это изменить? Так. Будешь себя берегти? Так.
Нет? Ну нет.
Но держать себя где-то, как зону взросления, что может быть проблема.
Дала ответ, Лера, на это вопрос?
Хорошо. София?
У меня близко до этого вопроса.
Вот если мы говорили, если мы ничего с этим не делаем, как терапию найдем, например, и он ничего не изменяет,
но, например, это в компании происходит, то тогда как?
Еще раз.
Он это не изменяет. Но у него, например, реальная зависимость. Это не просто что сказал и все.
Это то, что нужно лечить, реально.
Так. И он не хочет изменять. В зависимости от того, с кем ты работаешь, с кем ты работаешь, с кем ты работаешь,
то есть та людина, которая не изменяется, на каком уровне, или СЕО.
СЕО я всегда говорю, скажи, пожалуйста, почему на такой руководственной должности,
как на посаде, находится человек, который себя убивает?
Ты смотрел, следовал за операционной информацией, сколько этот отдел принес тебе прибыли?
Очень быстро наступает озвучивание, прозрение, как я говорю, в людей.
Потому что они начинают смотреть на цифры.
И когда ты смотришь на цифры, ты понимаешь, что есть какая-то проблема, что-то идет не так.
И тогда могут запропоновать то, что мне пропоновали иногда в одной компании.
Или ты можешь попрацевать с этим специалистом.
Продажи офигенные, просто космос.
Не может ее освободить.
Но есть проблема. Поможешь? И вы можете дальше переадресовать на кого-то другого.
Потому что вы подсвечиваете и честно скажете за контрактом то, что есть на самом деле.
Потому что если кто-то себя убивает, это означает, что этого нет.
Но ваша ответственность про то, если на это обратить внимание или нет.
Так, даю ответы.
И это одна из безопасных дорог.
Добре.
Юрий, у меня к вам единственное вопрос.
Вы знаете, после какой скорости уже не можно врятовать жизнь?
Не знаю.
Тогда я вас сейчас просвечу.
150 километров на день уже ничего не остается ни от вас, ни от других.
И даже если вы такие крутые, и я действительно считаю, что вы крутые, вы уверены в себе, как в воде, скажу отвертно, возможно, вы в себе уверены, но в других не будьте таким уверенным.
Потому что когда есть весна, есть осень, или есть какой-то стресс, я не знаю, кто живет в Киеве, посмотрите, пожалуйста, иногда бывают там стрессы, и я не люблю выезжать в следующий день на дорогу,
Потому что люди какие-то не от света этого. Я могу быть очень классной водикой, очень красивой водой, но кто-то не в таком классном состоянии находится.
Поэтому, когда мы выезжаем на дорогу, нам нужно следовать и быть осторожным, как до себя, так и до других.
За других я не могу носить ответственность. Но если дестресс, мой мозг, он отдыхает.
он не увидит других людей. Так происходит, к сожалению, авария. Так, далее, может ли SEO убивать компанию, чтобы спасать себя? Нет, обычно, если посмотреть на SEO, если он разрушает себя, то он может в будущем разрушить компанию.
Как это происходит? Он увык много работать, он будет требовать много работы от своих подлежащих.
Подлежащие будут иметь много агрессии, будут выгореть, даже если они будут освобождаться, они сделают плохую репутацию.
Понимаете? И поэтому с временем эта компания может умереть, к сожалению.
Чем может SEO говорить информацию про сотрудников? В зависимости от того, с кем вы работаете, с кем у вас контракт. Если у вас контракт с SEO, то вы говорите и работаете с SEO. Если у вас контракт с подлеглыми, то вы тогда работаете с подлеглыми.
Если вас берут в организацию, нужно разделять SEO и подлежащих.
Если вы работаете с SEO, вы не можете работать с подлежащими.
Если вы хотите, или иногда происходит, что вы коучите подлежащих,
сделали тренинг, вы также говорите, что вся информация,
которая будет надана тут, она конфиденциальная
относительно уровней в организации.
Я вам сейчас покажу, как работать с трехсторонними контрактами,
когда есть кто-то еще, вас нанимают.
Чи я вам дала
в ответ на вопрос, что иногда
что-то может быть не так.
И просто для себя
это нужно следовать,
конфронтироваться, если есть такая потребность,
и сказать, что я
волнуюсь, обижаюсь про вас,
но нужно
сохранить себя.
На что я обратил внимание и на что рекомендую вам обратить внимание.
Смотрите, какие есть триггеры.
Это план Б, план С с людьми, когда им плохо.
Нужно научить людей сообщать вам, когда им становится тяжело.
проговорить триггеры, которые могут убивать или запускать открытие этих аварийных люков.
Не выспалась, не наелась, посварилась.
Всегда створить список поддержки, как для себя, так и для других.
То есть ритуалы, действия, то, что будет вас поддерживать.
И сделать паузу до того времени, пока вы не почувствуете снова или они не почувствуют снова эту энергию.
Это понятно?
Втомились, мои хорошие, да, уже?
Передоз информации.
Как я вас поддерживаю?
Очень-очень сильно.
Есть ли у вас какие-то вопросы относительно этого?
Нет?
Есть?
Все нормально.
Ну, тримайтеся, еще трошечки, еще трошечки я с вами побуду.
Смотрите, как я учусь на уровне не руководителей, а, ну, проговорю некоторые вещи, да,
как можно вообще, как можно вообще про это говорить экологично, да, как коуча.
Если я чувствую, что я потеряю сенс в работе, я не возьму лекарственные мовки, да,
особенно если есть дедлайны.
Я проговорю про это с лидером
или с HR.
Я выбираю остаться в живых
отношениях, а не идти
в эмоциональный изолятор.
Потому что страшнее, когда люди
перепрацевали, может быть
и очень плохая история.
Например, самоубийство в организациях.
И главное,
чтобы вы до этого не были причастны.
То есть, когда вы видите, что у кого-то кризис, вы сразу информируете других и говорите, что я вижу, что тут человек выгорает, я вижу, что у него депрессивный состояние, я прошу обратить на это внимание.
Какие сигналы риска, что в человеке что-то не так, или в руководителе что-то не так, злость на всех подряд, желание освободить всех сразу, потеря веры в бизнес или в себя, игнорирование базовых потреб, ежесон, телесная активность и эмоциональная отстраненность или надконтроль.
Это понятно?
На это все обратите внимание, и если вы будете об этом говорить, будете об этом думать, вы сможете создать еще и другие сенсы, как себя поддерживать. Что для себя главное делать? Давайте я про вас.
Вы можете, если вам тяжело, вы в самих втомлениях, подыхать, погулять, купаться, плавать, кричать, если у вас не очень хороший клиент.
Нагадать про свои опоры, кто вас поддерживал, или как вы проходили это раньше.
Сказать, что я умею, могу.
Или подумать про свои ресурсы.
Давайте, для того, чтобы вам это было интересно, на 5 минут поедем в пары.
И вы расскажите, пожалуйста, как вы себя будете поддерживать в сложных ситуациях.
На 5 минут в парах.
Да, про 2 хваленки я вас делю на двое и приеду к ней.
Подключайтесь.
Давайте, подключайтесь, еще трошки.
я вас распределю вручную зараз
так надо вас не трогаю дякую дякую
кто-то они все по двое дам татьяна ван и вещь л
и лера
татьяна вы с нами
доброте делала но мы переместим
Василий, вы выбрали или не ввели в пару?
А как я могу ввести в пару? У меня мало таких приглашений.
Но, в принципе, лучше меня сейчас пара на это, потому что, если дают поезд, то все будет чуть не шокирующе.
Так, этого раза я прошу.
Хорошо.
А можете открыть презентацию, просить скрин?
Сейчас.
Сейчас, сейчас, сейчас.
Показываю.
Не побачила.
Супер, я сраблю.
эти две штуки можно туда и додаток до материала
как самоподобие, иногда нам этого не хватает, даже сейчас про собственную безопасность, люди
утомляются. Да, я уже тоже вижу, что на самом деле тяжело столько времени быть. Очень, я же говорю, значит
нужно час, час пятнадцать и далее отдых, час пятнадцать и отдых. И какой-то один перерыв, там хотя бы
на 45 минут. Нет, 45 не нужно, потому что будет очень много времени, они расслабятся, а потом они
уйдут. Наш максимум это 20 минут. А, например, между вами и между коучингом?
Можно. 30 минут. То есть перерыв наиболее 30 минут. Кто хотел поесть, он поел, кто хотел попить, он все сделал.
Есть приготовили, потому что много девочек. Что-то сложили, что нужно. И нужно так делать, чтобы они успели продолжать проводить время либо на встрече, либо с семьей.
что будет, например, там обучение 11 месяцев, то есть, чтобы не очень поздно. Они же обучаются и в неделю, и в субботу.
Еще четверг вечером, пятница вечером, неделя, суббота, праздник.
Да, я видела. Хорошо, знаете, что один раз в месяц. У меня вчера у мужчины, он почувствовал, сколько обучаются, он говорит, боже, то это же невозможно.
что они еще работают, а они же работают, да, хоть это один раз на месяц, но все равно это очень тяжело.
Да, у нас программа и большая.
Да, я стал свидетелем вашей разговора, поэтому это интересно, и это действительно, ну, целый день выдержать,
а считая еще другие вещи, то оно действительно чуть-чуть тяжело и расслабляет,
насколько я ресурсный и готова их втягивать, но я с утра еще имел бранч, скажем так, то это было
иначе, то мне сейчас тяжело. Всем тяжело. Я не думаю, Василий, что вы единственный, кому тяжело.
Просто поделюсь. Я стал свидетелем этой разговора. Но я знал, куда иду. Юля это предупреждала сразу,
типа, чуваки, это будет пришел. Я такой, да окей. Я скажу так, это будет очень интересно. Давайте дальше.
Смотрите, то, что я хотела вам еще напомнить о вопросе, если вообще много вам, ну, очень вам тяжело относительно, как себя поддерживать, то это изменение фокуса с провалом на адаптацию.
Что я могу сделать еще сейчас? Как это влияет на меня через 5 дней, 5 месяцев или через 5 лет? И как я могу это перетворить на опыт? Это все за спокойствие. Если у вас есть проблемы, вы себе дайте такую ответственность и вам будет хорошо.
Сейчас переходим к трикутным контрактам. Есть такая штука, трикутные контракты, то есть, когда есть большие силы, то есть организация, есть я, я коуч, и есть ты, другие, с кем вы будете работать.
Может быть, вы придете к нам до тренинга еще куда-то.
То есть нам нужно, когда мы начинаем работать с SEO,
или нас нанимают,
всегда на старте любого проекта
визуализировать такой трикутник.
И это означает, что есть три стороны,
которые принимают участие в этом контракте.
Организатор. Что он замовляет.
Тут вы записываете это,
когда вы работаете с кем-то другим.
можете это написать, если это тренинг, на дождь.
Есть выполняющий, то есть что я делаю.
Организатор хочет сегодня получить такой-то тренинг.
Хорошо, как я буду это делать?
И участники, какие у них есть ожидания от этого тренинга.
Это сегодня то, что я вас запытывала.
И что для вас будет главным?
А что вы от меня хотите отримать?
И структура трикутного контракта нужна для того, чтобы мы озвучили ожидания.
Чтобы не было, знаете, надмирных ожиданий.
Есть длительность контракта.
Сколько мы будем с вами работать?
Озвучение ожиданий.
Что вы от меня хотите?
Как вы? Чему вы пришли сюда?
И чем будете заниматься?
Прояснение ответственности, то есть каждый из нас несет свою ответственность и не перекладываем эту ответственность на других.
И укладываем двусторонний контракт между вами, как ведущими, и участниками.
Чи це зрозуміло? Пронто, пронто. Студентам моим. Да, зрозуміло, так, ладо, так. Добре. Ань, слыхай.
У меня такой вопрос. Если вас нанимает компания для прокачки тренинга, то есть у них есть определенная цель.
Одним предложением, Ань. Вопрос одним предложением. Задайте, пожалуйста.
А этично ли рассказывать SEO о том, что вы знаете у его подчиненных?
Нет, конечно. Я не рассказываю SEO о том, что я знаю об его подчиненных.
У меня есть контракт с организатором, то есть что он от меня хочет получить, и я выполняю его контракт.
Например, в нашем случае организатор Академии, у меня с ней контракт, что я должна вас обучить.
То есть они мне говорят, сколько есть людей, сколько есть студентов, что есть.
У меня есть конкретный контракт с вами, с каждым из вас, как я с вами функционирую.
Буду ли я докладывать информацию SEO-компании? Никогда.
Хорошо, а если SEO, интересно, кто слабое звено?
Это его личная проблема, кто слабое звено.
Вам необходимо отдавать и передавать информацию экологично,
таким образом, чтобы вы не выдали всю информацию, которая есть об этом участнике,
но чтобы вы могли влиять на изменения в этой компании.
А если я вижу потенциал, например, в другом сотруднике, им нужно подсветить?
Тогда вы задаете вопрос таким образом, чтобы подсветить, а не рассказать.
Например, там, Александр какой-то есть проблемным сотрудником.
Мы же говорим в положительном ключе, да, о том, что обратить внимание, вот есть потенциальный сотрудник.
Например, руководитель на него даже…
Нет, не так, нет, не так.
Мы не говорим, обратите внимание на потенциального сотрудника.
Для того, чтобы задавать правильно коучинговые вопросы, они выглядят так.
Кто на вашей точке зрения, по вашей точке зрения является потенциальным сотрудником?
Создайте, пожалуйста, тройку лидеров на это место.
Кто будет из них более эффективным?
Как вы думаете, у кого, если я разговариваю с Сео, какие есть слабые, какие есть сильные стороны?
Таким образом мы формируем его идентичность и восприятие ситуации.
Но мы не решаем вместо него, иначе мы спасаем.
Я дала ответ на вопрос?
Да, да, да. Спасибо, благодарю.
Классно. Я очень рада.
Давайте подведем с вами итоги, что мы сегодня с вами сделали.
Давайте сейчас сделаем подсумки, чем мы сегодня с вами занимались.
Смотрите, мы поговорили, что такое контракт.
Девчата, выключите.
Мы поговорили про разные типы контрактов.
Мы поговорили про сценарные контракты, мы поговорили про разные случаи в контрактах, мы поговорили про прихожие контракты, и мы поговорили про то, когда нам тяжело, угода не работает, и вообще, даже поговорили больше, когда есть какие-то, ну, такие, знаете, подводные камни, есть подводные камни, где команде тяжело.
Идея, как сегодня Аня сказала, слабое звено.
Скажите, пожалуйста, как вы сейчас, что вы с собой возьмете,
как наилучший результат нашей встречи?
Пожалуйста, одно слово.
План А, план Б, план С.
Да, отлично. Дальше.
Все не работает, Люд. Я вообще все не понимаю.
Мне надо конкретно. Я всегда люблю так.
Снежан.
Крутой контракт и план А, план Б.
Дякую, что она нагадала.
Добре, дякую.
Юль.
Про контракты.
Круто.
Что еще?
Знания, контракт, инструмент, контроль над собой.
Инши никто ничего не берет?
Был контракт.
Добре.
Как вы зараз?
Втомились?
Слушайте, я вам опишаюсь.
Вы гении. Я уже Юля сделала видос, сказала, что это гений, гений. Я просто вами захоплюсь.
Очень. Спасибо, что у меня действительно есть любовь к тебе.
Я вас прошу, пожалуйста, научитесь, научитесь с удовольствием.
Бережите себя, пожалуйста, давайте. Тут есть реакции, давайте. Я научилась ставить реакции вообще.
Меня мои организаторы научили. Давайте, будь какую реакцию, кто в каком состоянии сейчас, чтобы я увидела.
Ракеты, да, это круто, сердечки, хорошо. Я очень благодарна вам за доверие, за то, что вы выбрали меня, что вы со мной.
Пожалуйста, бережите себя, обнимаю тех, кто обнимается, а кто не обнимается, просто стою рядом.
До следующей встречи, если есть вопросы, напишите, в следующий раз все будете задавать.
Добре, давайте еще у меня вот такая штука с сердцем, молюсь за вас, бережите себя, на связку, попа.
До встречи, до встречи.
Спасибо вам всем.
Пока, пока.
Боже, какие там мальчишки, какие все, все. Василия, легкой дороги, всем легкой дороги, бережите себя, сил вам.
Всем скажу пока, пока, пока, пока.
такого вы наимоверно дякуем такое мои хорошие дякую чекай уже на наступную застричь буду всех